thank you
hey guys welcome to this front and full
course video
now front-end development is one of the
most commonly heard phrases today now
front-end development is basically the
part of web development that involves
coding and creating the front-end
elements of a website
now the front end is typically what the
end user or the client interacts with
so in this video we're going to be
learning all about front-end languages
and libraries
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our Channel already make
sure to hit the Subscribe button and the
bell icon to never miss an update
so here's what we'll be learning today
first we look at a complete tutorial on
Version Control Systems that is get and
GitHub
once you're familiar with that we'll
move on to understanding the basic
front-end language that is HTML
we'll also look at how to implement HTML
registration forms and build a simple
app using HTML that is the quiz app
moving ahead we look at a detailed
tutorial on CSS after that we'll look at
JavaScript and how to add interactivity
to our web applications
now JavaScript offers some really cool
libraries and Frameworks for front-end
development
so first we learned react.js which is a
JavaScript library and moving ahead
we'll understand how angular is used to
build apps
so now that you know what's in store for
you let's go ahead and Jump Right In
hello this is Matthew from Simply learn
and today we're going to delve into git
and what it actually is and how it fits
within your devops tag so a little
scenario before using it one of the
challenges that a lot of developers and
development teams would have had is
developers would be working on different
types of code whether it's database code
whether it was python or whether it's
java.net and they would have a central
server that they would be pushing all of
their source code in but there was
little or no communication that was
actually going on in between all the
developers you know the challenge you
had with that scenario is that when
people would be checking a code you
could be like you know there'll be
conflicts and you'd have to roll back
different code versions and and this is
really kind of the challenge that git
addresses git is a tool that allows all
of a developers no matter what stack
they're working in to have access to all
of the code and it makes it much more
effective at being able to have
development teams work on small medium
or even massive applications and some of
the biggest applications out there are
managed through a git distributed server
environment so let's jump into what
we'll be covering so you have a clear
understanding of the value that you're
going to get out of watching this
presentation so we're going to go
through devops and the tools have
available for devops we'll talk about
what version control means within a
devops environment and cover the two
different types of Version Control
centralized and distributed and then
we're going to zero in on git which is a
really fantastic distributed version
control system and we're going to go
through and understand the features
workflow branches and commands in git
we're going to give you a demo and then
summarize all the activities at the end
of the the presentation so what is
devops well this is one of my favorite
questions I love the idea of what devops
is so devops really is a culture of
being able to deliver Solutions faster
where your development teams and your
operation teams work effectively
together the idea is to be be able to
continuously build out Solutions and
have testing codes that's built into
your Solutions so that no matter where
they are in the stage of the integration
and deployment life cycle they're always
being tested and you can always have
code being ready to be released out the
idea is that instead of having big
releases that you'd have maybe once
every two weeks or once a month that you
would actually have a continuous stream
of releases because you always have code
that has been tested you have your
network that's been tested you have your
environment being tested and you'll be
able to provide feedback directly to the
appropriate person whether they're in
debts or whether they're in arts to be
able to be successful at being able to
deliver Solutions faster the bottom line
your Dev team things like operations and
your operations team begin to fill and
think like developers it's really a
fantastic way of being able to speed up
delivery and have your team just think
and feel and act in a different cultural
environment so let's have a look at some
of the tools that are available to you
in Dev devops environment if we look at
devops it's really kind of split into
two areas the dev side you have building
code planning and testing and then on
your upside you have release deployment
operating and monitoring but the tools
really all interact with each other and
what's really great is that the tools
are either open source or very very low
in cost and in fact most of the tools
you're seeing in front of you right now
are open source tools which means
there's no licensing to you and you can
actually effectively manage them and
Implement them within your team right
now so let's have a look at some of the
dev tools that you have for doing code
versioning and so some of the tools that
you may have used in the past include
subversion team Foundation serves and
git these are all different types of
Version Control software that you have
out there one of the oldest ones is
subversion it's a centralized Version
Control System it's one of the tools I
used years ago it really is good at
doing what it's supposed to do which is
just a very simple version controlled
solution it's open source so it's free
there's no licensing there are
challenges with working with it because
it is a centralized tool rather than a
distributed tool we'll get into that in
a little bit but for a very basic
Version Control System you know it does
what you wanted to do team Foundation
Service Solutions something that many of
you in Microsoft world may have been
using for a long time and the thing
that's great about TFS is it's built
right into the Microsoft environment
it's the server side the services side
of building out your Solutions with
Microsoft just recently in the last
couple of weeks at the beginning of
September 2018. Microsoft actually just
rebranded TFS as Azure devops and so you
have Azure pipelines and there are five
now Azure tools that you replace TFS but
these are all tools that are very
similar in concept the old TFS tools are
very similar to the centralized SVN
tools whereas the new tools that are
part of Azure are actually much more
aligned with get so what you're seeing
is Microsoft moving from the centralized
server to a distributed server with
their new Azure devops tools which is
fantastic news for every developer
listening to this and then we have get
and get is a distributed Version Control
System it is again open source which
means that you can start using it right
now without fear of having to have any
costs or any penalties and the thing
that's really good about it is that it's
really you can use it for almost any
kind of digital project and what it's
good at is being able to create that
historical record and versioning of your
source code whether you're doing a web
application a mobile application or
you're actually building a python script
for a machine learning solution so let's
dig into what version control systems
are and how they can be of value to you
so the role of a version control system
is to allow developers to be able to
check in their files into a repository
and here you can actually have see how
we can check in three files into a
repository and that repository then
becomes a snapshot or a historical
record of the files that we're working
on and you want to be able to have it so
that the repository is flexible enough
so that as you want to be able to scale
and add in new files or new versions of
a file that you can actually do that
easily within your VCS environment and
the goal is to be able to constantly
have each of these versions available so
that anybody wants to be able to check
out the file can actually have the
latest version or see a history of how
that file became what it is today let's
look at centralized Version Control
Systems and then we'll compare it
against distributed Version Control
Systems so a centralized version control
system has a central server where all
the files are stored and everybody has
to check in and check out from that
centralized server and all of the
versions are managed within that server
environment environment the problem is
is that if that Central server crashes
which doesn't happen but very often but
it can happen you end up losing all of
your files and I was actually on a
project where that actually happened to
us and we lost six months of history of
how the application was created
fortunately for us we actually had a
backup but it didn't have all the
historical data so we were able to at
least continue working but we just lost
a lot of files and it took a while to
get back into place so let's now look at
and compare this to a distributed
version control system with a
distributed Version Control System you
still have a centralized server that
manages the files but the difference is
is that as a developer you check out all
of the files for a project so you can
actually manage the whole project
locally on your development machine and
make your changes and then you can just
check in and out the changes that you've
made to the centralized server the
opportunity you have here is that the
server itself is goes down you're not
going to be in a situation where you
lose all of the history because
everybody that's working on the actual
application has all of the versions of
the code locally on their machine now
one of the more popular distributed
Version Control Systems that out there
is git I mean it really is probably the
most popular by a margin compared to a
system out there so you know let's dig
into you know what actually is get so
git is a version control system for
managing files and as a developer you
have a get client on your machine and
you're able to make changes and create
local repositories of a program on your
computer and then you can sync up with a
remote service such as GitHub or gitlab
or the new Azure Labs environment where
you can actually store files remotely
and then allow remote teams to have
access to the lose changes in the actual
application you made so you can track
your changes easily you have it's the
the tool is inherently distributed so it
makes it very easy to manage the code
for large teams and you can bring people
in very quickly and you can have people
come in as Specialists and spin them up
quickly and have them work on a piece of
the code and then drop them out of the
project if you want to have a check on
how this works go and start contributing
to any of the the many thousands of Open
Source projects at GitHub where you can
go in with your get tools and just
contribute to those projects and then
finally one of the things that I really
like with Git is that it's not a linear
development approach it's not starting
from a and going to Z it's a non-linear
approach which allows you to have
branches that people are working on in
parallel to your master Branch where
people are actually doing the delivery
of the production code so let's step
through some of these features so get as
you can imagine the first thing it does
is track history that's probably the
most important part of having a Version
Control System it's a free open source
you can actually go and use it right now
there are no costs of actually using it
it is a non-linear environment that
allows people to be able to build out
new features in parallel to the master
Branch so that you can be constantly
having the master code out there without
and adding in new features without
breaking the code and you can
automatically create backups by because
each developer has a version of the code
remotely it's incredibly scalable some
of the biggest projects out there now
are being managed through git and
because of this scale the collaboration
becomes a byproduct of teams working
together and branching just is so much
easier within get so as you can see this
whole thing leads to a very effective
distributed environment so let's step
through some of the the workflow that we
have available for git so the way that
git works is that you as an up operator
as a developer you have the get client
on your local development machine
whether it's a Linux machine a Mac or a
PC and you connect to a remote server
and you pull down the latest working
copy and then you're able to make all of
your changes uh locally and you can
modify the codes you can review changes
and you can commit those codes to your
git repository that you have locally and
then you can push those changes back up
to the remote server and as soon as you
push them into the remote server those
changes then become available to
everybody else working on the project so
they can be constantly keeping everybody
updated on all the work that is
happening so you know typically the way
that it would work is you know you would
start off with having the working file
the working directory that you have
locally then you would stage those files
into a staging area and then you get
those files ready to be committed to
your git repository and these are all
actions that you would do locally and
then connect to a remote server and then
later when you go back into work on your
project the first thing you should
always do is check out that code so you
always have the latest version of the
code and everybody's kept in sync so
let's talk about branching and get so
the way that branches work is that if
you imagine you're working on a project
and projects always have a tendency of
getting bigger than you imagine and what
you want to be able to do is keep that
main product working and keeping it
working effectively but if you want to
be able to add a feature to that product
you may have two or three different
groups that are working on multiple
features
simultaneously and what you want to be
able to do is give them the freedom to
work on those individual features and
the way you do it in git is that you can
create branches off the master and while
you're um of the the main branch which
is called the master and so each person
could be working on their own separate
branch and then when they want to they
can then later merge those branches back
into the main master and all this time
the main Master still works and still
able to produce the right code for the
customer but at the same time it allows
the developers the freedom to be able to
write in their new features and so we
can look at this in a little bit more
visually with the master branch and we
can put in small features and large
features that we can then merge them
back as we need to so this kind of
covers some of the commands that we have
in git so the First Command you'd want
to use is called get init and that's
allow you to go into a folder on your
local PC and or your local Mac and
convert that file that folder into a
local git repository and that creates
that repository then you want to be able
to make changes to that repository and
the commands you'd be using in this
instance would be add commit or status
and you want to be able to sync your
repositories through the remote server
so be able to put the code that you have
on your computer on the remote server
you push you're going to get the code
from the remote server you pull and then
had origin and then if you want to do
parallel development from the master
Branch the main branch you would use
Branch merge or rebase as ways to be
able to do parallel development a very
warm welcome to all our viewers I'm
Anjali from Simply learn and today I'll
be showing you the installation for get
on windows so we'll start by downloading
and installing it on our system we then
have a look at the git bash interface
we'll type in some basic git commands
next we'll create a local repository
that is we'll create a repository on a
local machine we'll then connect to a
remote repository and finally we'll push
the file onto GitHub first things first
we need to download and install git so
download git for Windows and I'll select
the second link
so 2.19.1 which is the most latest
version of git that's the one we want
for Windows system choose your version
so mine is a 64-bit system and it's
downloading so this will take a while so
git is finally downloaded now we need to
install the sonar system
click here run
so go to next we don't have to change
this path uh just so just click on in
quick launch and on desktop next next
again next nothing to change here either
and install
so now git is getting installed on our
system
so we don't need to view the release
notes we just want to launch the git
bash so let's just stick that and then
click on finish
and your git bash interface appears here
so we are on the master Branch the first
thing we do is we'll check the version
for our git so the command is git dash
dash version and as you can see version
2.19.1 on our Windows system which is
exactly what we just downloaded we'll
now explore the help command so let's
just type get help config so config is
another command and as I hit enter the
manual page for the second command
opened up which is config so what help
command does is that it provides the
manual or the help page for the command
just following it so in case you have
any doubts regarding how a command is
used what a command is used for all the
various syntax of the command you can
always use the help command now this
another Syntax for using the help
command itself which is git config dash
dash help enter this does the exact same
thing as you can see
now that we looked at the help command
let's begin by creating a local
directory so mkdir test now test is my
new directory I'll move into this
directory so CD test
great so now that we are inside our test
directory let's initialize this
directory so get init is the command for
initializing the directory and as you
can see as you can see the path here
this is the local path where a directory
is created so I'll just show you the
directory test and it's completely empty
what we do now is we'll create a text
file within this new directory that we
created so new text document and I'll
just name this demo I'll open this and
just put in some dummy content so hello
simply learn
save this file and go back to your bash
interface let's just check the status
now so git status and as you can see our
file has appeared it's visible but
nothing is committed yet so this means
that we have not made any change to a
file through the git tool itself so the
next thing that we are going to do is
we'll be adding demo to our current
directory the next command that we'll be
applying is the commit command and when
you add certain files to the current
directory the commit command is applied
on all the above directories so git
commit minus M and a message that will
appear once the file is committed
so as you can see one file is changed
and one insertion I'll just clear the
screen next thing we need to do is we
need to link our git to our GitHub
account so the command for doing that is
git config Global user dot username
and this will be followed by our
username so let me just show you my
GitHub account
so this is my GitHub profile and my
username is simply learn Dash GitHub so
guys before you begin this procedure
just make a GitHub account type in my
username here simply learn Dash GitHub
and enter and there you go a git is
successfully linked with GitHub next
thing we do is we'll just open our
GitHub and we'll create a new repository
give a repository name so I'll get name
it test underscore demo and create
Repository
great so our repository is created this
is our remote repository what we do next
is just copy the link and then go back
to your bash interface
now we need to link our remote and a
local Repository
so git remote origin and then paste
the HTTP link and now that our local
repository and a remote repository are
linked we can push a local file onto a
remote repository so the command for
doing that is git push origin Master as
we are on the master branch
and that's done so now let's move back
to GitHub I'll just click on test demo
and as you can see here our local file
has been pushed to our remote repository
with that we have successfully completed
our demo if you have any queries
regarding this please post them in the
comment section below and we'll get back
to you as soon as possible and now we're
going to go through and do a demo on git
so we're going to do a demo on git so
you can feel comfortable running the
commands in the interface and you're
able to get get running correctly in
your environment so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to set
up which version of git that you have
and then we're going to see if we can
establish some Global configurations
within your git environments and we're
going to do sandeep.dash as the name
email address is sandeep.simplylearn and
then we're going to do a list of the
different configuration settings we have
so to check the version of git that we
have we do git dash dash version in our
terminal or command line window you can
also use Powershell that'll actually get
you running in the same environment as
well all of these tools are going to be
command line tools and then the next
thing we're going to do is we're going
to assign some Global usernames and a
global email address and so that we can
actually access the get account itself
locally on the device and so we're going
to Dash and we're going to put in config
dash dash Global user.name Sandeep and
then a git
config.global user.email and
sandeep.d at simplylearn.net and now
we're going to check the list of
usernames and email IDs in our
configuration environment with Dash list
and you'll see that we have everything
in there correctly here is our username
right here and our name and our email ID
so if you need any help when you're
actually doing any of your work and get
all you have to do is to get help config
or git config dash dash help and this
will allow you to actually get access to
the help screens so let's just go and
type that in git help help config return
and this takes us to the help page
that's running locally on your device
and here we have a breakdown of all the
different commands and what those
commands actually do within a git
configuration
and we can go ahead and we can do get
config dash dash help and that will
actually take us to the same page so two
ways of doing the same thing so we're
going to go ahead and we're going to
create a test repository on our local
system and we're going to do that with
make directory called test and then
we're going to move our cursor within
command window terminal window to the
test folder and then we're going to
initialize that folder to become a git
repository so let's go ahead and do that
so we're going to make a new directory
and we're going to call it test and
we're going to move the cursor so it's
actually in the test folder we do CD
change directory to test and you can see
now we're actually in the test folder
and now all you have to do is initialize
this folder as a git repository and so
we're going to do this as git init and
it's now a new git instance that we can
actually now use for managing our git
environment so we're going to create a
new file and we're going to call it
info.txt and we're going to put some
content in it and we're actually going
to put it in the folder that we've just
created so you can actually see what
it's like to to test out the get
environment with a file that hasn't been
checked into it yet so let's go ahead
and do that so we open up our folder
directory and here you can see we have
the test folder and we're just going to
go ahead and create a default test file
so right click Text new document
info.txt open that and we'll just you
can put really whatever you want in here
we're just going to put in this
information right now name equals Sam
registration number one two
479 and save that file close it out now
if we actually go ahead and run a get
status command you'll see that the
info.txt file is in red that's because
that file has not actually been checked
into the project it's a new file that
we've added but it hasn't been committed
yet into the git repository so let's go
ahead and see what it takes to actually
add the file to the git repository that
we just created so we're going to do
that by doing get add info.txt and then
we're going to commit that into the
history of that git repository so we can
do so it now has Version Control and we
can start doing uh forking and other
kind of similar activities when we
connect later to our GitHub git
environment so we do get add info Dot
txt and remember we're actually still in
the test folder so it's going to look
for that file in that folder and just
add it in and now if we go ahead and do
get status we'll actually be able to see
that the info.txt file is in an active
color first of all you have to commit it
so we go get commit Dash M and then
we're going to commit and we add in some
quick text you can write whatever you
want committing the text files now
actually committed into the get
repository and it's all running locally
on your PC so we're going to go make
some changes to the file and we're going
to save it and we want to be able to see
how we can use git to compare the
differences between the two files so
let's go over and we're going to make
some changes to the info.txt file here
we are here's info.txt which is going to
add in a new line we're going to add in
the line address and we're going to save
that file and now when we go over to get
we're going to be able to review the
difference so we're going to do git div
and here you actually see that we've
added in a new address file so now you
can actually see this is the difference
and the difference between the two
documents now as you can imagine when
you have code this would become more
elaborate where actually Google should
take show you code that's been pulled
out if you've reduced any of eliminate
amazing code or if you added in new code
really useful so we're going to go ahead
and add our get username to a remote
location so we can actually start
testing out the file that we've created
into a remote repository in this case
we're going to use GitHub and you'll be
able to see how we can actually then
save that file into a git repository
that somebody else could then access and
be able to make edits to so let's just
go ahead and make those changes so git
config Dash Global user dot username and
we'll do simply learn and that will
associate it with this getch repository
that we've just created locally so
simply on dash GitHub so simply learn
GitHub is the username that we use on
GitHub so we're going to go over to
GitHub here we are in GitHub and then
correct new Repository
and then as you can see with Sim so
we're in simply learn Dash GitHub and
we're going to call the new repository
test we're going to make it public so
anybody can access it and you'll see
that it automatically adds a readme file
and we have our test environment set up
correctly so we'll go ahead and copy the
URL link which is github.com simplylearn
GitHub for test.get copy that and we'll
go back over to our command line window
and so now we're going to add the
username to the GitHub configuration so
what we're doing is we're connecting the
local repository to the remote
repository so we type get remote add
origin and then we'll paste in the
address and this then allows us to
connect the local repository that we
created in the test folder with the
remote repository and now we're
connected so now that we've connected we
can actually push the file that we have
in the local repository on your PC or
Mac to the remote repository in the
GitHub server environment so let's go
ahead and do that so we're going to do
get push and push is the command to push
the documents from the origin which is
the local file to master and Masters a
remote file okay and there we are
success so what we have now is the file
that we just created in our local get
repository is actually now in the remote
repository as well so anybody can access
it so let's go have a look at that so
we're going to refresh the GitHub page
and hey there we are there's info.txt
has been uploaded and we're ready to go
that's great that's uh that's what you
should be seeing so refreshing your web
page on the remote GitHub folder and it
could be any get service but just
happened to be using GitHub because it's
free to use you'll be able to see that
the local file has been installed and is
now part of the git repository in the
remote server so what we can do now is
we're going to create three more files
and we're just going to call them
info.txt info 2 and info three and then
we're going to push them out to the
remote server and we're going to merge
everything together into a single
environment so let's go ahead and create
create those three files and we're just
going to add those into the folder so
let's go ahead create new text document
info one and then we're going to create
info 2 and then info three look at my
typing right here okay here we go there
we are
okay I'm opening info three and I'm just
going to enter some text in here and
what we're going to do is illustrate how
we can do branching and each of these
files I'm going to save and then close
out and now I can go over and so let's
create a new branch and we're going to
call this one first underscore branch
and we go get Branch first underscore
branch and this will be a new branch of
the code environment that we're creating
and so hit return and that allows us to
create a new branch and so what we do is
we're going to move to the new Branch so
we're going to do get checkout first
underscore branch and that allows us to
move into that branch and you see that
info.txt is already there which is good
that's what we want to see now what we
need to do is add in the new documents
so here we have the different steps
we've taken we created a branch we moved
to the new branch and now we're going to
go ahead and add the info 3 txt to that
Branch so you can actually see
everything coming together and we're
going to go ahead get add info 3.txt so
we're just adding a file like we were
previously see with our initially our
first initial git folder and that file
has now been added to the first Branch
so we're going to go ahead and commit
the file to the first branch and then
we're going to merge the documents into
the master Branch so we have everything
together so let's go ahead and do those
steps we're going to do the commit first
and then we're going to merge everything
together right so we do git commit Dash
M and we'll just put in we're just going
to say uh made changes to First branch
and that's just a documentation so that
we know what we've done and there we are
we've committed the file so we had that
file info three txt committed and now
we're going to go ahead and merge the
files into the main master and so we can
actually have everything together as one
consistent environment and we do that by
typing in so this list out what we have
in our Master file so we just do LS and
that will show everything in the folder
and we have info.txt info1 txt info 2
txt and info 3txt are now all in the
first Branch so let's go ahead and we're
going to merge okay so actually before
we merge we have to check out the master
Branch so we do get checkout master so
it gets us into the master branch and
you'll see that we have just one file
there info.txt so we're going to list
out the files in the master branch and
so so what you'll see is info dot text
info one text and info two texts are
there but info dot info 3 text isn't
there because that was created in a
separate Bunch so let's go ahead and
merge the first Branch into the master
Branch so we do git merge and we do
first underscore branch and there we are
we've merged it in and excellent that
looks good so let's go ahead and list
out the files that we have in the master
branch and we do LS and then you'll see
that we have four files including the
info three dot text that we had in a
separate Branch now all in the master
branch in this session we will have a
look at the basics of GitHub before
diving deep into the subject let's first
have a look at a use case
the used case we will consider today is
that the world's largest Sporting Goods
hotel brand decathlon
decathlon has 1600 stores spread in 52
countries with around 100 000 employees
the IIT team of GitHub consists of 1000
members that helps decathlon to bring
its Shoppers journey to their devices
so here we will first see the problems
that they faced and then we shall see
how did they sort out that problem
in the beginning decathlon worked on the
data center with the help of a VPN and
using a VPN was a huge challenge in
terms of workflow visibility and
avoiding redundancies
so the first problem is how to maintain
workflow visibility and avoid
redundancies
then since there are so many stores
located at so many different places
hiring of developers seem to be a
difficult task as a physical workplace
was always needed so the second problem
is how would they hire developers now
let's see how did decathlon solve these
two problems one after the other
in the first case the entire decathlon
shifted from any other remote repository
to GitHub
GitHub turned out to be an amazing open
source Community as the code became more
visible across the organization and now
anybody could contribute to it
then let's talk about the second case
for hiring the Developers as we know
GitHub is an open source community so it
helped in collaboration with any
developer all over the world
the potential developers could now
contribute to benefit the global
community
now the question arises what made this
contribution possible so the major
contribution role was played by the
Version Control System
this was just a single case amongst many
others there are many organizations that
have benefited from GitHub now when we
have realized how GitHub has
revolutionized the market let's start
learning more and more about GitHub it
is time for us to jump on the topic what
is GitHub
GitHub is a service hosted on the web
where all the projects are stored every
project on GitHub has its own repository
and its unique URL git provides a
graphical interface to store the files
and helps team members to coordinate on
the project from anywhere
GitHub provides several access control
and collaboration features like wikis
and basic task management tools for
every project
let's now have a look at the features of
GitHub
the first feature we will see is easy
project management
GitHub help project managers and
developers to coordinate better on the
project
the work can be easily tracked and
updated which makes sure that the
project is on schedule and as entitled
second feature is increased safety with
packages
the packages on GitHub can be published
as desired they can be published
privately or within a community or can
also be published publicly
the packages can be easily downloaded
from the GitHub to use and reuse them
next feature is the effective team
management
now as all the team members can stay
updated with all that's happening on the
project so this helps them in staying
organized and well coordinated the pull
request and other modification tools
make sure that the team focuses on the
code
moving on the next feature is improved
code writing
with the help of GitHub the quality of
code has significantly increased now
with the help of gitpool command one can
review improve and propose new codes
along with that suggestions or
modifications may be discussed before
changing the original code
the next feature is increased code
safety
GitHub uses code ql which is the
industry's leading semantic code
analysis engine this tends to find risks
in the code which other tools tend to
miss
the last feature we shall see is easy
code hosting as the name suggests the
codes and documentations are hosted in
one place
we also know that there are thousands of
repositories on GitHub so each
repository has their own set of tools to
release and host the code
finally let's have a look at the
competitors of GitHub there are several
competitors in the market here we have
just put the most common ones first is
at least in bitbucket then comes fog
bugs followed by surround SCM and gitlab
then we have buddy and finally followed
by Beanstalk let's see the differences
between git and GitHub git is a software
that can be installed directly onto our
systems whereas GitHub as we saw in the
demo is hosted on the cloud then git can
be used offline we don't typically need
an internet connection unless we need to
access the GitHub whereas GitHub can
only be operated when we have an
internet connection next difference is
git is something independent and can be
used without GitHub whereas GitHub has
nothing to do unless we make
repositories in git which means it
cannot be used without git then git is a
version control system that helps in
source code management whereas geta
provides centralized hosting of the code
on the cloud next difference is git does
not work work according to a graphical
user interface while GitHub is a simple
graphical interface next difference is
git is a command line so it operates on
several commands like commit merge Push
Pull Etc whereas GitHub is a web-based
service so it has nothing to do with
command line then git is released under
the gnu general public license which is
an open source license it ensures that
the software is free for all its users
whereas in the case of GitHub there are
two tires a free tire and a Pay Tire in
the end let's have a look at the
competitors of the two as a competition
git has Mercurial supervision IBM
rational team concert and clear case
while for GitHub the competition is
bitbucket and gitlab hello and welcome
to git commands my name is chidanand and
I am with the simply learn team today I
am going to cover few essential git
command hands and walk you through a
demonstration for most of it I begin by
installing a git bash or the git client
and configuring it for its first time
usage once I'm done with configuring the
git client I am going to spin up few
repositories locally and work on these
repositories using git commands once I'm
happy with my local changes I'm going to
commit few of them and then push these
changes to a git server of my choice for
today's demonstration I plan to use
github.com which is a cloud hosted free
service and it provides free account
registrations for anyone eventually I
will cover few topics regarding git
branching and merging because these two
in my opinion are the killer features of
the get distributed Version Control tool
kit is one of the most popular
distributed Version Control tools of
recent times and like any other
distributed Version Control tool it
allows us to perform various Version
Control tasks without really needing a
network connection before I jump into my
demos station let me spend some time
explaining to you the git client server
working model what does it take for a
couple of users to collaborate and start
working with Git the bare minimal thing
that any user would need in order to
start working with kit is something
called as git bash or the git client
this comes as an installer for all
popular operating systems like Windows
all flavors of Windows Linux Mac OS and
other operating systems so once you
install git bash you get a command line
utility using which you can fire up your
git commands and ensure that you can
bring up repositories you can work with
this repositories by adding files to it
committing changes to it and all those
git commands would work perfectly well
so you can bring up a small repository
and you can work with your repository
using this git bash but what does it
take for you to share this repository
with another user who has also got get
install on this system this is where you
would need something called as a git
server so for user one or one user to
share his repository with another user
he would need to collaborate using
something called as a git server so in
the present Market there are a bunch of
git servers which are popularly
available some of them are free some of
them come with a cost because they are
licensed a bunch of these servers that I
can think of are GitHub which is one of
the most popular git servers that is
around in the market for a long time now
it comes with two variants one is the
cloud hosted one which is the github.com
and then the other one is an Enterprise
server which comes as a black box that
can be installed into your data centers
so typically organizations who don't
want their source code to be put up on
the cloud but go for this GitHub
Enterprise servers wherein the buy this
servers and these servers are hosted on
their data centers other popular variant
of the git server is bigmark Market this
is from the famous atlassian products
and it integrates very well with all
other atlassian products like jirom in
recent times there's one other variant
of the git server called gitlab which is
getting very very popular these days
because gitlab not just provides a git
server it also provides something called
as a runner this is a part of the
continuous integration strategy where as
soon as you have a source code check-in
that is going in you have this Runner
that kicks up and builds your particular
project so all these are bundled
together in a git lab and gitlab also
provides you with a Community Edition
which is almost free of cost having said
that there are a bunch of these tools
available for my demonstration what I'm
going to do is I've already registered
myself on the github.com by providing my
username and my password and I'm going
to use a free account so whatever
reposit is that I'm gonna put up on this
server is all public by default so our
register Myself by using my username or
my email ID and my password so this set
of authentication is also referred to as
https authentication so in order for me
to share my repository with say user 2.
the first thing that I got to do is have
an access to a git server where both
user 1 and user 2 are set up so once I
have that I can push my repository onto
this server and provide right kind of
access so that user 2 or the other
developer whoever wishes to collaborate
with me on this repository can use his
credentials as long as is registered
properly on the git server he can use
his credentials and pull down this
repository and work with this repository
so this is the https way of
authenticating and sharing repositories
another popular way of sharing
repositories or working with each other
is called as SSH authentication as many
of you would know SSH means nothing but
creation of a private and a public key a
bunch of keys public and private are
create created on the client machine
while I create a keys I will be asked
for a passphrase I need to type in a
passphrase and remember my passphrase
and then I take this public key and kind
of post it on to my account within my
git server so that whenever I'm going to
connect next time using my command
prompt or any of the tools it's going to
challenge me for my passphrase as long
as I remember my passwords correctly I
can authenticate myself and get into the
server so both https and SSH are popular
ways of communicating with the git
server having said this let me just get
started by installing the git bash on my
local system and then fire up some of
these git commands and build up some
repositories make some changes in my
repository commit these changes and
later use my GitHub credential to
connect to my GitHub server and push my
repositories out there
let me now go ahead and find my git bash
for my windows so that I can go ahead
and install it so I just type in git
client for windows open up a browser and
type in for this the first one that I
find is a GUI tool I don't need this GUI
client I need this one so this is a git
client or the git bash that I was
referring to it's about 40 Megs and let
me just download this pause this video
for some time so that the download
happens and come back to you once I have
the download the download seems to be
complete when I'm recording this video
the version that I have the latest
version that is there is 2.19.0 and this
is a 64-bit version for Windows so I've
got that downloaded let me go ahead and
find it and install this EXE
all right I go ahead choosing all the
default options I want it to be
installed in SQL and program files under
the git folder everything looks good for
me I'm not going to make any changes
here
get Bash from Windows yes I might want
to use git from Windows command prompt
that sounds good for me open SSH that's
fine
looks good looks good no I don't want
any of these new features
so what I'm doing is installing the git
bash or the git client so that I can
start using my git commands
and the motion that I'm using is
2.19.0 which as I record this video this
happens to be the latest version
all right so looks good I don't want to
see the release notes I'll say again
launch git Bash
so what I get is this window so this is
the git command prompt so let me check
if everything is looking good it's a Git
Version it sounds good it's a git help
all right a lot of git help commands
everything looks good so I ended up
installing the git bash I can go ahead
with all other commands
now that I have git bash installed on my
system let me open up a git bash prompt
and start using it but before I do
anything I just need to configure It For
the First Time stating what would be the
username and the email ID with which I
want the git bash to be configured with
the command to do that is get config
hyphen iPhone Global which means that
this setting that I'm going to set would
be a global setting user dot name and
this the name of the user would need to
be specified within a double code in my
case I am using a simply learn account
which is the official account and this
is the particular username of this
account the other setting is nothing but
git config hyphen iPhone Global this is
also Global setting
and this would be the email ID
the email ID need not contain a double
quote
so in my case this is the email ID that
I would be setting up git to work with
all right let me check if the
configurations were set correctly or not
all right if you see this the username
and the email ID has been picked up the
way I wanted it to be picked up looks
good so far all right so what do we do
next by default whenever you open up the
git prompt you're placed into your home
directory let me create a folder here
which would be a repository folder from
where I'm going to create all my
multiple git repositories so I will
create a folder called let's say git
underscore demo
all right
there's already a folder called git demo
so let me just delete that in the first
place and let me create this git demo
again
all right let me navigate to this
particular folder
so this is the folder let me open up
that folder using a command prompt
this is my git demo so this would be a
folder so I would use this folder as a
base folder for creating all other
repositories as a part of this demo so
let me create my first repository a
repository is nothing but a folder so
let me create my first folder called
first repo
and let me
get into the syllable all right as of
now this is just an empty folder
if at all I navigate to this you could
see that this folder is empty there's
nothing much in this folder at all at
this moment
okay so let me create a repository out
of this how do I create a repository of
this is pretty simple I just run and get
init command
when I say get init it means it's going
to initialize a repository as of now
the folder contained nothing in it was
an empty repository so it initially is
an empty repository in this particular
folder for all I look at my content you
would see that there's a hidden folder
this would be a hidden folder since I've
configured my Explorer to view all
hidden folders I see it otherwise you
wouldn't see it so a folder by name dot
get is created within this first repo
and this was created because we ran the
command kit init
if I get into this folder I see a bunch
of directories and other configurations
if you see there is something called as
a hooks directory a couple of
configuration files that are here in
this directory all these relate to one
or the other type of a client hook that
can be enabled and this info this
objects
this references a bunch of stuff that is
there
so what is this folder this is a magical
git folder and this is created whenever
a repository is initialized so by
default if at all you get into any git
folder or any git repository you would
see this dot get folder a word of
caution do not get into this folder and
try to modify anything because if you
fiddle around with this and corrupt this
particular folder your whole repository
will go for a toss so let me come out of
this
and let me show you another thing now if
you notice here when I was in the folder
the repository did not have anything
after this now when I say git in it
there is something called as a master
that shows up so typically what happens
is whenever a git repository is created
for the first time it creates a default
Branch the name of the branch is called
master and that is why you would see
Master within braces this doesn't mean
anything else other than we have a
repository out in this particular folder
and by default there is a branch called
master and we are currently on that
Branch if at all I create multiple
branches in this folder whenever I
navigate to different branches the
branch name within this brackets would
change all right so far so good so we
created a folder we made it a git
repository by initializing that with the
git in it and then I'm not put anything
yet in the repository so let me try to
do that let me create a few files within
this particular repository so I use a
touch command touch is a Linux command
it kind of creates this particular
folder if all you're not comfortable
with the file creation by this way you
can always use a file explorer and
create some files in this so I create a
file called touch master.txt and open up
in the notepad
okay so this is my first file that's
what I'm going to write inside this
I save this and I come out of this all
right now let me do a git status command
so what does this set tell you there's
no commit set you're in the master
Branch there is an untracked file and
this shows up in red it also gives you
all the command that is supposed to be
run so if at all you want to add this
file you would say git add and the name
of the file and then you're going to
commit it
so what happened is that when the
repository was initialized it was an
empty repository now that a git notices
that there is a new file in this
repository called master.txt if at all
you want you want us to let git know
that you want to track this file we need
to add this to the repository so the
command to add that is called git add I
can specify either the name of the file
or I can give a wild character saying
git add dot now if I run the git status
command again
it says there's no commits yet added a
file and the file which was earlier in
red now shows up in green and it says
it's a new file master.txt all right it
also gives you something called git
remove command if at all you want to
unstage or undo your changes so what has
happened is the file which was earlier
untracked has been added into the git
index or it is ready for staging or it's
in a staged State now I can go ahead and
commit this file if at all that's what I
want to do so let me do that
I'll do a kit commit minus M and I give
a message that I want I would say this
is my first get commit
all right I run the get status command
again and see it says on the branch
Master nothing to commit it's all nice
and clean so typically what happened was
I created a empty directory made it into
a git folder by doing a git in it I put
a file into it I made some changes to
the file I added that file into the
repository and I committed to the
repository if it were I run the git log
command
it says this was the commit ID or the
commit number or the commit hashtag and
this is the author if you notice this is
the email ID and the username that we
set earlier and this was done on this
date and this is the
commit message that is there all of it
looks so good let me do one more commit
into this repository so I will touch
Master One Dot text I'll put in another
file
I'll open up this particular file
write something into this
all right I save this change
let me also open up the older
file make some more change into this
all right so what I did I modified the
older file that existed I also added a
new file to my repository now if I run
the get status command
it says modified this file which is
showing in red and it says you have one
more file which is an untracked file
all right now let me add both these
files because these are the changes that
I want to
incorporate I would say git add dot I
run the git status command again
and it says now this is a modified file
this is a new file looks good to me let
me go ahead and Commit This so git
commit with the message that says this
is my second commit
all right
if I do a git log now it shows both the
commits the first comment is the one
that that shows up at the bottom and the
topmost one is the latest commit that is
there so far so good if at all you
notice I'm doing all these git commands
without really connecting it to any git
server I don't need any network
connection for doing any of these things
I can keep on doing more and more git
commands and run git commands the way I
want to
without really having any connections to
the kit server now that I have my
changes the way I wanted and I've
checked in all the code changes into my
local repository I may want to share my
repository with somebody else and work
in a collaborative way so the way to do
that is as I mentioned earlier to host
this repository or to push this
repository onto a git server I already
have a GitHub account wherein I've
registered myself using my username and
password so I log into my GitHub account
using my username and credentials and
let me go ahead and create a new
Repository
my repository is already there on the
local system so what I essentially need
is just a placeholder for my repository
so that I can link them together and
push the content from my local
repository to the server
if you notice the name of my repository
is his first repo
so let me copy this I would create a
folder structure or a repository
structure on the server with the same
name so that when I pushed my repository
from my local box it will go ahead and
get created in the server so the
repository name should be the same as
what I created on my local box
description I would say this is my first
get Hub Repository
on the server
this is just an optional description
that will show up and if you notice
I can't have any private repositories so
whatever repositories that I'm going to
create here would be a public repository
so I choose public and I don't want to
initialize this with a readme file or
anything of that because I already have
a repository with some content with some
code checked in all that I need is a
placeholder for my repository on the
server so with this option with just a
name and with an optional description
and the repository being public I go
ahead and click on the create repository
button
so if you notice it gives me a bunch of
commands that I would need to run in
order to create a repository and push it
onto the server and also important point
it shows me two URLs one is the https
URL and the other one is the SSH URL as
of now we do not have any SSH keys that
is set up so let me use this https URL
to connect my local repository with the
repository on this server
so I've done all these things I already
have the repositories set up all that I
need is a placeholder for me to connect
my local repository with the server URL
so this would be the command that I need
to copy
but essentially links or ads and origin
with the URL of the git server I just
copy this command
and run it here
get remote add the name of the remote is
called origin and it points to an https
URL which is nothing but the placeholder
that I've created on the server
all right so let me check if it's added
correctly
okay the URL looks good I'm all set I've
got two comments in my repository I'm
done with all the changes so let me try
to push my repository onto the server
the command for doing it for the first
time is git push hyphen U this is for
linking the Upstream
origin master
so git push hyphen U Upstream linking
origin master link the master
branch of my local repository with the
master branch on the server repository
and where is it going to push it is
going to push by default to An Origin
and the origin points to this URL all
right let me try doing this
so it essentially opens up an URL asking
me the credentials with which I need to
log into my GitHub server so let me just
copy and paste
the username and the password with which
I have registered
I would say login
okay success so I am able to create a
repository on the server and the content
seems to be pushed and it created a new
branch called Master it is linked the
master Branch from the local repository
with the master branch on the server so
let me go back to my server and refresh
this page
and see if all my commits have come in
master master one dot text for all I see
the commits they seem to be two commits
this is my first comment this is my
second comment and if at all you notice
each of this commit comes with a hash
key or a hash ID which contains the
details of my commits in this commit the
files were added this was a line that
was added if you look at the second
commit
I added these lines
I made this you know one line chain that
was there I also added this new file
which was not existing these are the two
commits that existed
and if you see
the timestamp of the Commit This is the
commit which was committed for 15
minutes ago so what does this mean is
that the commit is the timestamp when we
actually commented the code in the
client the pushing is just after we have
committed the change we have pushed it
so there's no time stamp of the push
that happened
this completes the first part of the
tutorial wherein I create a repository
on the client and then I pushed it to
the server after creating a repository
Skeleton on the server now let me
demonstrate to you the SSH configuration
that is required for creating a pair of
SSH keys and ensuring that I connect to
the GitHub server using the SSH
mechanism so for doing that I need to
First create a pair of private and
public key the command to do that is SSH
Keygen
hyphen T I will use the RSA mechanism
for creating my keys Capital C and I
need to specify the email ID using which
I'm going to connect to all right I need
to create the keys for
all right so generating a private and
public key pair it says let me know what
folder should I create the keys in so by
default the keys are created in the user
home directory under a DOT SSH folder so
this is pretty good for me so let me go
ahead and say that that's fine enter a
passphrase so let me enter some
passphrase
keep in mind that I would need to
remember my passphrase because when I'm
going to authenticate myself using SSH
mechanism it will challenge me for this
particular passphrase I need to enter
the right passphrase so that I get
authenticated
so the key is generated and by default
it is created in this particular folder
so let me go over to that particular
folder
and this is the folder where the keys is
generated you would see a public key and
a private key that is created let me
open up the public key with a notepad
and then copy the contents of the whole
file
and now I would need to stick it in
on the server so that I can get myself
authenticated using SSH keys so I have
logged in to GitHub using my credentials
and go to my settings
and you would see an SSH and gpg keys
let me click on that as of now there are
no SSH key or gpg keys so I would click
on new SSH key and let me paste my
public key that I've copied and I would
say add SSH key
it prompts me for my password just to
make sure that
I've got the right kind of
authentication to be adding a new key so
this one looks good that means the keys
were added successfully let me check if
my SSH keys are working well
so I do SSH hyphen capital T I would say
get
at github.com
this is just to double check if my SSH
keys
are authenticated correctly are you sure
you want the connection yes you want to
continue yes
all right now a check for my passphrase
let me enter my passphrase I hope I
remember it correctly
all right
pretty good I've been successfully
authenticated so that means now my SSH
keys are good and just by using my
passphrase I can connect to my GitHub
server using SSH all right so for the
Second Use case what I would do is
create a repository on the server with
some content in it and then clone that
repository cloning is nothing but making
a copy of that repository linking the
origin so that I create an exact replica
of the repository which is there on the
server on my local drive so let me first
create a repository on the server I'll
create a new Repository
let me give a name for my repository and
let me kind of initialize that with the
readme file I would call this my second
repo
give some description
this is my second repo
that is created straight
on the git server on the GitHub server
to be precise
it's a public repository this time I am
going to choose this option the reason
being that I don't want to create just a
skeleton as of now I want to create a
repository with some readme file in it a
random readme file with no content in it
but then I want a repository to be
created on the server all right I say
create a repository
So Random readme file with some content
in it gets created and I can see there
are two URLs to this repository https
and SSH so this time let me copy the SSH
URL so that I will use this URL to clone
this repository on the server
rather from the server to my local box
all right so let me navigate to my root
folder the folder that I created for
making all my repositories git
repositories if you see my first deposit
is already here so let me clone my
repository the second repo that I
created on the server the command to do
that is git clone the URL of the
repository that I want to clone
oops looks like I didn't copy the URL
correctly let me copy that again
copy this URL
all right so if you notice there is no
https to it I'm just cloning the URL
that is SSH URL of the Repository
it asks for my passphrase again
okay
so I just had first repository earlier
now I have something called a second
repo this is an exact replica of
whatever was the repository content that
was created on the server so if I get
into
the repository there's just a simple
readme file that is there let me try to
add a new file out here I would say
Notepad
second dot text
some text file I'm going to put in here
yes definitely you will not find that
file there
this is my second
file that
I will push onto the server
I'm going to put in some content out
there
and save this
and if I do get status
it says this this is a new untracked
file you want to add this file onto the
repository do you want to track this
file yes I definitely want to track this
file let me also commit my change to the
file
with a message
this is my first
commit for the second repo
I'm giving some particular message
and this time around since I cloned my
repository from a server the origin is
already set for me I don't really need
to add the origin and all that stuff
because what happened in the first case
was that I was creating a repository
from my local box and then pushing
another server which is why I had to set
up the Upstream branches and stuff like
that in this case I have cloned an
existing repository from the server so
when I clone I get the replica along
with all references to my repository so
I don't need to do anything more rather
than push the content I'll just say get
push to be in the safer side I would say
origin and master
ask me for the passphrase
okay you post the content onto the
server let me see if the contents have
come in here okay wonderful I had only
one comment now I see my second comment
so what was added as a part of the
second comment it says a new file was
added all this line that never existed
got added this is the second file the
content exactly what I pushed onto the
server
now this completes the tutorial when I
create a repository on the server cloned
it made some changes to the repository
and pushed it to the server using SSH
a quick recap of all the git commands
that we ran till now get init is used to
initialize the repository so if at all
you are creating a local repository you
can get into any of the folder which is
not a git repository and run this
command whenever you run this command a
magical folder by name dot kits gets
created in the folder and from that time
onwards git will start tracking any
changes that happen to that particular
folder it also creates a new repository
and a branch by default the branch that
is created is called the master Branch
git add dot is a wildcard character for
adding any number of new files into your
git repository if you have a bunch of
files one file two file 10 files a
folder containing multiple files in it
all of them could be added into the
repository using this command so once
you add any number of files into the
repository you can keep on adding more
and more files into the repository once
you're done with that you want to commit
the changes that has happened in the
repository you use the git commit
command git commit hyphen M with a
meaningful message this will commit all
the work items that you have done in
terms of the files that got changed the
more files that got added all this with
one particular message get status will
give you the status of all the files and
folders any file that got added any file
that got created any file that was
deleted all the status of the files will
be obtained using the git status command
git log will show you all the commit
history with the latest history or the
latest commit showing up on top git add
remote origin this command is used
whenever you want to link any local
repository to a server and this is when
you want to really push a repository
from the local to the server for the
first time git push hyphen U origin and
master this is the command that you
would use whenever you want to push
contents from the local repository to
the server over git clone and the URL of
the server this is the command that you
would run whenever you have an existing
repository on the server and you want to
make a fresh clone or a fresh copy of
that particular repository onto your
local box
more than often many developers or git
users find themselves in situations
where they would want to go back in
history and modify or change some of the
files that they recently committed or
checked into the repository now from a
perspective of get this is a very very
simple activity however from a
perspective Version Control tool you
will have to be really cautious about
the chain that you're gonna do in case
the changes are pretty local none of the
developers or none of the other users
who are collaborating with you would be
affected by this change you are good to
go ahead and make this change however if
your repository has been pushed to the
server and you're trying to modify
something from history this would have a
very bad or adverse effect on all the
other users who will be using it you
need to be really cautious while running
these commands in case your repository
contents are local you've not pushed
your changes to your repository and if
at all you made some changes to the
repository maybe to fix a defect or to
include a new feature and you may few
things you can go over and modify this
with some of these commands let's say I
have this simple repository called undo
undo repo and if at all I look at the
logs of these I have the commit
histories which are like this
I have about five commits that is there
in my repository and in C1 I've added a
file in C2 I add another file in C3 I've
also added some file in C4 I made some
changes to M1 and M3 and in C5 I have
added another file called M4 now this is
my commit history now let's say I made
these two commits but possibly I want to
Club them together along with some other
changes because whatever changes I did
did not really fix things the way I
expected it to fix so there is a git
command called git reset this would
allow me to go back in history to go
back to any of the snapshot get rid of
all this commit history on the commit
messages but retain the changes that
were made as a part of these comments so
if at all I need to go back in history
and go back to this particular comment
and however I just want to get rid of
these commits that are there in terms of
the commit messages but I want the
changes that were there as a part of
these commits to still exist I would do
command called get reset hyphen iPhone
soft
now this would go back or unwind my
changes back to this particular snapshot
getting rid of all the commit messages
that were there as a part of these two
comments but a soft would ensure that
the file changes that were done as a
part of these two commits would still
exist a full remain so the command for
that is git reset hyphen iPhone soft
which is the snapshot that I want to get
back to if this is the comment that I
want to get back to I just copy this
and paste this
all right it doesn't give me any message
but if at all I do a git log pretty one
line
what it says is 7 C2 now the head which
is nothing but the current pointer which
is earlier pointing to C5 it's gone back
to C3 now what happened to the changes
that were there as a part of C4 and C5
if at all you do a git status if you see
the changes that were part of C4 was
some changes to M1 and M2 and C5 a new
file got M4 got added if what I do a git
status
you'll see those changes still exist
however from the git history or the git
commit history C3 is the topmost comment
that exists as of now c4 and C5 have
been currently read off but the changes
that were there still exist
all right now I can make some more
changes that I want if as a part of my
commit and possibly go ahead and commit
this whole thing as a new commit
altogether maybe I'll open up a notepad
and possibly create a new file called
m6.txt
and say one new file that was missed out
I make this change I go to a get status
all these files are still there I would
say get add dot I'll say get
commit hyphen m
C4
rewriting history
and I do a git
blog
pretty
there you go so C1 C2 C3 still existed
and whatever was a part of C4 and C5 the
older ones I have gotten rid of this
along with those old changes I also
added a new file I made some changes and
I was able to commit it now if you look
at my git history it's all nice and
clean however do this activity only when
you don't push your git repository to
the server one other most powerful and
useful command while undoing or
resetting the history is something
called as revert this is a safe way of
undoing some things remember what I
talked about when exactly you can do a
reset it's only when your changes are
local and is not being pushed to the
repository take this scenario wherein
let's say I have a git server
and I have the changes which are C1
C2
C3
and possibly C4
all right so this is a bunch of comments
that has happened this was the oldest
comment and this is the newest comment
and if at all developer 1 is the one
who's responsible for pushing these
contents
in the first place so he has got C1 to
C4 on his history
I'm going to jump all these C2 and C3
and get into C4 and he's pushed all
these contents out here
and there are a bunch of people from the
server who has pulled this repository
and all of them are the same level
now imagine a use case where developer
won then figures out that by mistake he
put in the C3 which is a wrong thing to
do and possibly you know he could have
done a better job of fixing this in a
different way so he wants to get rid of
the C3 or C4 or any one of these
comments
if he's going to do that and push it to
the server first of all the git server
would not allow him to go back in
history but assuming that he forcibly
pushed something
what would happen to all these people
who are looking to work ahead from C4
all of them would be affected in an
adverse way so in short never go back in
history if at all you need to undo
something go ahead and put in a new
commit to undo something
let's take this example maybe if at all
a developer one wants to get rid of C3
better way to do that is by adding a new
commit which is ahead say let's say C5
and what does this commit to this commit
possibly gets rid of C3 instead of going
back in history it actually is taking
your git history ahead but as a part of
this commit you are undoing some part of
the work that was done as a part of C3
in short you're removing a commit but to
remove a commit you're adding a new
commit and this is why you're doing it
because there are a bunch of other
people who are your losing this
repository collaboratively and what plan
to get ahead in terms of History they
cannot afford to go back in history and
modify something in history all right
the command to do this is called the get
revert command
so let me take up this repository which
has got a bunch of commits in it and if
at all I do a git log
pretty one line
I have these bunch of comments
and C1 I've added a file in C to our
other file in C3 I've added one more
file and in C4 I made some changes and
this is the latest commit and this is
the oldest commit so if at all I see the
contents of the git folder it contains
M1 m2m3 and M4 and let's say looking at
the previous use case that I mentioned I
may want to get rid of this particular
comment
I want to get rid of the C3 which is
nothing but I've added a file called
m3.text but I added it by mistake I need
a better way of fixing it possibly I
look at it later on but for now I don't
want this particular commit and the
changes that were made as a part of that
commit to exist so the better way to do
that is using the git revert command so
git revert and the commit ID whatever I
want to revert so if I want to revert
this
I copy this particular commit ID and
bear in mind that considering a reset
revert works on one commit at a time so
I can do one commit revert at a time I
can Club a bunch of them together and do
one commit but otherwise the revert
always works on one commit at a time so
get revert
face this
essentially what I'm trying to do I'm
trying to undo this particular commit
while I'm undoing this commit what does
git do it safely adds a new commit and a
part of this new commit It undoes
Whatever changes that were done as a
part of this comment so if I say git
revert this
all right I forgot to mention a message
which is why this window is showing up
but that message is good for me I say
write and quit
all right and if I do a git log
all right if you see this C1 still is
there in history and our history is
going ahead from C5 I see another commit
but what was there as a part of this
comment actually is getting rid of this
commit C3 so if at all I see my files
here there's only M1 M2 and M4
M3 was added as a part of C3 now I've
gotten rid of M3 by getting rid of the
revert command for C3 so this is a
better way of undoing things
now that we have acquainted ourselves
with few of those basic gig commands let
me get into very very interesting topic
regarding git which is about branching
the topic is interesting because git
deals with branches in a completely
different way compared to any other
version control tool in most of the
Version Control tools whenever you
create a new Branch a complete copy or a
subsect of the whole repository is
created which in my opinion is very very
cost inefficient because it's a very
very expensive operation both in times
of time and the disk space however in
Git You just create a very very
lightweight movable pointer whenever you
create a branch there is no folder or no
copy of the repository that is created
in short the branches are very very
inexpensive and great so go ahead and
create any number of branches that you
need however once you create your
branches do all the work relating to
that branch in that specific branch and
once you've completed your task go ahead
and merge your branches back into your
base branch and then delete the branch
let me go ahead and create a repository
with some branches in this and give you
a demonstration of that
so let me go back to my base directory
which is git demo and then I'm going to
create a new folder here
I'll create a folder called Arc details
all right this is my folder here
all right I navigate into this folder
and let me create a repository here I
initial as a repository and Dot git
folder is created without any files in
it so let me create a few files in it
say notepad name dot text
organization name
I create a name.txt within this maybe
I'll create one more file in this
Notepad
employees dot text
foreign
I just put in some content in this save
this content
all right
so if I try to get status I just see two
files in it so let me go ahead and add
these two files and let me commit my
changes it's okay
commit hyphen am or iPhone m
First Command
so if I do a git log
I see only one commit and there are two
files here you can see those two files
that is here
all right so at this stage let me go
ahead and create a new branch
and the command for creating new branch
is get Branch name of the branch so let
me name my branches Bangalore Branch blr
branch
and this created a branch but I don't
see any changes in the folder structure
or in the file that exists here I've
just created this Branch so if it all I
do a git branch
I see these two branches and whatever
star means I am currently in this master
Branch so let me go ahead and get into
the blr branch at this moment the number
of files that exist in this repository
is same there's absolutely no change in
any of the branches both master and blr
Branch point to the same snapshot
so let me get into
the other branch and the command to do
that is git checkout
plr Branch I've actually switched into
Bangalore Branch if you see the content
of the files there's exactly two files
the way it was earlier because I have
created a branch from my base branch
which is the master branch and when I
created a branch there were two files
existing here if you see the content of
these files they would all be the same
all right so let me create a file that
is specific to Bangalore branch so I
will just say Notepad
maybe I want to put down the address of
this organization specific to Bangalore
in this address dot text so I say
notepad address dot text
we'll say simply learn
Bangor office
say located in
some arteries
I would say Bangalore
foreign
of this file
and I'm creating all this new file in
this blr Branch so I would sync it add
Dot
I would say git commit hyphen m
angalore
branch
comment
all right if you see this now I have an
address.txt which is there only in the
Bangalore branch that I am presently on
now let me switch back to my master
Branch the command to do that is git
checkout
Master Branch if you remember when I
forged out or when I created a new
Branch from the master Branch I didn't
have this address dot text in it so let
me go back to git git checkout Master
branch and keep noticing this particular
what happened to the address dot text
it kind of disappeared how did that
happen it's all because of this magical
git folder so what happened is now git
knows that when you are in the master
Branch the file that was there in the
Bangalore branch which was called the
address dot text didn't exist
so git is playing around with the file
system snapshot so if I come back let's
say I come back to git checkout
Bangalore branch
if you see this the address.txt file
appears
so this particular file is only present
in the branch and git is playing around
with the file system snapshot by moving
the pointers across and ensuring that
whenever I am switching to Bangalore
Branch I see this address dot text when
I go back to my master Branch I don't
say this Bangalore branch
contents which is the address dot text
all right now that I created this Branch
maybe I may need to push this onto the
server so let me go ahead and create a
particular repository structure on the
server similar to whatever we did in our
previous exercise
so the name of the folder needs to be
exactly this one so let me copy this
and let me create a repository very
quickly
go here and say new Repository
all right this
is the name of the Repository get Branch
demo this is what I'm going to put in as
a description I would say public I don't
want any readme files in it because I
already have a repository I will just
say create a repository
all right let me use
the SSH URL yeah this is the SSH URL
this is good for me so let me copy this
URL
let me add it here
I'm linking my local repository with the
server and I would let me come back to
my master branch
let me first push my master Branch so I
would say git push hyphen U origin
master
it asks for my passphrase
all right
push my master Branch it looks good it
says New Branch Master is created so if
I go back to my server and it will
refresh
if you see it says only one branch
and it says what is the name of the
branch master
if you see the contents that is
employees.txt and name dot text now
let's try to push the other branch that
is there the command to do that is a
little different compared to
the way we created it on the track
because on the client we created the
branch with a git Branch command now
this Branch doesn't exist on the server
and I need to push this new Branch onto
the server so the command would be
get push hyphen new origin and the name
of the brand that I want to specifically
push
all right now it created a branch out
here
let me do a refresh of this
all right it says two branches
if we get into this Bangalore Branch I
will see the address dot text if at all
I go back into Master Branch I would not
see this under stock text
wonderful
now let me do one thing let me try to
get the changes from the brands that I
created back into the master branch that
is what I would mean by merging I would
want the changes that is there as a part
of the Bangalore Branch to come back
into my master Branch so if I go to
click checkout
Bangalore Branch I see this address.net
this is there only as a part of
Bangalore Branch now assuming that I am
done with the changes from the Bangalore
Branch I want to get those changes back
into my master so let me come back
to my master branch
and the way to merge in the changes is
get merge so what is that you want to
merge I want to merge Bangalore Branch
changes and where will it merge it will
merge it into the current brands that
I'm on presently I'm in the master
Branch so this command would merge the
changes from the Bangalore Branch into
your master Branch so with this if we'll
keep looking here the content that was
there that was added as a part of
Bangalore branch which is nothing but
the address dot text this file should
appear as soon as we do a merge
all right so it happened quickly and you
would see this address dot text that is
here so if you see let's check the
contents in terms of the git log
all right so there's only one branch
that we had earlier which had only one
commit right now we are at this
Bangalore Branch commit which was there
as a part of the Bangalore Branch commit
so with this change let me push this
change onto the server as well git push
origin master
okay those changes were pushed to the
server and now
if at all I do a refresh out here
okay I mean two branches
the princess's Master even if I'm in
master plans I should see this address
dot text that is there even if I'm in
the Bangalore Branch the content is all
same because we immersed these two
branches now that I've merged this
Branch I don't need this Branch anymore
so I would go ahead and delete this
locally as well as push it onto the
server so that it gets deleted from the
server as well so delete Branch locally
the command is get
Branch hyphen D and the name of the
branch
only thing you need to ensure is that
you should not be currently on that
branch which you're trying to delete so
I would say get brands and I'm presently
in the master Branch so I can go ahead
and delete the other Branch so get
Branch hyphen D Bangalore branch
all right this got rid of our Bangalore
Branch locally
if at all I don't get Branch hyphen V it
shows there's only one branch as of now
however this Branch would still exist on
the server because Server doesn't know
anything about the changes that we have
done we need to specifically push our
changes onto the server
okay there are two branches still here
so let me go ahead and push these
changes so that the branch gets deleted
from the server as well the command to
do that is get
push
origin
hyphen hyphen delete and the name of the
branch
all right
so this went ahead and deleted the
branch from the server let's check that
okay if you see now there's only one
branch
these are the basic steps that you would
need to know before you work with any of
the branches within git and as I said
before the branches are very very
inexpensive in great go ahead and create
any number of branches that you want but
just ensure that once you create your
branch finish off your task and once you
finish off your task go ahead and delete
the branch and before you delete the
brands please ensure that you merge in
the branches so that you get in or take
in the work that was done as a part of
that particular Branch to summarize the
git branching commands are as follows to
create a new Branch you issue a command
git Branch the name of the branch and
this would automatically spin off or
create a new Branch from the existing
Branch from where you issue this command
if you are on the master branch and if
you execute this command get Branch new
underscore Branch it creates a new
underscore Branch from the master Branch
once you create a new branch in order to
get into this Branch you would type in
git check out the name of the brand inch
this would automatically switch the file
system snapshot between different
branches now the branches that are
created are by default created on the
local repository in case you want to
push any specific Branch onto the server
you would have to issue a command get
push hyphen U origin and the name of the
branch so this will ensure that the
contents of the new Branch are pushed
onto this server at any time if you want
to list out all existing branches on
your local repositories the command
would be git Branch hyphen AV assuming
that you did all your work in a new
branch and you're happy with the changes
you would want to bring back those
changes into the master Branch the
command to merge the contents of any new
Branch into a master Branch would be git
merge and the name of the branch this
would automatically merge the branch
contents that you specified into the
brands on which you currently reside if
at all you're on the master branch and
if you issue a command git merge new
underscore Branch this would merge the
contents of the new Branch onto the
master Branch so once you merge the
contents of any branch you would
possibly want to go ahead and delete
this Branch so the command to delete
those branch locally is get Branch
hyphen capital D and the name of the
branch this again would delete the
branch locally in order to make this
change on the server which is in order
to remove this Branch from the server
the command to do that is git push
origin hyphen iPhone delete and the name
of the branch this would also delete the
brands that you created on the server
welcome everyone to this lesson by
simply nowhere in which we are going to
talk about the git merge conflict of
this one now we all have worked on gate
and we know that gate is a very good
version control system which we have all
together but how to resolve a problem
which is known as git merge because
during the developers check in or do any
kind of merge activity this isn't common
problem which they face on daily basis
now this isn't something which we are
going to talk about in this so that we
can give an kind of an insight to all
those developers and to other particular
different people who are using the Git
Version Control System here now what
exactly we are going to talk about here
we are going to talk about what exactly
is Git Version Control System we also
going to talk about what exactly is the
basic git commands used in git and then
we are going to talk about that what
exactly is a merge conflict all about
and then the different type of merge
conflicts which we encounter while doing
any kind of merging or any kind of
modifications and then how to resolve
these merge conflicts faced by a
particular individual or a particular
developer
and then the last one is that the
various git commands which is involved
in resolving these conflicts
and then we will be going on with a
small demo to better understand that how
these conflicts can be resolved all
together right so let's first of all
talk about that what exactly is a Git
Version Control System now git is a kind
of a version control system which we
basically used for storing a kind of
source code there which can be used for
storing a source code of
java.net Android node.js different kind
of programming languages can be stored
all together in this version control
system so in an organization you will be
having a full-fledged Version Control
System known as git now you may be
having different projects different
repositories multiple developers
multiple collaborators working on
different different projects so it's a
very extensive tool which is used by
different developers and in fact it is
not only limited to Developers a lot of
other people also exactly use this
specific tool now the main task of using
this tool is to perform a better
coordination of the work here among the
different people among the different
developers and also to have a proper
track of the particular progress of the
specific project so using the repository
you can see that over the period of time
you can do the tracking that how the
different commits are happening here how
the different source code modifications
are being done so the complete status
and the complete stats you will be able
to get from this a kind of a Version
Control System here now it's mainly used
for source code management here in any
particular software development process
or a particular team here so it's a very
important and in fact a key tool for any
kind of development project so the
development cannot survive without
having a Git Version Control System
now git favors both programmers and
non-technical users now if you are a
programmer definitely you will be using
it for storing the source code and
having those particular files having
some dotnet source code Java or some
particular source code present there but
in fact if you're not a particular
developer if you're not a programmer you
are working as a non-technical job so in
that case also you can store it for
keeping your project files best example
a particular devops engineer can also
use these repositories to store their
Version Control Systems to have these
scripts Python scripts shell scripts
configuration management tools scripts
any kind of automation scripts they can
store they want to have it they can keep
use of these particular Version Control
System here so it's not a dedicated tool
for a particular developers anyone who
wants to utilize the features of Version
Control System can make use of this
specific tool
in fact it allows multiple users also to
work together so different people and
different programmers can collaborate
with each other with the help of this
particular specific tool here
and it can also handle large projects if
you feel that you are working on a
particular big project which is having
multiple repositories multiple projects
are there so in that situation Git
Version Control System Will Survive and
will provide you a better performance in
different different aspects so it's a
very good tool for you to handle which
big projects where you are involved with
multiple changes multiple programmers
multiple collaborators and different
kind of source codes
now what are the different basic
commands which we use in git to manage a
git repository now first of all the a
very basic command of a git over here is
git config
whenever we work with any kind of git
repository locally when we do a git
clone and we manage or we do the
modification to the git repository
locally there so in that situation we
often have to provide some details like
the username email ID so that whenever
we provide whenever we do some kind of
commits the author details should be
submitted according to that so in that
situation we have the particular command
called git config which will definitely
help us to do some configurations so
that we will be able to have some
configurations configured and we will be
able to have some author details or some
additional parameters so all those
things we can configure using this git
config command here now
if you want to initialize a local
repository now you are not working on a
remote repository and you want to
initialize a local repository in that
case you can use the git init command in
a specific folder so that you can
convert that a simple folder in a
full-fledged Git Version Control
repository so init command is used to
initialize a local empty bear git
Repository
next command is git add now git and
command is used whenever we do any kind
of modifications or into my local
repository so that file will be present
into the working area in into the
working copy over there now the moment
you run the git add command on couple of
files or on a individual file so what
will really happen that all those files
will be added to the staging area now
why these files are adding to the
staging area so that at any moment of
time when you run the git commit command
these files will be picked up from the
staging area and will be preserved
permanently into the git repository or
running any kind of git commit command
now git commit command will only pick up
those files which is present in the
staging area so if you have done
modifications to 200 files or 2030 those
kind of files there if you do the git
add command only for five six files so
only those five five six files will be
taken care in case of a particular
commit so you need to make sure that you
select the desired amount of files
before doing any kind of get commit
activity
right now next command which we have
here is get div command now git diff
command is a kind of Base tool which we
have here which really helps us to
understand that how we can check the
difference between two files and in fact
this git diff command can also be used
to see the difference between two
different branches also so if you feel
that if you have done some changes to
the file to a specific content here now
if you want to see the difference
between your particular head revision
number and whatever the modifications do
you have done right now so in that
situation you can run get div command it
will let you know that what the
different kind of changes and
modifications you have done so if at any
moment of time before doing any kind of
commits you want to do some kind of
review you want to see that what
different changes you have done so in
that case you can go for the git diff
command so get div command used to see
the content the difference or the
modifications which you have done
recently to the specific file
right and the last one we have already
discussed the git commit command which
commits the changes to the Head revision
number and this comments are something
which is stored locally and you will not
be doing the direct commits to the
remote repository so commit is something
which is done into your local repository
only but yes this is the last stage of
doing a modification say once the
comment is done it will directly modify
your history your git repository there
and the changes will be permanently
preserved into the repository so git
command is primarily used for
permanently preserving the changes into
your local Repository
right so these were some of the commands
there now there are some further
commands Also let's discuss about them
now next command is get reset command at
any moment of time you want to do some
undo activity for some local changes
done to your local repository into your
git repository in that case we can use
the git reset command then next command
is git status now git status command
will show you the state of the working
directory and the staging area so both
this area will be shown when you run the
git status command if you have done any
kind of modifications to the working
area that will also be visible to you
and if you add some files to the staging
area that also will be displayed using
the git status command so git status
command is very important because
ultimately it lets us know that how the
different things and then how the
different files are modified over here
right the next thing is git merge here
now git merge is a very specific command
which is used to move the changes from
one branch to another now at any moment
of time if you feel that you are working
on some other Branch like develop Branch
or some other feature branch and you
want to move the changes from this
feature Branch to the master Branch so
in that case you don't have to do the
commits all together again in the master
Branch all you can do is that you can go
to the master branch and Trigger the
merge activity so this merge activity
will check what is the difference
between the two branches and whatever
commits is missed out it will also be
synced back into the master brand so get
much actively helps us to move the
changes from one branch to another one
next one is the git push command here
now git push command will eventually
help you to move the changes from your
local uh to move the different comments
from your local repository to the remote
repository now in this case what happens
that if you are working in offline mode
if you have done some couple of commits
now git push will help you to sync those
comments back to the share to the remote
repository now these remote repository
can be GitHub with bucket or gitlab that
is a different story but yes all your
changes will be synced or will be moved
from your local repository to the remote
repository right and the last one is the
get poll get pull is an opposite
activity of push here now you might have
seen that some other developers are also
doing some check-ins or some push
activity to the remote repository now if
you still work on an old version of your
source code it may cause a lot of
problem for you so at frequent intervals
you may have to pull the changes or you
may have to download some changes from
the particular Network or from the
remote repository now once that is done
you will be able to see that those
particular changes will be pulled down
and you will be pretty much able to do
the uh you will be able to fetch and
download the changes from the remote
repository to your local repository here
so this is an activity which really
helps us to understand that how we can
pull some changes from the remote
repository to your local repository so
that you can have the latest source code
which might be pushed by some other
developers or by some other
collaborators so that you can always
work on the latest source code into your
local system so this is again a
mechanism in which we are trying to see
that what are the different git commands
we can explore and we can utilize here
to interact with the git repository so
this was some of the basic commands
which we can use for managing in the
gate repositories here now let's talk
about that what exactly is a merge
conflicts
now merge conflict is something which
gets originated the moment we do some
kind of merging activity now merging is
in process in which we move some source
code from one branch to another now all
the developers cannot work on the same
piece of Branch there so what really
happens that in that situation all the
developers mainly work on some couple of
branches and then they all collaborate
to some other Branch or different
developers try to push their changes
from the local repository to remote
repository so in all these situations
the source code gets move from one
location to another now what happens in
as per this diagram we have a remote
repository over here now all we are
trying to do is that we are trying to
push some source code over here from a
particular developer here now he is
doing the pull and push activity and
this another developer is there who is
also doing the pull activity here so
merge conflicts uh basically happens
then for example this uh particular
developer a is trying to do some push
right so that push is almost done here
and when the particular developer V is
trying to push the particular results or
try to push its own content to the
remote repository he got a merge
conflict which means that his particular
developer B merge activity is canceled
is deferred here now it could be a
possibility because of the changes on
the difference on the two piece of
source code there so let's talk about
that
now in order to prevent such kind of
conflicts developers usually provided
with the isolated branches so that they
can work on their branches and once the
development is done they can do a single
merge and they can sync their changes
into a single Branch so the git merge
command combines separate branches and
resolves any conflicting edits over
there so once the developers are done
with the specific changes with the
modifications to the source code later
on they can combine those things they
can work on these components and they
can resolve all these conflating
modifications right so a merge conflict
is an event that takes place when git is
unable to resolve the differences in the
source code between the two commits
automatically
normally the gate is having the
capability to understand that okay these
are the two different piece of source
code which is getting pushed to a remote
repository but in any case it does not
happens automatically there is any kind
of conflict which arises over there and
git is not able to take any kind of
decisions so in that situation we will
be able to get a merge conflate now it
could be a possibility that one merge
can happen successfully then the next
merge will be canceled and will be
differed due to this much conflicts so
git can automatically merge the changes
only if the commits are on different
lines or the branches here so if at any
moment of time you are devoting from the
process you are having some different
lines of source code so that is where
the merge conference comes into the
picture now what are the different kind
of merge conflicts which we normally
face uh the main types of words conflict
is is
first of all there are two points where
we can say that a merge can happen or
can come into a conflicted State the
very first one is the uh started the
merge process now if at any moment of
time there are changes in the working
area or working directory and we are
moving or these changes are getting
moved to the particular working area of
the stage area of the current project so
during the merge activity itself the
particular merge will fail because there
are some changes or there are some kind
of modifications which is right now
present over here in the working area so
in this case conflicts happen due to
pending changes now for instance you
have done some modifications with
changes now you are planning to do the
commit but before that you felt that I
want to do some kind of merge now since
there are some pending changes which is
available there into your working area
so what will happen that your merge will
definitely slightly well there itself so
before even starting before even in
initializing the merge as in particular
pre-check your merge activity will fail
there itself so in that situation you
have to either remove those pending
changes or you have to resolve those
pending changes before even going for
the merge activity second
during the merge process definitely if
you are getting some conflict so the
merge conflicts gets originated so the
failure during the merge process uh
indicates that there is an conflict
between your local branch and the branch
being merged right so you're trying to
move the changes from one branch to
another so it means that there are some
particular conflicts which is coming up
in the particular branch in which you
are trying to do the merge so in this
case git resolves as much as possible so
if there is any kind of difference in
the source code in the comments and the
different line of source code there so
git automatically try to resolves it as
much as possible but at any moment of
time it's not able to do it's not able
to manage in that case a particular
human Interruption is required so that
we can merge or we can resolve this
particular conflicts manually there so
these are the two types of situations in
which a particular merge can enter a
particular conflicted area area
now how to resolve these merge conflicts
now what happens that in order to
resolve these merge conflicts the simple
way to do this is that we open the file
which is in conflicted uh status now
once that is done you do the required
changes whatever source code you feel
you want to proceed you will select that
source code you will use that source
code and once the addition or editing of
the file is done so what you can do is
that you can run the pretty much
straightforward command called git add
to add that file to the staging area and
then what you can do is that you can do
the git commit activity so that the
particular merge conflicts can be
resolved and you will be able to see a
merge here now this is a something which
is known as one of the best approach for
resolving the merge conflicts because
even if it comes up if git is not able
to handle it automatically and it
requires for you to manage it manually
here so definitely in that situation we
have to open the source we have to
select that which portion of a source
code we want to keep do the
modifications manually and then follow
the traditional approach to perform a
custom commit so git add and get commit
command you will be doing there in that
situation to have a particular final
merge executed all together so this is
the steps which we can follow to perform
a custom uh to resolve a particular
custom merge conflicts over here
right now the various git commands which
we can use to resolve the conflicts here
now get log hyphenation merge is in
command which helps us to list down all
the commits that are causing the
particular conflict here if at any
moment of time your merges fail down and
you want to see that what are the
different commits which is causing the
issue here probably you might be you
know ignoring some commits which is not
that much important or you can manually
overwrite the content so that those
conflicts data can also be added and
whatever changes you are trying to add
that also should be modified
second command get div command you can
always use the uh to check the
difference between the particular files
between the Repository
git checkout is something which you can
use to particularly check out a file so
that if you want to check out the latest
content of a specific file or a folder
so in that case you can make use of this
git checkout command here so git
checkout command will definitely help
you to understand that how we can go for
or how we can do the checkout of this
particular repository or a particular
file here
right so then we have a command called
git reset hyphen iPhone mixed so git
reset hyphen iPhone images and command
to undo the changes of to the working
directory and whatever the particular
changes you have so that will be undo
there and it will be able to do the undo
changes to the working area and the
staging area here now then we have git
merge a hyphen iPhone award which will
be used in order to exit the merge
process and return back to the state
before the margin begin if you're not
able to resolve the merge conflicts
manually also so in that situation we
will be aborting the merge situation or
a git merge over here
and the last one is git reset so git
reset command is used at in time to of
merge conflicts to reset the conflicted
file so that what we can happen that we
can go back to the previous situation
before even starting or the state before
the merge activity was started there so
git reset will eventually help me to
reset all the files which is in
conflicted area and a latest files will
be checked out and will be replaced so
these are some couple of commands which
we can actually use in order to resolve
the merge conflicts into your git
repository now that was something which
we were trying to understand that what
exactly the git merge was there and how
the git merge originated and how they
get particular merge conflicts gets
created and how we can resolve it now
let's go for a proper demo on this one
so that we can understand it properly
that how exactly git merge conflicts
rail work and how we can resolve it
now this is the git bash which we have
installed to run some git commands now
in this one first of all I'm going to
create a two repositories so I'm going
to run the command called git init
a that will initialize a repository
get init B that will initialize a b
repository here so two repository I have
got A and B now in basis a what I'm
going to do is that I'm going to add the
remote so git remote add origin so I'm
just trying to add the origin over here
so the origin over here in this one is
the maven build so this is a repository
which I have got into my GitHub account
the moment you do this what next you can
do over here is that you can run the
particular next git pull command to
fetch the latest updates here right so
next move to the particular next command
here
now when you do this what will happen
that all the changes which is present in
the remote repository are Central
repository will be available here also
right so you will be able to see some
couple of files all together here now
the same activity you have to do in the
particular B directory also or in the uh
particular B repository also so you have
to add the URL the remote URL here
and in this case also we are trying to
fetch the particular values here now
what will happen that uh we will be
doing some modification in the
particular a repository and then we will
be pushing that uh change to the remote
repository and then through the B when
we try to push the changes so in that
situation we will try to see that what
really happens do we really get the
merge conflicts because both of them
although is trying to do the changes to
the central repository but these two
repository represents two different uh
local repositories probably in two
different developers machines over here
so that's what we are trying to
replicate here so I'm going back to the
a directory here so that I would be able
to do some changes all together so I'm
just opening readme.md file here so
pretty much I'm just trying to add some
vertical changes over here to this uh
particular file so this is what we are
trying to do here
now let me add some particular
additional and a particular new line
over here in the file and then save the
content now once this is done I will be
able to see that yes there is a
particular change which is done all
together here so you will be running git
add command
and then get commit command to save the
commits all together
so we are giving a particular commit
here so that we will be able to identify
that this is something which we have
committed from a repo a now once this is
done I will be doing the push activity
so that I can push these changes to the
particular remote or the central
repository here so exactly what we did
over here so far we have a particular
downloaded remote repository in a
repository a and then we are doing some
changes some modifications and once
those modifications are done we are
pretty much changing or putting up that
new commit all together to the GitHub
repository so this is what we are trying
to do so far over here in this one so
this git push activity will take the
particular axis
right so when I do the particular push
activity here so if the credentials are
saved then that's fine otherwise it will
ask for the particular username and
password all together here so that will
be asked by the particular activity here
so it will ask for the password so all
you have to do is that you have to just
share that password and your git push
activity should be passed on or should
be you know done there and as you can
see that changes really got moved to the
GitHub repository now sometimes the
credentials get expired so you may get
some particular message saying that you
have to put some password there a
particular interactive window will be
open there and you have to prompt or you
have to provide that password and
according to that it will proceed
further
right so this will eventually help you
to move the changes into the GitHub
repository all together so all of your
changes will be pushed to the GitHub
Central Repository
right after some time it really pushes
my comments to the remote repository it
will take some time depending on the
network connectivity and the kind of
changes you are trying to upload so now
since uh my particular repository is
done so what I can do is that I can
further go back to the particular
directory here now what we can do is
that we can go back to the beat
repository over here and in this case
also I am just trying to do some
modifications so for instance that uh
I'm just trying to do the changes here
to the readme file again of kind of a
changes in this one now in this case I
am trying to delete this line the last
line I'm trying to delete here or a
couple of modifications I want to do
over here like
added data from repo
and then for the most I want to have let
me do some arrangement like let me have
this data added all together over here
or I can add it
yes so data is added and this data is
removed so the idea is that we can do
different kind of free shuffling of the
data up and down so that we can
understand that how it really works so I
have shuffled the data I have removed a
couple of lines and let's see that how
it works right so I have even added some
couple of lines of both here in this new
line I have added one line I have
removed from the last and this
particular line I have shifted five six
line up over here now let's me save this
file and then run the git add command
after this we are going to run the
particular comment here saying
commit from
repo B
once commit is done same activity
pushing it to the remote repository now
let's see what really happens now when
we are trying to push this particular
change to the remote repository after
the change was post from repo a it will
throw an error saying that the
particular due to the conflicts the
updates are simply rejected here right
so in this case what really happens that
because we are having a different stream
of source code in a remote repository
and from local repository you are trying
to push some different line of source
code so what next you need to do is that
first of all you need to do the activity
called git pull
hyphen hyphen revised origin master so
you're going to pull the changes from
the remote repository so that you should
be able to get some particular content
all together in this particular B over
here now the moment you run this let's
wait for this activity
now once that is done you will be able
to see that you are seeing a message
saying that conflicts are there so first
of all you have to resolve this
conflicts and then it will be proceed
further you have some couple of options
like you have to resolve the conflicts
manually and uh because git is not able
to handle it otherwise once they get
conflicts is resolved you can run git
rebase or iPhone continue if you want to
skip this commit so you can say git
replace hyphen iPhone skipped and if you
want to abort the particular this rebase
here so in that case you can run git
Freebase hyphen iPhone aboard
now uh since we want to manage or we
want to resolve this conflict manually
over here so what we need to do is that
we need to open the merge tool on this
one so once you open the merge tool from
there you will be able to resolve those
changes manually and then continue with
the array base so let's go with the git
merge tool here so we are going to use
the command called git merge tool now
when you run this so what will happen
that uh it will process it will open the
a normal VI command line over here and
all the files will be processed all
together now uh this is the
modifications right which is uh you know
which is done over here so we are just
trying to see that which particular file
or what resultant file we want to
configure here
right now in this case since you are
able to see that this is the final file
which is present and uh here exactly the
merge conflict comes up because you can
see that three different files are given
to you in uh this side so you have some
files in which you added new two lines
and here you added this line there this
artifact will be there now here you also
added this a particular new line instead
of having this line default here so what
exactly happens when you scroll down you
will be able to see that where exactly
is the particular issue or what are the
different modifications you start there
so in this one if you scroll up and down
you will be able to see that what
exactly it happens so the main area of
conflict is first of all this area so
this should not be there as per git as
per the normal file but yes if it is
there so we have to see whether we want
to continue or we want to proceed uh
with this particular specific file or
not so yes so I will say that okay uh
let's remove
this line let's not uh
let's copy this line
let's delete this line here and
add the line over here in this one and
uh
please this line also from here so this
is what I'm just trying to make use of
here now here I just want to have the
particular
line paste it okay delete it so this
line I will
okay so I have added this line in the
final I'm just trying to resolve this
conflicts manually I'm just editing this
file here trying to remove this one this
one this one and uh this one so this is
how my particular
final file looks like and I am going to
go to this one now you have resolved the
conflicts manually by doing the
modification to the file now just press
column WQ save the file over here and uh
then close the other files also
right so this is how I have done the
modifications and I should be able to
continue further now so what I'm going
to do is like I'm going to run command
git previous
continue now once that is done so the
particular commit which uh or the
modifications which you have got over
here so that is something which is
totally done and yes the Revis is
finalized over here now again this is
the manual modifications which you have
done so you should be good to go to push
to remote repository so again in this
case what you're going to do is we're
going to run like git push
before that if you want to check the
particular git log so you can check the
particular git log over here so the last
commit which we would try to doing like
commit from repo B is also available
over here right so A and B both changes
are present now so we should be able to
push the changes to remote Repository
so it will take some time to do the push
and as you can see it's trying to uh put
some content so we'll still wait for the
final confirmation so that we can ensure
that yes all the conflicts is resolved
and yes that's correct all the
particular conflicts are resolved and we
should be able to see both commit a and
commit B into the repository so let's go
back to the GitHub portal and see that
if we really got those particular
comments in that
so let's when we access our particular
repository on GitHub so we should be
able to see that uh we have got an
activity that uh the commit is checked
in there so if you go to the comments
part you should be able to see that you
have got these commits gun process all
together if you click on any one of the
commit you will be further able to see
also that what different changes you
actually moved so this is the way that
how you can resolve the conflicts and
you can take care of the changes from
two different developers or for two
different push activity so that's it for
this particular demo I hope you liked it
thanks everyone today's topic is learn
HTML in 10 minutes let's begin
first we'll go through a quick
introduction to basic web architecture
to understand how the internet works
then we'll understand what exactly HTML
is
after that we'll have a look at what CSS
then we'll go through JavaScript
and in the end we will create a simple
web page using HTML and CSS to gain a
better understanding of the HTML tags
so without further Ado let's begin
now what exactly is the basic web
architecture now web architecture is
made up of three essential elements
that's the website that is the front end
of a web application that is visible to
the user then there is the server which
constitutes the back end of a web
application and holds and manages all
the data and finally there's the IP
address that is the address assigned to
a website in order to be accessible on
the internet
first up let's have a look at what
website is so your browser starts by
loading the main HTML file and then the
CSS and JavaScript
the user interacts with the website and
is not concerned with the backend of an
application now secondly we have the
server once you've developed your
website you'll have to host it on your
server to make it accessible on the
internet
server along with the database contains
all the data of a website and
facilitates user interaction
lastly there's IP address which is the
third element of the web architecture
now website is hosted on an IP address
we put a domain name over that IP
address the same way we put names over
people's phone numbers
when you type a domain name in the
browser it will give you the server call
the server will then send over the
website to you
next what is HTML HTML is the most
widely used markup language for
developing and structuring web pages on
the internet
it defines the structure of websites and
formats these web pages
so what exactly is CSS then now CSS is a
simple design language used for making
web pages look more beautiful and
presentable
it can be attached to any HTML element
to style it or even position it
according to the developer's choice
then you must be wondering what exactly
is Javascript
now JavaScript is a powerful interpreted
language targeted for web development it
is used for making web pages interactive
and bringing the web pages to life
so now let's create your first website
now HTML short for hypertext markup
language is the coding standard for
documents designed for web browsers
consisting of a series of elements or
tags and which can be used to structure
a web page right so these elements can
include headings paragraphs div
containers tables and more HTML tags are
nested meaning there are opening and
closing tags with the content in between
those tags so now let's write a simple
HTML code that will help you understand
the basics of the language so for this I
am using the text editor that is Visual
Studio code you can go ahead and
download this text editor from their
official website so here I've created a
simple dot HTML file in my vs code and
I've added the initial HTML files
now let me explain to you one by one
now doctype is not so much of a tag but
it is more of an instruction now this
indicates the browser that the document
type to be served to the user is in fact
an HTML document now this doctype
instruction should always be included at
the very top of your HTML page next up
you have the HTML tag that is used to
contain all the web pages HTML code
right so it contains an opening and
closing tag with contents in between
them
the HTML tag can also have attributes
now for example there's the Lang
attribute allowing you to specify the
spoken language of the contents of the
page followed by the HTML tag there's
the head tag now this is the first
section of the code that contains all of
the information about the web pages
properties links and more it could have
Pages title description additional meta
tags and CSS code so here I've used the
title tag and let's give a title say
HTML
in 10 minutes
all right you can also add CSS to the
Head tag by using the style tag and
change the display styles of HTML
elements that are being used the next
section is the body tag now the body tag
contains all the displayable contents of
your web page including headings
paragraphs div containers tables and
more
now the HTML header tags are used to add
headings to a web page there are several
types of headings available for
developers to add to a web page right so
first off let's have a look at them I'm
going to create a simple H1 heading tag
and the message I'm displaying is this
is
the first heading
all right
after this I'm going to add a paragraph
tag which creates padding in the top and
bottom of the element to help separate
the text between each paragraph
right so I'm gonna add a P tag and Save
this is the paragraph tag
[Music]
after this let me add a simple h2 tag
which is
another heading Tab and say this is the
second heading
[Music]
also add line breaks which are helpful
from time to time if you want to provide
a single line break in your content you
can do so by adding the BR tag so here
let me just add one for
better understanding
now the HTML div tag defines a division
or a section in an HTML document that is
used as a container for other HTML
elements now these elements can include
content areas sidebars page bars page
headers Footers Etc
this tag is used to apply styles to HTML
elements that cannot be added otherwise
you can also make use of the HTML image
tag to add images to a web page now
these images in a web page are a very
common site and they can make the
website look more attractive so for that
we can use the image tag so say IMG
within which I mentioned the source
I'm adding the HTML logo so let me just
mention that here
and then I'm gonna provide width for it
and then a specific height
all right so when you save the file and
when you look at the browser
you can see that uh the first heading is
displayed then your paragraph tag is
displayed followed by the second heading
and then the image now let me show you
how you can add styles for some of these
uh headings and paragraph tags so here
in back in my first heading that let me
just say styles
and let me change the font
of the content that is being displayed
I'm going to change it to Career new
and for my paragraph tag let me display
the content in italics so I'll say font
style and make it italics
so let me save this and when I look at
the browser
you can see that the font has changed
and so has the font style here
so now we've covered a few important
HTML tags used to develop a web page now
there are many other tags available for
almost everything you'd want to add to a
web page now all of these are available
on the internet for you and you can use
them in your website so it's time for us
today to talk about something very
interesting feature of the HTML because
this particular session which we are
recording it for you it is designed
dedicated for HTML based Hands-On so in
this HTML page Hands-On we are expecting
that all of you are aware about the
basic concept of HTML as well as the CSS
so this
kind of learning is going to help you to
understand like how HTML and CSS can
connect together while offering you a
mini application the first application
on this track we're going to offer you
that is related to your HTML
registration page okay so as you know
for this particular registration
development application I would like to
use the visual studio code which is one
of the very very popular tool provided
by Microsoft so this tool we will be
using it for our mini application
development so let's get started with
this so step number one let me go back
and create a new folder now I will
create a new folder name called
registration
and inside this I would require two
files number one it's called index dot
HTML
and another one that is called
CSS we can say app dot CSS
so in index.html file we want some
started development so I want to start
with my HTML tag so
I already have this HTML based autofill
code provided by your Visual Studio code
so there are plugins are available
inside this so that you can
automatically create the basic structure
for this HTML which you can have the
HTML tag head tag as well as the body
tag and from this point onwards we will
start developing our code now so I want
to develop a registration page so in
this registration page I will start from
my form tag now so inside this form it
is saying like form action to something
I really do not have any backend so I
just leave it as a blank and here I will
start with my H1 tag where I want to say
register
after this register I want to offer the
paragraph tag
where I can say please
in this
form
two
register with us
register okay
okay now after that I would like to
start with horizontal row so HR
so
starting with my horizontal row
and pause this because see we would like
to organize our application and now
level at this level for I just want to
give the name called FF it's just the
name and after this FN stands for the
first name and within this label I would
like to use a b type which is a I would
say the Bold here I will pass fasting
bull attack is close it's a level
inside this level I would like to use
input tag here I will call input
applicable to text and offer few other
details also like I say a placeholder
please order will offer you what to be
filled I'm saying first name
is
the placeholder value after this name
equal to FN that is the stat for first
name after that id id is optional but if
you want to pass we'll use this idfn
right equal to f n and required
because I want this field cannot be
blank so this is my
first text box where I have this first
name with me
like that I will go ahead and talk about
my next property or password and for
password also I would like to have the
similar details with me
so this label I'll copy
and paste it below
and this is for
your password so we're given the name
call PSW
here we are saying password
and input available text so here I will
change input app equal to password
because password field details would not
be visible to you please here will say
placeholder I can say enter
password name equal to you can give PSW
I equal to we can give same PSW
so we have a password in a similar like
we would like to offer a confirm
password fields too I will copy this
line
and paste it again and here we can say
confirm password
you can say
cpsw again password enter
confirm password say PSW
and cpsw
now it's over after this we want to make
it as a horizontal row
closed
and once it is run then we'd like to
have the button with this
so here's the button we can say register
and here in my button I would like to
offer the type equal to submit
are we going to submit so that's it so
this is the simplest form I have it
now I would like to see how it really
looks like it so from here I would like
to open it Rebellion finder
let's open this
but it looks like that
right so this is what my formula form is
ready and now we would like to go back
and start developing my CSS in which I
will beautify my form to offer some more
details on this
well friends as we know the HTML page is
ready it's time to go back and start
developing a CSS to beautify my HTML so
inside the CSS I would like to start
with the tag which is account body
foreign
tag I can offer some basic setups but
I just want to keep the basic background
color now which is called
background hyphen color
I can just give the name for tea
that's a pattern color let's rest of the
things I can just leave it as it is now
for all the other properties I can say
box sizing
[Music]
go to iPhone box
after that dot container
container
and in this container we have to offer
certain benefits
now first thing you need to understand
which are the places I will be using the
container
you see here in my index.html file
when we talk about form actions and all
okay we say H1 register we haven't used
any container right now so let's get
added the container
do
foreign
container
okay and this particular div tag will
get closed only at the last
so the strip tag
to close at the last
here so I want to make the look and feed
for this complete container
in much more better ways so here in my
container we want to see
margin Auto
let's press enter here
margin
portal now with
50 percent
then adding
texting pixel
followed by background color
which you want white
then box shadow
this box Shadow we want to give some all
four Originals 20 pixel
continuation to save 20 pixel
and 0 pixel
and which color we want so I just say
rgba
this RGB just give the value called zero
again zero
and the value which you would want to
give to this Alpha because it is always
between 0 to 1 we are saying 0.7 that is
an opacity
well four properties as given now let's
see how it looks
yeah why because we haven't added a CSS
in my HTML so let's add the CSS so
inside my
browser HTML
now inside my head
let me add link
our L equal to style sheet href equal to
app plots uses
that's it
now let's see
there we go looks better now so this is
your container okay which you can see it
is having some Shadow I would like to
organize this all set of text boxes in
much more better way
so after this we want to offer the other
properties too looking for my input
go back to my app CSS
so after this container we want input
input again
time equal to
text
now also
to
input
type
equal to
password
here we offer few things number one
width
which is hundred percent
after
sorry
that padding
one second 15 pixels
then margin
you're offering five pixels
yeah
zero
22 pixel zero
followed by display
I will say inline block
inline block solid type order do you
want any border so I say none
and background
we can offer the color so we can say
all right smoke
that's it let's see in my HTML
awesome so this looks more beautiful
more organized so this is
your form but I want to make it even
more better now because I want to
perform the validation and in validation
we want to check how the focus will come
in so the beautification needs to be
added more here we want to offer the
same input type text input type password
I copy this
here
now here we want to offer background
color
we want to open the background color on
Focus
this has to be your focus
focus and here also on Focus
so now background color
we want to change to anything but other
typing we can just give
save and outline
no
okay so this is my for focus and for the
registration button
so here we see Dot
I do not have that class called register
button so I have to create this class
inside my
button
register BTN I would like to offer the
properties for those like background
color
teeth
followed by color
which is
White
then padding
we offer 16 pixels
then border
no
then cursor
I think it is better to have pointer
only
that width
100 percent
solved by margin
this Auto
then opacity
then I say 0.8
5 so this is for my registration version
let's see
wow this looks better now so this is a
full size button
so this is for my button and I want the
moment to take my cursor on button
the color should change or it should
look like a hover
copy this
over
and here we say opacity
I just pick the valuable one that's it
now you see now the color is changing
great so like this you see how the
conditions are working on a Plus on
register you see the messages
please fill the field blank and it is
changing the
when we talk about the situation called
Focus so in this it works like that when
I give the name
you see now how the background color is
changing now so it is little bit more
grayish color so friends this is what
your registration page with the basic
setup having this HTML as well as the
CSS together so this time we're going to
develop another very interesting example
using this HTML JavaScript and CSS
together and that is called working with
a quiz application these are one of the
very very interesting project will be
developing it from the scratch and I'm
sure that you will enjoy a lot
so what we will do we'll start creating
a new folder now first of all I'm going
to give the name call
HTML quiz
now I'm going to create a three files
inside this number one I'm gonna say
index.html
index.html then I need another file that
is called app.css
and the third file I'm going to create
an inside this that will hold the script
related part so we are saying script
torches
so we have total number of three files
ready with us now from HTML page we
would like to develop this HTML tags
first
so we'll go to the HTML and see
so we have got this basic HTML syntax
ready and from here we will start
working with the Dev tag first
here onwards Dev tag
so visit my Dev tag we would like to
create another div tag
foreign
class
to this particular div see we haven't
created a CSS but we would like to offer
some of the CSS classes available here
so you see
depth class equal to container
now we have got another Dave track
inside this we will set div
ID equal to question hyphen container
question iPhone
container so that is the name or ID of
this tip and we say class
equal to height
now within this div tag we would like to
offer some details but before that we
would like to create some embedded Dev
tags inside this so we're going to
create another depth tag here
and this tip ID
equal to
answer
answer hyphen buttons
so that's the ID name and we would like
to offer the class also
class equal to
BTN hyphen grid see again I'm telling
you these classes are just creating it
but we would like to use this in our CSS
okay so they are just the normal
classmates we are giving it right now
now insert this div tag
if you want to offer
some more details
now what exactly the details are number
one you would like to offer few buttons
now
button so we see a button class
equal to BTN
and after that you would like to give
the name called answer one
answer once so that I can have this
button class
copied three more times
and now we can change
the names to
here three
here four so we have total number of
four answers ready with us Dev tag is
getting closer another tip tag is
getting closed here and now here before
the last step tag is getting close we
would like to create another div tag
now inside this tip we say
plus equal to controls foreign
we want to offer few more buttons
button here we say button ID equal to
start button
start iPhone BTN
okay and then we say class
class equal to start
hyphen
ptn
space BTN and we say start here
now just copy this complete line
and put it again so rather than giving
the start button we say
next button and class equal to
next hyphen button
next iPhone button BTN and we'll give
additional property called height
foreign
next
let me make this S capital
and
two buttons we have created
after this div tag is getting closed
after that I would like to start another
type tag
and this is tag we will offer
class equal to score
okay and here
we would like to start working with a
span and here we will say spam ID equal
to
right hyphen
answer
or answers I can see
so after that a div tag is getting
closed
and that's it and it lasts the last step
tag is getting closed
which you can see it right now we would
like to use the script tag
but one more thing
this Dev tag I would like to close even
before
two div tags are getting close and this
is another tip type which is closed at
the end and here we want to include the
script tag
script
SRC equal to
script.js that's it our HTML page is
almost ready Let's review
and
yes I can see some standard buttons has
been created now we would like to look
make gives a better look and feel to
this kind of Button cell complete UI by
offering some awesome CSS
okay everybody so we'd like to start
working with CSS part now
so to work with the CSS we have to offer
few things
here we're providing a root and Victor's
wrote some basic settings we are
offering it number one
foreign
hyphen Hue hyphen neutral
sure
iPhone
hyphen hyphen Q
hyphen neutral the value given is equal
to 200.
after that we're giving call hyphen
hyphen hue
again hyphen round
this value we're giving is
zero
then we are saying hyphen hyphen here
hyphen
correct
so these three values we have given
followed by body
in this body we would like to offer few
details number one
hyphen hyphen hue
this we are making with a variable
how can happen you neutral the one which
we have already declared
okay now we will try to provide padding
so this padding we're giving zero
next property is margin
module also remain zero after that
display
foreign
after that width
we're providing width almost 100
followed by height
so height we are providing this call
once again 100
okay now we have called justify contents
let's justify Contents I can say Center
perfect going forward
align items
here we can say Center again
now background color
which color you would like to give it so
we can just use this option called hsl
in this we will like to use this war
again this in this world we are using
iPhone hyphen Q
and followed by
100 percent
comma 20 percent
these things and this is style we would
we would like to use in my index.html
page So within my head tag
well in index.html5 how you would like
to define the style so we always use
link
CSS so the value is automatically
style.csl but we would like to change to
app
s.css that's it
now let's see the final outcome
now it looks better
okay so it is only for the background
nothing else it is impacting now we want
to offer few more things into my CSS it
is only for the body
now we would like to go ahead with the
body Dot correct
body dot correct
we are providing
Q
or
and here you would like to offer
iPhone icon draw
and also sorry not wrong just hold
correct
foreign
body
dot Raw
body.com
so same thing I'd like to copy
so rather than correct
we're using Rock
well these two properties we have
defined
going forward we would like to start
working with a container
container inside my container I would
like to offer width
basic thing that we are providing 800
pixels
followed by Maxwell
this Max would be 80 percent
now going forward background color
background color we are offering White
that always looks better followed by
border radius
border radius that we are providing 5
pixels
after this padding
this padding will be 10 pixels
followed by box shadow
this box Shadow we can say zero
zero
10 pixels
2 pixels
so this is we have applied for the
container and container is used right
over here let's see
okay now it looks better
so this is where it comes under my
container now we would like to offer the
buttons
here in our CSS
we want to now offer the button colors
so dot
BTN
hyphen
great
well
in index.html file so we have a call
Button grid this button grid we would
like to start from here
between grid between grid display
Ed
followed by grid
iPhone template columns
so here we are saying repeat
in this repeat we are saying two
comma
Auto
then we would like to offer the gap
this Gap will be the 10 pixels
followed by margin
that will be the 20 pixels
and then 0.
this is for my button grid let's see
awesome so that looks pretty nice
now going forward we would like to apply
the styles of my button
so how my button will looks like in
well button grids we have created it now
we would like to go ahead with the
buttons
so dot ptn
followed by the details so
I can open hue
War
will be using neutral
also going forward we would like to use
border
so this border we want to use
12 pixels
or I would say one pixel
and install it
and hsl
values you would like to give it once
again
War
hyphen icon View
solid by
100 percent
30 percent
okay so these are the values for border
followed by background color
so we would like to use the same
details
now we would like to use background
color
so in background color we will just use
hsl rather than this
so high point Hue 100 and 50 percent
okay
followed by border radius
foreign
pixels
now padding
padding just 5 pixels
and 10 pixels
then color
this color will be white for sure
and the outline
outline we are using is none
last option cursor
so cursor we will be using pointer as
you should see
so
these are the details are available
which we want to use it
for my button
now the last option
you want to use it for the button hover
Dot vtn
Dot or
or
and for this pull forward
you want to say border color
this border color you would like to use
black
that's it let's see
awesome
so this looks pretty nice
as you can see right now here
well so
this is how my initial looks like it
okay now I also want to change
this
start button and next button both
so here we want to use Dot
start hyphen BTN
and also for
Dot
next iPhone PT
common look and feel for both font size
come on
1.5
REM
next font weight
now this font weight I want to keep bold
followed by padding
this padding is Big 10 pixels
and 20 pixels followed by 10 pixels 20
pixels
next cursor
will be as usual pointers
now we want to go ahead with the
controls
with Ctrl C display
s
followed by justify contents
justify content Services Center
followed by a line
items
here we say Center
and last option which is left is called
height
this height is a
display none
that's it let's check this out
well
so
this will be visible to me
so the moment I said start then with
other buttons will be visible so this is
how my program is well my CSS is all set
well let's get start working with the
script part now
this is a major part of your main code
development so here we will start
working with this const and here we will
say start
button equal to
document Dot
get element by ID and here it will give
the name call
start iPhone ptn
that's the name like this
I just copy this line
make it available here like we will call
start button
we have a call next button
and here
next button
click here another one
here we change the name and give the
name call question
container element
container
element
question
by ID
here we give the name call question
hyper container
question iPhone
container because this is already there
you see question hyphen container is
already there we're using question
hyphen container
like this we would like to use one more
and that is called question element
question
element
by ID here will be passing
question
followed by
foreign
element
answer buttons element
answers
or I can say answer buttons element
answer hyphen buttons
so naming convention must be chosen very
carefully
now we will provide
option called Shuffle question because
we want every time the questions to be
get shuffled
shuffled questions
Shuffle questions
current question index
Shuffle questions and current question
index
and we would like to provide one
variable called let
quiz score
zero
so we created those variables
now
once it is done we want to basically go
ahead and start creating a set of
questions for my application
so here we want to provide the questions
so we say const
questions
cost questions
equal to
array first question so I would like to
create it here is called question
now here we will say
foreign
which one of these I would say which one
of these is a JavaScript framework
this is my question now
okay so I would like to have answers for
sure
so here we are providing answers
so what answers we would like to provide
so in this answers the first answer I
can say
like this
here I say text
first would be python
python
okay python
answer is true or false
correct
false so it will be the false copy
now let's change the value here I say
Django
correct false
third is react
so
here I can say true
last I'm keeping it score
false as you should see
so like this we have created
a question
and four answers
okay so we're all set now
so here after that we want to create few
more
okay so once again I would like to bring
some questions now
and related answers
so I just copy this
first
so second question
I can say
who is the prime minister of India
foreign
answers available
okay
talk about converter Modi value is
called or true
second we will give the name call
the value is called false
so I've taken the values like this
and we can take one more
just for the demo purpose
so
like here
next is called what is 4 multiplied by
three
I can have many answers
so I'm just making the first is called
six
it's false second struggle
like that total we have created
three
okay so we all are set with this
multiple questions
okay
now once it is done we would like to
offer one function here
okay and what that function would be
the function would be known scroll clear
status class
function
here
status
class
it takes some parameter called element
and here we will say element Dot
class list
Dot
remove
Elementor classlist dot remove
correct
and once again I copy the same line
[Music]
so we have two options available
right and what wrong
now going forward we want to have few
more functions to be attached there is
only one function we've attached that's
called clear status class
now we would like to add one more
function here
call function set
status class
okay and here we pass two parameters now
one is called element
and second score correct
two parameters we are passing it now
element and correct first we are calling
this function called clear status class
is a function which we have created pass
element
followed by we are saying if
correct
then
element
Dot
class list Dot
add
correct
okay
else
else use the same option
what will try to add from here
so this is how we would like to apply
it or wrong
so this is a set status class which we
have it now
followed by the most important function
which you're going to use it right now
here
is called
your select answer so you have to
basically select the answer so this is a
little bigger function
so let's try to understand function
select
answer
here we pass e as in parameter
and from here we will reuse const
select selected pattern
selected button equal to e Dot
Target
number one second cost
correct
equal to
selected button
Dot
data set
select button dot dataset dot
correct
now going forward
we'll be calling this set status class
function
this set status class will be passing
document
dot body
as a first parameter
and correct
is the second parameter
okay now we are using
array Dot from
and here in this editor from we are
using answers
button element
installed
children
okay followed by Dot
for each here
we're using this button
as in parameter
now here what I will do here using this
option called
search status class
first parameter will be what
a button then
button Dot
data set Dot
we can keep the value called what
correct
okay so this is how we are using this
array now we'll be utilizing the main
evaluated value called if
a question Dot length
if suffer questions dot length is
greater than
current quotient index
Plus 1.
then what then we are saying
next button
Dot
class list Dot
remove
and here we will say height so this will
be hidden
okay else
condition says what start button
dot inner text
okay start button dot enter text equal
to
restart
okay
and next is called start button
Dot
classlist Dot
remove what we need to remove hide part
that's it
okay and here we're using this option
called if
selected button Dot
data set
equal to
correct
then
quiz score
plus plus
and
document Dot
get a limit by ID
here we are providing
right iPhone
answers
followed by
Dot
inner HTML equal to
quiz score
so whatever this code will be after
selecting the correct answer this will
be available to the user
okay now the next thing which we're
going to develop it is basically your
reset state
function reset state
so what we're going to offer here we are
saying
clear status class
document
Dot
body
okay here we are saying
next button
Dot
classlist Dot
add
height
okay now we are using this while option
now
answers put an element
DOT first child
so here I will be using answers button
element
child
here we have a call to move child and
here we'll be giving
Asus button elements
Dot
first child
so these are the functions are used
right now we haven't called those
functions but we'll be calling those
functions one by one
but this is something which you wanted
to start with
okay
well reset state is already set now
going forward we would like to start
working with the show questions so that
the user can start seeing the question
using function show cushion
show question
the first parameter will be question
and
from here onwards we would like to use
the cushionary mode
so we have a call question element Dot
in a text
equal to
question Dot
question
now followed by questions dot answer
question Dot answers
Dot
for each and here I would like to use
we are passing what
answers and parameter
now here we like to create a button
called const
foreign
equal to
document Dot
get sorry document dot create element
let's create a button now
okay after that we are saying
button
dot inner text
you have to set the value equal to
answer
dot text
Then followed by button Dot
classlist Dot
add here we are
offering
BTU
okay now we are saying if the condition
is
answer Dot
correct
if answer is correct then what
then button
Dot
dataset Dot
correct equal to
answer Dot
correct
okay now the next thing is we are using
button
dot add event listener attaching The
Listener to this event which event
on click event
second parameter will be
select answer
then
answer whatever element
Dot
up and Joint of what
button so this is your show questions
followed by what is the next question it
will appear so here we say function
set next question
foreign
function set next question
here in this next question we are just
saying
reset State the function we are calling
it and saying
show question
and here we are passing this
Shuffle questions
and we are passing this current question
in text that is what is set
next question is offering it to me
now the last function which is left that
is called start game how the game will
start
function
game
and here
the main magic begin here we say start
button
dot class list
dot add
and here
height
after that
suffer questions equal to
we have got questions Dot
sort
okay here we say
math Dot
random
okay
and five we're passing this value
okay after that we are saying
current question index initially we are
giving 0 right now
after that
question
container element which we have already
defined
Dot
classlist Dot
remove
height
okay and then calling
set next question
which is the function we are calling it
by initializing our quizzes score
with the value equals zero
well start game is
ready next thing which you have to start
the cover part
so here we are seeing
start button Dot
add event listener
here in this
on my click event
I will try to call this function
start game
first thing now next we'll be calling
next button Dot
add event listener on click
on click
we are using
okay so here we're calling current
question index
current course question index plus plus
and
set next question
that's it
so here are mostly done with our code
script.js We have basically already
initialized there
okay so the values will be kept
automatically so most of the things are
now ready with us
Okay so
our JavaScript is almost
ready
index.html file is there and app.css is
also ready with us now let's finally see
how my overall look and feel really
looks like it just go here and try to
refresh
and check on a button called start
awesome I could see the first
question appears automatically which of
these a JavaScript framework if I select
as using my correct answers for react
now you can see is automatically making
rest of them as a red and not giving me
the next button now
as a prime minister of India and
signature Modi create next and I say
4 multiplied by 3 is at 12 I said next
and which of those used in mobile app
development flutter and flask as a flask
it says Twitter and now you can see the
application looks perfectly fine and it
gives me the restart now
and that's it so this is how dear
friends your project is now completely
working and expected as a way it was
designed for when I once I can restart
and you can say start button now it's
giving me 4 multiply by three that means
it is one second I have taken random
question cascading style sheet which is
also called CSS is an important aspect
of web designing it has made our web
page responsive and user friendly
this video will help you understand all
the concepts of CSS and provide lots of
Hands-On examples
we'll start with understanding selectors
Box model grid layout flexbox
differences between grid layout and
flexbox and some more basic topics then
building on these Basics will make an
app bar learn how to create animation
and Transitions and finally we'll move
on to CSS Advanced functions so let's
begin
in this video you will learn what are
CSS selectors and what are their
different types what are CSS selectors
CSS selectives allow you to select and
style HTML elements selectors are used
to find elements based on their ID
classes types attributes value of
attributes and much more let's discuss
the most common selectors there are
several different types of CSS selectors
the most common of them are CSS element
selectors CSS ID selector CSS class
selector CSS Universal selector and CSS
group selectors so what is the CSS
element selector
the element selector selects element
based on the element name
this is a CSS selector it means it will
select all the P elements on the page it
will style all the P elements to the
central aligned having blue color
this is a CSS selector
it is set to P this means it will select
all the P elements on the page it will
style all the P elements to be centered
aligned having blue color
let's look at what it looks on a page
so as you can see all the elements are
centrally aligned with a text color blue
CSS ID selector
the ID selector uses the IDU attribute
of an HTML element to find a specific
element
an ID should be unique within the page
so you should use the ID selector to
find a single unique element
to find an element within a specific ID
use a hash character followed by the ID
of the element
so here we have used the hash paraben so
all the rules will be applied to the
HTML element with ID equal to para1 so
this is an ID selector
it will be applied to all the HTML
element with ID is equal to para1 as you
can see it is applied to the element
having the ID paragraph and all the
other elements are defaultly styled
CSS class selector the class selector
finds the element with a specific class
set by the HTML class attribute to
select an HTML with a specific class use
a period character followed by the name
of the class so this style will be
applied to all the elements having the
class name class 1. this is a class
selector it is denoted by a period
symbol all the elements having a class
named class 1 will be styled with
centrally aligned and color blue
as you can see the element having the
class name class 1 is tiled and all the
other elements are set to default CSS
Universal selector
the universal selector selects all the
elements on a page the universal
selected is assigned by a star character
the universal selector selects all the
elements on a style sheet as you can see
it is denoted by a star Mark all the
elements inside our web page will be
centrally aligned and the color will be
set to Blue
as you can see all the elements are
centrally aligned and the colors are set
to Blue CSS group selector in
stylesheets there are often elements
using the same style to minimize the
code you can group selectors to group
The selectors separate each selectors
with a comma here we have group
selectors for H1 H2 and P
so style is applied to H1 H2 and P
elements only
it is better to group The selectors to
minimize the code
here we have group selectors P H2 and H3
so style will be applied to only element
having PS2 and S3
as you can see so all the elements of P
H2 and H3 are centrally aligned and
colored to Red in this video we will
discuss what is the Box model and its
various properties
we will also do an example to understand
the Box model better
so let's get started
every element that can be displayed on a
web page is comprised of one or more
rectangular boxes CSS Box model
typically describes how this rectangular
boxes are laid out on a web page
these boxes can have different
properties and can interact with each
other in different ways but every box
has a Content area and options
surrounding padding model and margin
areas
the pollen diagram demonstrates how the
content padding model and margin CSS
properties determine how much space and
element can take on a web page
the content area consists of content
like text images or other media it is
bounded by the content Edge and its
dimensions are given by the content box
width and height
the Border area is the area between the
Box padding and margin its dimensions
are given by the width and height of the
Border
the margin area consists of spaces
between the border and the margin the
dimensions of the margin area are the
margin box width and margin box height
it is useful to separate the element
from its neighbors
the padding area is the area
that includes the elements padding this
area is actually the space around the
content area and within the Border box
its dimensions are given by the width of
the padding box and the height of the
padding box
now let's jump to an example to
understand the Box model better
so we are on the sublime text later
to get started I've created a box theme
simply run background color pink the
font size is 30 pixel and we have set
the border to zero solid green
let's see how it looks on our page
so as you can see we have a box named
simply learn with background going all
the way to the end
I have also removed all the padding and
margin from the page so that the boxes
are pushed just at the corner of the
page as you can see
let's start by adding a padding of 20
pixel to the Box
if you save the file you can see the Box
increase by 20 pixel from all the sides
inside the background of an element it
goes around the content of the element
most of the buttons inside the CSS be
designed using padding so that the
background of the button becomes wider
than the actual text
the next thing we can do is change the
border of the element if you change this
border size to 15 pixel we will get a
nice solid background of color green
the Border goes around the padding of
our element so we have the 20 pixel of
padding around our content and 15 pixel
of border around the padding which is
around the content
now we'll see the working of the margin
if you add 30 pixel of margin to an
element you can see the spacing on the
outside of our border
so let's add the 30 pixel margin and
refresh
you can see the spacing on outside of
the Border module is used to space two
elements apart from each other
now let's change these values to see the
difference
let's make the margin 40 pixels
we'll make the padding 30 pixels
and let's keep the Border 20 pixels and
make it color red
let's observe the changes
so as you can see our border now has a
red background the padding is 30 pixel
the margin is 40 pixels let's inspect
the elements to understand it better
inspect you can see the different Style
here in the computer tab you can see the
Box model
this is a Content area this is the
padding area this is the border and this
is the margin area
we have the margin of 40 pixels around
the border so you can when you click on
this area you can see the margin gets
highlighted
the Border area gets highlighted of 20
pixels this is the padding and this is
the content
you can change the size of the content
by adding the height and width
so let's try adding height and width
we'll give the height 50 pixels and will
give the width also 50 pixels
just save the file
now when you refresh you can see the
content Area 15 to 50. in this tutorial
we will discuss everything needed for
you to get started working with grid
layouts
we will start by discussing what is a
grid layout then we will move on to the
features of the grid system and some
basic terminologies which will help you
understand the grid system better
in end we will work on an example to
understand the grid system
so let's get started
what is a grid
a grid is a set of intersecting
horizontal and vertical lines defining
the rows and columns
and what is the grid layout
so CSL grid layout is the most popular
layout system available in CSS
it is a two-dimensional system meaning
it can handle both columns and rows
unlike flexbox which is largely a one
dimensional system
you work with grid layout by applying
the CSS rules to both the parent element
which became the grid container and the
elements children which become the grid
items
the CSS grid layout excels at dividing a
page into major regions or defining the
relationship in terms of size position
and layer between parts of a control
built HTML Primitives
you can see this is the basic layout of
a grid system
like tables grid layout enables an
author to align elements into columns
and rows however many more regular
layouts are either possible or easier
with CSS grid than they were with tables
for example a grid container's child
element could position themselves so
they actually overlap and layer similar
to the CSS position elements
so here are the features of the CSS grid
layout
they are fixed and have flexible track
sizes you can create a grid with fixed
track sizes using pixels
for example this sets the grid to the
specified pixel which fits to the layout
you desire
you can also create a grid using
flexible sizes with percentages with the
new FR unit designed for this purpose
you can place the items into a precise
location using the grid line numbers
names over targeting an area of the grid
the grid also contains an algorithm to
control the placement of items not given
an explicit position on the grid
you can define an explicit grid with a
grid layout the grid layer specification
is flexible enough to add additional
rows and columns when needed features
such as adding as many columns that will
fit into a container are included
it also gives you control of overlapping
content
more than one item can be placed into a
grid cell or area and they can partially
overlap each other this layering May
then be controlled with the Z index
property
so here the basic terminologies you
should know to work with the grid system
better
the grid line is a dividing line that
make up the structure of the grid they
can either be vertical or horizontal and
resides on either side of rows and
columns
a grid column is a space between two
adjacent vertical grid lines
the size of a grid column is determined
with a grid template columns property
on the other hand a grilled row is a
space between
two adjacent horizontal grid lines
its size is determined by the grid
template Rose property
the grid cell is the single unit of a
CSS grid
and in Grid design a gutter is basically
the width of the space between columns a
gutter margin is a white space formed by
the adjoining inside margins of two
facing pages in a book or space between
columns on a page
so with this let's now move on to the
Hands-On demo and see how the grid
system works in actual world so we are
on the Sublime Text Editor open with a
project with some basic background
Styles and nothing inside the body
you can see this is the basic background
style we have pre-applied just to have a
good look of the Box model
we'll start by creating a container and
wrapping our grid items in it so let's
create a grid and give it a class name
grid container
and inside of it we'll put out different
grid items so we'll just create
different grid items and give them a
class grid item followed by a class
number they belong to
so that we can easily distinguish
between them
just copy paste this
five times
so we'll have the five elements on our
page
let's save the file and see how it looks
on the page
yeah
so you can see we have the different
grid items on the screen so there are
easy for us to visualize we have not
applied any styles to them other than
the visual styles
so we'll go back to our code
let's go back to the CSS styling sheet
so to create the grid we'll open our
style sheet we need to display grid on
our grid container so we'll select the
grid container and set the display to
grid
foreign
any rows and columns for us to work with
it just they give the alignment properly
therefore by default it looks just
exactly the same to make the grid look
actually great we want to need to do is
Define columns and rows for a grid
so to do this you will use a set grid
template and set the column if you want
to set the size of the column we'll set
the size to 100 pixel line 150 pixel
foreign
if you refresh you have the 100 pixel
column on the left and a 150 pixel
column on the right and then the grid
captures our next row
but what if you want a box to flexible
size themselves according to the items
inside of them here we'll use a fraction
in it so instead of a 150 pixel column
we want one fraction of our size and
instead of 100 pixels we want the two
factors of our size
so we will just replace with two
fractions
and this with one fraction
now if you save the file and go back to
the page
you will see the items on our left here
in our first column are twice as the
largest item on the second column
and that because of the FR units we have
defined
you can see the difference in the sizes
item one is the twice the size of the
item two
another thing you can do is with columns
is use repeat
suppose you want four Columns of a size
100 pixel wide you can just write repeat
command and inside of it how many times
you want to repeat the size
so we'll just delete this
and use the repeat
we'll set the number of times we want to
repeat and the size of the columns
now if you save the file we will see we
have a four Columns of 100 pixel wide
we can do the same things for rope just
set the grid template rows and Define
the size you want
now you can see we have the symmetric
size all around our container
if you don't know how large your grid is
going to be you can use the grid Auto
rows and this will determine the size of
all the rows that is added after the
template rows suppose we want all our
rows to be 100 pixels
so we'll just delete the grid template
rows
and set the grid Auto rows to 100 pixel
now you can see all the rows are now 100
pixel tall
let's change our column back to 100
pixel and 150 pixels
so that it will be easier for us further
we'll just delete this grid Auto rows
now we'll talk about the spacing of the
rows and columns apart from each other
we can do this with the help of the grid
grab property grilled row Gap will give
some spaces between the rows similarly
the grid column will give you the spaces
between the columns
foreign
columns
now we want the same value for both The
Columns you can use a grid grab property
and mention the space
will just delete these two
and instead of it we will use just the
grid Gap
and set the size to 20 pixel
now you can see the evenly spaces
between the rows and the columns
this is all you need to know about the
sizing of the different columns and rows
now let's talk about the positioning
items within its grid cells so for
horizontal positioning we could use the
justify items and we can set that to
Center
so that's into the each item within the
cell
by default it is set to stretch
you can also set it to start
or end
or space around
we will leave this to Center
to vertically position the content we
could use the Align items
the Ally items also accept the same
values
we can set it to Center
we can also set this one to start or end
foreign
just will give this to Center as well
you can also align the entire grid
within the container
so let's get rid of these to just
demonstrate them in a proper manner
you could use a justify content and that
will align the content horizontally
within the container
you can also set this to start or to end
just set this back to Center
to align the content vertically we could
use the Align content and the Align
content also accepts the same value we
can set it to Center
or start
if you inspect the elements
foreign
centrally between the container we'll
just close this
okay so this is everything you need to
know to get started with the grid layout
grid works very similar to the flexbox
but it allows you too much in terms of
laying your elements because of its 2D
nature in this video we will learn what
is a flex box and how it is useful in
designing the layout of the website
we will also try to understand the
different properties of flexbox with the
help of an example
so let's get started
what is a flexbox
also called flexible Box model is
basically a layout mode or model that
provides an easy and clean way to
arrange the items within a container
if you are using a CSS for a while you
must have used the old block model where
you assign width in terms of percentage
or fixed width and then use the float to
arrange the items on the page
suppose for example you want to arrange
three boxes in a row
then you have to enter everything
manually from width height and to
padding flexbox can do all these things
with ease
some of the concepts of flexible Box
model is the ability to alter item width
and height to best fit in the containers
available in the free space
Flex model is the direction agnostic
which is different from the Box model
which is vertically biased and the
inline which is horizontally biased
flexbox works for both
flexbox is more effective in a small
scale layouts
so here are the main properties of the
flex
okay so let's jump to some code and
learn how this product properties work
okay so we are in the subline text
editor
to get started let's add a div inside
our body here and we'll give a class of
flexbox container since this will be the
container where all our flexbox item
will decide
foreign
we will add another div and give it a
class flexbox item and one more class
flexbox item one which will help us to
understand which items we are referring
to when we style our elements
individually
let's just save the file and see how it
looks on a page
now if you save the file you can see we
have the box because I have already
applied some of the styles to these
flexbox items let's just see the styling
so you can see we have the items tiled
just a basic styling so that we get the
Box on our web page
now let's just copy these and add two
more flexbox items and you will see we
have two more boxes on our page
just copy and paste them below
give them the class name flexbox item 2
and flexbox item three just save the
file
now you can see we have three boxes on
the page
Now to create a flex container
we will add display Flex to our Flex
container and this is how we create a
flex
box container
so here we will just add
display Flex
just save the file
now you can see all the items are at the
same height and they are all in the same
row you will also notice that if you
shrink our browser the items adjust
themselves accordingly to fit within the
browser
now if you want to style the elements on
the mean axis we will use the property
justify content inside of flexbox
container let's make it a center
save the file
now you can see the all the elements are
in the center of the page
another thing we can do is if we want
our layout to have a spaces between the
elements we will set the justify content
to space between
you can see all the items are now evenly
spaced if you want to lay out your items
on the cross axis we would use the Align
items property the default value for
this is stretch
if we want to keep the size of our items
we will use the center and then all our
items will be centered vertically
before flexbox aligning the items
vertically inside the container was
nearly impossible with flexbox you can
do it easily
now you can see the items are aligned
vertically inside the container now
let's just delete everything and we'll
just keep the display Flex
foreign
layout instead we will use the flex
direction and change it to column select
Direction column now if you refresh the
page you will see all the items are
shown up in a column
now we can start talking about the
different properties that can be applied
to our different flexbox items as
opposed to a flexbox container items the
text box contains only for laying out
and spacing between your items as well
as the positioning of your item inside
the container the actual flexbox item
properties are used to overwrite those
item Properties or to apply different
sizing to these elements now if you want
the first item that it does not shrink
when you shrink our browser we'll set
the flex shrink to zero to our first
item
so we'll set the flex
shrink to zero
now if you go back to the page
and try to shrink this
you see the first item Remains the Same
it does not shrink
now in the same way you can set the
items to grow into position with the web
browser suppose we want our Flex box
item to to grow with the as the page
grow and cover all the empty spaces so
we'll set this Flex grow to 1.
now you will see the all these empty
spaces are taken by the second item
let's say we want a second box to be the
center of the container instead of
stretching to full height we can use the
Align self property and set it to Center
now you will see that the alliances
property overrides the Align content
property of the container
you can see it is centrally aligned
so this is all you need to understand
and get started to work with the flex
boxes
I hope you guys enjoyed this video and
learned something new about the flexbox
and how you can use the text box to
create the dynamic layout for your site
in this video we are going to discuss
one of the most important topics of the
web development which is CSS display so
without wasting any time let's get
started
so what is a display property
the CSS display property controls the
layout of the element on the page
the default value of the display
property is block or inline
let's jump back to our Sublime Text
later to see the various display
Properties by using an example to get
started I have a really simple example
setup as you can see inside my HTML add
the two paragraph tags and I have a
formatting with the background color of
sand color and font size 30 pixels
as you can see this looks like something
like this on the page
the very first property we are going to
discuss is the display block property
the drug display values make an element
a block element
the block elements start a new line and
span the entire width of the viewport by
default like how P elements behave
there are also line breaks before and
after these elements
the default value of the
P element is a display block
so here
this looks something like this
what display box does is it means that
it is going to take the entire width
given to it
this is going to force a new line above
and new line below it so you cannot have
something next to here now if you change
here this to
[Music]
the next property we are going to
discuss is in line the inline display
value turns any element into an inline
element
these elements will appear on the same
line without breaks
now if it says here this to display in
line now all the P tags will behave as
an inline element
now if you go back to our page and
refresh
you can see now this is an inline
element
the inline element takes a minimum
amount of space possible as you can see
here the CN color takes the minimum onto
space to fit all the content inside of
this p
so this is what an inline element does
also all the inline elements are on the
same line
they share the space together because
they take the minimum amount of space
possible
there are no line breaks in these
elements and they try to fit as closely
as possible
now one of the demanded fear is we
cannot change the height and width of
the inline element
if you change here height
200 pixels
and with 200 pixels and Save
just go back and refresh you'll see
nothing happens this is because in the
inline display property you cannot
change the height and width of the
element
the next property we are going to
discuss is the inline block value the
inline block value is a hybrid of inline
and block element elements assigned
display inline block appears on the same
line with the other inline elements the
characteristics of inline elements
however inline block elements are also
like block elements in that you can
change the width and height of the CSS
now if here if you try to change the
height and width
of the element
just just change this to inline block
now if you go back to the page and
refresh
you will see the height and weight
property works this is one of the major
difference between the inline block and
the inline inline display property
the last name type of display we are
going to discuss is the display none and
this is a really straightforward display
property
you just delete this
and change the display to display none
now if you save the file and go back to
refresh you see both the element
disappears
the display then removes the targeted
elements and all its child elements from
the page this causes accompanying
elements to behave as if this element
does not exist in this video we'll
discuss everything we need to know about
CSS positioning
by the time this video is over you'll be
able to position the elements in CSS
like a pro
so let's get started
first let's cover the theoretical part
here we will discuss what is the SS
position property and its different
types after that we'll jump to practical
example to learn how to work with these
properties so let's get started
so what is CSS position property
the CSS position property allows you to
define the position of an element on a
web page the top right bottom and the
left CSS position properties are used to
determine the final location of the
element
there are four values that you can use
to set the position of an element on a
web page they are static fixed selective
and absolute
using one of the four values above you
can specify how an element should be
positioned you can also use the top
bottom left and right property so
further Define the element position on a
page so let's discuss each of the
properties individually
CSS static position
this is a by default position for HTML
elements
it always positions an element according
to the normal flow of the page
it is not affected by the top bottom
left and right properties
it is important to note that having a
static equation is the same as not
setting the position property at all
the next is CSS fixed position
the fixed positioning property helps to
put the text fixed on the browser
the fixed test is positioned relative to
the browser's window and does not move
even when you scroll the window
the next is CSS related position
the relative position property is used
to set the element relative to its
normal position
the relatively positioned element
behaves the same way as a static element
except that it is now subject to the
values of the four other CSS properties
we'll discuss each of them with more
detail in examples
now there is CSS absolute position
the absolute position is used to
position an element related to the first
parent element
that has a position other than static
if no such element is found the
containing block is HTML
with absolute positioning you can place
an element anywhere on the page
now let's move on to the example to
understand each of the properties better
to demonstrate the properties I have the
simple example setup currently we have
three elements with just basic curving
Style we have not applied any position
style to them
now let's click on this element 2 and
inspect it
just go to the computed and type here
position to see the position of this
element
so you can see the currently the
position is static
static is the default value of all the
elements of the page in starting
the next position we'll see is a
relative position
it works almost in a similar manner to
static if you go here and change your
position to relative
you can see nothing changes relative Act
is the same as static with the only
difference is that the relative allows
you to change the top left right and
bottom of this element Let Me Show an
example
now if we change here to
left
20 pixel
and refresh
you will notice the elements move itself
to a 20 pixel from the left
let's set the top to 10 pixel as well
you can see the element has moved 10
pixel from the top and even overflows
the element below
this is because relative position when
applied with the top right left and
bottom actually takes that element out
of the document flow
so let's just reset it
next property we are going to discuss is
absolute position and this property gets
well along with the top right left and
bottom
so let's make this position to Absolute
and you can see the changes made due to
this by just
saving
the absolute value completely removes
the element from the document flow this
is useful when you want a particular
element to be a specific position but
you don't want to disturb the other
elements positioning
absolute position positions the element
inside of some parent container that it
can reference now just
let's shift the top to 10 pixels
you can see the movement of this element
[Music]
the absolute position always position
the element inside some parent container
that it can reference to
now if you change the hair body position
to relative now the this nav bar will
position the element according to this
body so if you go here and refresh this
you can see that this 2 is in its
relation to with this container
and this is where relative is very
useful
next is fixed positioning which is very
similar to Absolute positioning with
some differences
so let's change this to fixed
and just save this
now you can see it completely ignores
this relative positioning and goes
entirely at the top
this is because fixed position elements
are always fixed based on the entire
HTML element
it has nothing to do with the parent
elements one unique feature of its
element is they stay in the same place
when you scroll
let's make the height here
to 200 vertical height
now if you scroll down you will see that
the element 2 will stay on the same
position
see the two elements stick to the same
foreign
does not work that way when you change
this here to Absolute
you can see it is not straight at the
top now this is one major difference
between absolute and fixed
so that's it you can see the working
with the CSS version super EV in this
video we'll discuss the differences
between both the layouts and we'll
discuss which one you should use
I will also show you both the layout in
a practical example without diving too
deep
so let's first understand the theory
CSS grid allows developers to construct
custom grids with more flexibility and
control than ever before
it is for two dimensional positioning we
got rows and columns here
whereas text boxes for one dimensional
layout it is useful in allocating and
aligning the spaces among the items in a
grid container the flexbox layout
pattern makes it easier to design and
flexible and effective layouts
the grid is used for creating a more
complex and organized layouts on your
pages
whereas the flex items is used to design
the responsive Pages without using too
much of positioning or float in our CSS
code to work with the CSS grid layout
you have to add display grid property to
your element
whereas to create the flex container you
have to use the display Flex property
so this is the main difference between
the layout of the
grid and the flexbox
here in the grid layout you can see that
there are rows and columns with all the
header menu main right and the footer
included whereas the flexbox is only for
one dimensional positioning
now let's move on to the example to see
the working of the both the layouts so
here is an example of the web page that
does not have any function other than
some basic styling
here on the page we have a header which
is blue in color this is the sidebar
with a red background this is the main
content and this black color is a footer
of the page here you can see this all
these items are stacked on top of each
other
in the code you can see um this is the
footer part of the page uh this is the
main content of the page this is for the
sidebar and this is for the header area
of the page
for The Styling part we have used some
basic styling just so as to understand
the example better
now we can turn the body into a grid by
setting the display property to the grid
so here under the body we'll set the
display to grid
just save the file and refresh
thank you
can see nothing changes because by
default the CSS grid starts creating
rows automatically and adds the content
in these rows that's why it didn't
change
we can change it by adding the grid
template column property in our body in
our case we'll need two columns one for
sidebar and other for the main content
let's set the side area to 30 percent
and we'll keep the main area to Auto to
cover the remaining spaces
foreign
you can see the elements are broken into
the skills we created
we'll also Define the rows for our
header and we'll use the grid template
rows
we'll set the grid template rows for the
header to 60 pixels
for the sidebar and for the main content
we'll set it to auto
and also for the footer we will keep it
60 pixels
now if you save the file and reload you
can see the elements are adjusted in a
2d manner just as you wanted
this shows the power of the grid and the
flexibility it provides to the developer
however we can see that the items are
not positioned properly in the header
and the footer
this is where the flex block comes into
play as discussed earlier flexbox is
about positioning elements in a
one-dimensional area
so what we'll do is we'll go back to our
navigation list class here
and we'll add display as Flex
now if you save the file and reload
you can see these are sitting next to
each other
by default the display sets them into
the rows
now we want the contents to be in the
center of the main axis
so we will use a justify content and set
it to Center
you can see the items are now in the
center of the main axis
to Center them vertically we'll use the
Align items and set it to Center as well
this will position them in the center
across the axis
for this to work we have to specify the
height um so we'll set it to 100 percent
so now you can see the items are aligned
centrally both on the main axis and the
cross axis
let's now add some spacing between these
items
so to give some spacing between we'll
add a margin to navigation item class
we'll set the margin to 0 for top and
bottom and 10 pixel to left and right
if we save the file and a refresh you
can see we have the spaces between the
items
in this video you will learn how to set
a background image on a web page you
will also learn some of the basic
properties of the background that are
used to set the image
so let's start by discussing the agenda
for this tutorial in this tutorial we'll
discuss what is CSS background image
after that we'll discuss some of the
basic properties of the background image
in the end We'll add a background image
to our web page by adding the code to
our text editor
so let's begin by discussing about the
background property of the CSS
the background image property specifies
an image to use as a background of an
element
the background is defined in the body
element of the HTML code
to add a background image on an HTML
element use the HTML style attribute and
the CSS background image property and
mention the path of the image inside the
URL attribute
there are several properties of the
background that are used to define the
image on a page some of the common ones
are background image background repeat
and background position
by default the image is repeated so it
covers the entire element
let's switch to the text editor and see
how we can add the background image to
our page so we are on the Sublime Text
Editor let's start by opening a style
tag
the background image is always set on
the body tag so type body and open the
curly braces
the background image is always set on
the body tag so open the body tag with
curly braces and start typing background
image
use the URL value of the background
image to set the path of the image
make sure the image is in the same
folder as of the HTML file here we have
our file nature3.jpj
so mention the path inside the double
quotes
save the file and let's see how it looks
on a web page
as you can see we have the image on the
web page let's format this image a
little bit we'll start by setting the
background size so type background size
and there are three values to the
background size first one is Auto
it will set the image as it is
save the file and let's see how it looks
on a page
as you can see the size of the image is
as same of the original size
the color value will set the image size
that will be fit to the web page
as you can see the image is set to the
whole web page
you can also set the image size to
manual let's say you want the image size
of bit 500 pixels so
now as you can see the width of the
image is 500 pixels next we will set the
background repeat property
there are three values to background
repeat first is no repeat with no repeat
value the images will not be repeated on
a page
now as you can see the images are not
repeated
second is repeat X it will set the
images to be repeated on the x axis
as you can see the images are now
repeated on the x axis similarly repeat
the images on the y-axis
as you can see the images are not
repeated to the y-axis and there is a
default value repeat which will repeat
the images on the web page
so let's keep it to cover
so let's keep the background size to
cover and set the background repeat to
no repeat
let's save the file and look it on our
web page
now as you can see the image is fully
fit to the web page
let's add a text above our image to see
how it looks like
so I'll add a paragraph tag
and type some random text here
foreign
let's set the text color to red and
align it to Center
I'll type P and open the curly braces
I'll set the color to red
and I'll set the text align to Center
let's save the file and see how it looks
on a page
as you can see we have a text above our
image which is centrally aligned and the
text color is red in this tutorial we
will learn how we can add colors to our
page using different methods we will
start with discussing colors and then
see the hex value and RGB format of the
colors in the end we'll do an example to
understand how we can add colors to our
page
CSS uses the color values to specify the
colors on a page they can be specified
using predefined color names hex or RGB
format there are nearly 140 standard
color names hexadecimal is a six digit
representation of a color the first two
digits RR represents the red value the
next two are green value and the last is
the blue value
all the other colors can be created
using the combination of these three
colors there are several websites
available where you can know the hex
value of the different shades of color
as you can see the black color is
signified by hashtag and the six zeros
the red is hashtag FF and the four zeros
followed by it the RGB color value is
specified using the RGB property this
property takes three values one for red
green and blue the value can be the
integer between 0 to 225 or a percentage
as you can see the black color is
signified by zero zero zero the red by
25500 the blue
y00255 and the green by zero two fifty
five zero now let's move to your example
to understand how we can add the colors
to our page
in this example we will see how we can
add colors in different ways to our HTML
so we are on the Sublime Text Editor as
you can see we have the standard
boilerplate ready with an H2 and a
paragraph on our page open the style tag
and make the font size of the paragraph
to 25 pixels so it is clearly visible
let's start by adding colors to our text
just by color names HTML supports nearly
140 standard color names
we'll make the color of the paragraph
green for that just type color and set
the color to Green
as you can see our paragraph is changed
to Green
let's try one more
this time we will add the color red
just refresh
as you can see the color is not changed
to red
there are nearly 140 HTML standard
colors that is supported by the web
browser
you can also add colors using the RGB
format there are many websites available
to know the RGB or hex value of the
desired color once such as HTML
codes.com
as you can see in the htmlcost.com we
have the hex value and the RGB value of
the desired color
let's try one
we'll add this color with the RGB value
171 229 and 27 to our paragraph So for
that just type RGB and the color code
you want
foreign
as you can see the color is not changed
to our RGB value let's try one more
this time we'll use this RGB value to
our text
you can see the colors changed to our
desired value
in this way you can use the RGB format
to change the colors
the next way is using the hex values
hexadecim is the six representation of a
color the first two digits are red next
one to a green and a last are the blue
value let's see how you can use the hex
values
as you can see the hex value for this
color is hash 31787l
we'll use this value to our text
to add the hex value we have to use the
hashtag followed by the color code
foreign
let's try one more
you can see the hex value for this color
in hash F14 a07
just copy the desired value to your file
you can see the color changes
you can also add color borders to our
heading do that just mention the Border
style along with the color code
we'll add the Border color red to our H2
now you can see we have the border
around our S2
I hope you have understand how to use
the color values to your web page there
are mainly three ways by which you can
add the colors to your web page they are
hacks RGB values and the color names in
this video we will discuss what are
keyframes and how you can use them to
add animations to your page
we are going to discuss what are
keyframes and will try to understand the
syntax of the keyframes so let's get
started
the keyframes are used to specify the
animation code in the page they are used
to change the animation from one pattern
to another
keep in mind that the keyframes do not
have any selectors on them
they are not tested inside anything they
are on the root of the CSS page you
write at the rate keyframes and the name
you can name it anything you want we are
going to use that name later on to call
the selector in this case we are looking
at from and 2 from implies the initial
State and to the ending State here in
this example the element will start from
0 pixel and will go all the way to 100
pixel so what we are going to do right
now is we are going to jump to the
keyframes and work out some examples to
understand the working of the keyframes
better so we are on the sublime tech
center and this is a simple setup we
have created one HTML element name box
and we have a CSS body of trading 50
pixel and the Box element is an inline
block
background red with heightened with 200
pixels
and also I have an animation style
declared on the box currently it's doing
nothing because it is calling keyframes
called my frames but we have not yet
created any keyframe we will discuss
what this animation line means at later
stage but right now I need those lines
to be able to export you to the
functioning of the keyframes
you can see we have a box on our page
with the color red and padding 50 pixels
around it we are going to write add the
keyframes and I am going to use the name
my frames then we'll write prompt
condition to have the starting State and
let's just keep the height 200 pixel and
then we want it to grow and we will set
it to increase till 500 pixels so let's
just create our keyframes
this is a from condition
we'll set it to 200 pixels
and we want it to grow till 500 pixels
just save the file
now as you can see our box is going all
the way to 500 pixel and when the
animation is done it resets back to 200
pixel and starts again because the
animation is looping you can also put
multiple style declaration for example I
am going to write background pink in the
two conditions
just save the file
you can see that the animation is
starting at red and ending at pink now
instead of saying from N2 we can also
say from zero percent to hundred percent
this is as same as doing from N2 but
what it enables you to do is you can add
something in the middle of here say 30
and we will make the color any different
so in the place of prompt we'll write
zero percent
and will replace two with hundred
percent
let's just add one more condition in
between say 40 percent
so at forty percent we want the color to
change to say something uh
greed
let's save the file and see how it looks
on the page
so as you can see it starts with red it
turns to Green in the middle and then
all the way converts to Pink as you can
see there are lots of interesting things
you can do with the keyframes
all of the things that I am showing you
today are just like how this works to
really get a great understanding of how
it works you just have to open an editor
and start experimenting on it
okay so now let's go back to our code
and learn about the animation property
so here we have the animation name my
frames
the animation name should be as same as
keyframe's name to work it properly
the animation duration specifies for how
long we want our animation to last in
this case 2 seconds
let's just change this to say
10 seconds
just save the file
now as you can see the animation is
going at a slower speed just to cover
the 10 seconds update
let's just reset it to 2 seconds
the timing function used to mention the
transition there are some keywords such
as easy and linear easy node and some
more the animation delay is interesting
to understand it means how long we are
going to wait once the animation is
triggered before the visual starts
happening
let's change it to three seconds
as you can see the animation starts
after the three seconds
iteration count specifies how many times
the animation should happen here we have
set it to infinite
which means animation will keep on going
let's change it to something say 5.
as you can see after the count of five
the animation stops
we'll set it back to infinite
animation running State can be paused or
the running state in this video we are
going to break down everything there is
to know about the CSS animation
CSS animations make it possible to
animate transitions from one CSS style
configuration to another
animation consist of two components a
style describing the CSS animation and a
set of keyframe that indicates the start
and end states of the animation style as
well as possible intermediate
now to understand this better I have an
example so let's get started now
so we are on a Sublime Text Editor now
to get started I have a very basic
example with HTML and CSS
I have a parent element here
and inside this parent element I have a
div class child
so when you go back to the page it will
look something like this this pink color
is the parent element and the small box
with the red color is a child element
whenever you hover over the element the
child elements move from left side to
the right side of the parent
we want to talk about animation
in case there are two different ways to
animate one is the CSS transaction
property which works well with only
simple animation
if you want to learn about CSS
transition property you can refer to the
last video on CSS transition
there is a full-fledged animation
property which is used for more complex
animation
I am going to show you how you can make
this simple transition into animation
for this example we'll make this child
element move all around the Box using
animation
so let's go back to our code
so just like the transition property we
have the several properties in the CSS
animation as well this consists of like
timing function fill in mode and several
other functions in the CSS animation
so to convert the transition into
animation all we need to do is write the
word animation and you write the
animation where you want it to happen in
our case here is our hover so we write
the animation here and as you write you
will notice that you have more
properties in animation than transition
in general you will write everything in
this animation keyword because it is
easier we can write it separately as
well like animation delay duration
animation name but
we will use the shorthand property of
the animation
so we'll select the animation and the
first thing that the animation leaves is
the animation name so we will give some
name to this animation
say
example
this is just like transition we can
specify our duration in our case we will
use one second
so we have given the name of the
animation will give the duration we can
define a timing function which will be
ease out
this is all the code we need for our
animation
this line is same as writing this
individually like animation name
[Music]
animation duration one second
and animation timing function
which will be ease out
or let's say is in
so for the better understanding let's
just remove the shorthand property and
use it individual properties
now just save the file
let's understand briefly what each of
these properties do the animation
duration property defines how long time
and animation should take to complete if
the animation duration property is not
specified no animation will occur
because the default value is 0 second
the animation timing function property
specifies the speed curve of the
animation
now comes the keyframes keep frames are
used to define the animation name we
come down here and write at the rate
keyframes
followed by the name of the animation
the keyframes has to be put outside any
selector
keyframes essentially determine what the
animation looks like between the value 0
and 100 percent
so at our animation we want to have this
Translate
so we'll write 100 percent
and we'll write
transform
translate X
100 and save the file
now when you save and go back to the
page
you will notice the smooth transition of
the animation
when you hover over
one thing you will notice that as soon
as the animation is over the Box goes
back to the original place
the reason for this is all the process
happens inside this keyframe this one
as soon as the animation is done the
default set kicks in
if you want this to stop in the
transform State like box should be here
is on the right side
we have to specify it in the animation
property we'll set the animation fill
mode to forwards so here
we'll set the animation fill mode to
forwards
just save and then when you go back to
the
page and refresh
you'll see the Box stops on the right
side and doesn't go back to the original
state
now that you have a basic understanding
of the animation and its different
properties let's work around our main
aim to move this child element all over
the parent element from this this side
to this side to this side so here at the
keyframes we'll just delete this and
we'll start with zero percent
foreign
will set the transform and translate X
to 0.
after that added 33 percent
we want
this box to move down so we'll work on
Translate Y
so
we'll translate the Y 200 percent
at 66 percent we want both the x axis
and y axis to to move from here to this
side
so we'll set
translate x 200 percent
and Translate
y 200 percent
and finally at hundred percent
we want to translate X
back to 100 percent
on the upward side so when you save and
refresh
you see we have achieved our Target
the child elements move all over inside
the parent element
to watch it little bit more slowly let's
change the time here to three seconds
when you go back and refresh
you can see the Box move little bit
slower
so with the animation property we can go
a step further we can tell our animation
how many times to repeat the order of
the animation
among other things
so the animation iteration count
property specifies the number of times
an animation should be played let's set
it to 3.
so here
you set the animation iteration ground
to 3.
the animation Direction property is
defined whether animation should be
played forwards backwards or in
alternate Cycles
so for the animation Direction we'll set
it to alternate
now if you save and go back
that's one
two
and three after the three count the
animation will stop and you must have
noticed that the Box were moving on the
alternate rounds
let's go back to see it again
this is the first cycle now it moves alt
on the other direction and now on the
other direction
so this is for animation you can see
animation property is as same as a
transition property with some more
functions answer properties you can add
more complex animations to the page with
the help of this animation property the
CSS transition property is the simplest
way to add the animation to our website
and in this video we are going to see
how to use it
so animation is a good way to catch
attention on the page and if done
properly it increases the user
experience
the most basic way to animate something
is by transition
according to the mdn definition
transition enables you to define the
transition between two states of an
element basically when the state of an
element changes such as hover Focus or
anything else you can change the CSS
property through a transition
there are handful of transition property
let's discuss what they are and how they
work
so we are in our Port pen I have a box
that changes the color on the hobo
the first topic that we are going to
start is with the transition duration
property
the transition division property
specifies how many seconds or
milliseconds a transition effects takes
to complete
so here I can write transition duration
and I can write here a number take note
that here we can enter time in
milliseconds or seconds I will suggest
you to use the millisecond since
JavaScript does not accept time in
second
so I will enter here 500 milliseconds
now
when you go here and hover over this box
you see the color changes from pink to
Green in about 500 milliseconds
let's change this to say two seconds
and see the difference
now if you hover this box
you see it takes two seconds to change
the color from pink to Green
[Music]
the next one we are going to look is a
transition property the transition
property sets the CSS properties to
which the transition effect should be
applied
suppose we want to rotate this box when
hovered over
so first we specify the transform
property here and will set it to rotate
45 degrees
now here we'll specify the transition
property and set it to transform
now if you hover over this box you see
it takes about 500 milliseconds for the
box to rotate to 45 degrees while the
color changes instantly
suppose we set it here to 2 seconds
and Save
now you will notice the Box will take to
about two seconds rooted to 45 degrees
while the color will change instantly
you can see the difference here
now the next property is transition
timing function the transition timing
function property specifies the speed
curve of the transition effect
the default value is ease ease means it
specifies a transition effect with a
slow start and then fast and then ends
slowly
suppose here
will set the transition
timing function
who is
there are four major values for this
timing function they are is linear ease
in and ease out
let's see one by one in detail
so the linear function specify the
transition effect with the same speed
from start to end
so if we change here to linear
you see it rotates with the same speed
from start to end
now if we change this to ease in
the easiest specify the transition
effect with a slow start so now if you
hover over this
you see the Box rotate this slow start
and then increases the speed at the end
that either specifies a transition
effect with a slow end
so if you set it to ease out
you will see at the end the speed
decreases
the last property we are going to
discuss is a transition delay the
transition delay property specifies when
the transition effect will start
the transition delay value is defined in
milliseconds or in seconds
let's set the transition
delay to two seconds
and just remove this
now if you hover over this box you'll
see it will take two seconds to rotate
the box to 45 degrees
so you can see after the two seconds the
transition property takes place
now if we change here
to background
you see the Box will rotate instantly
while the color will changes from pink
to green after 2 seconds
so this is a translation property is it
as simple as it can be in this video you
will learn how to add interactive horror
effects to your elements we will do an
example where we will create horror
effects to our buttons
so in this tutorial we will discuss what
is the CSS hover effects and then we'll
do an example to understand it better
so what is the CSS over effect
a CSS hover effect is a style technique
where the user interacts with an element
with a pointing device but it does not
necessarily activates it
it is triggered when the user hovers
over an element with a pointing device
now let's jump to an example
in this example we will create the hover
effects which will look something like
this we have different hover effects for
all the buttons thank you
so let's get started and see how you can
make this all by yourself
so we are on the Sublime Text writer
create two new files index.html and
style.css where we will write our HTML
and CSS code respectively
start by linking the CSS file with the
HTML file
now we will add four anchor tags we will
specify the class name for each of them
so that we can style them separately
later
put all the anchor tag inside the div
tag and name the class
middle
we will name the class BTN btn1 BTN btn2
BTN btnc and BTN btn4
just copy paste it four times
foreign
as you can see we have the four text on
our page
with this we are done with our HTML path
now let's shift to CSS and design the
text and add the hover effects so in CSS
you will start by setting the margin and
padding to zero we will also add the
background body color
foreign
as you can see the margin and padding is
now zero and we have a good background
color
now we will Design the buttons and give
them proper formatting we'll start with
the class middle
set the position to Absolute
the top property affects the vertical
position of a position element the left
property affects the horizontal position
of a coefficient element the transform
property applies a 2d or 3D
transformation to an element this
property allows you to rotate scale and
move the elements
as you can see the elements are now in
place now let's format the buttons
set the position to relative
display block
will keep the color as white
font size 25 pixels
we will use the font family as
montessorette
keep the text decoration to none
we will set the border to two pixel and
solid
we keep the text transformation
permission repeat we'll keep the text
transformation as uppercase
transition allows you to change the
property values smoothly over the given
duration
the before selector is used to insert
something before the content of each
selected elements
keep the position to Absolute
foreign
we'll keep the transition as all 0.6
second and ease
let's save the file and see how it looks
on a page
now as you can see all the elements are
in place with proper background and text
we have the padding and Border properly
formatted and now we can add the whole
effect to this button
now we'll add the hover effects to the
first button
as you can see we have the hover effect
on our first button ready
in a similar manner we can add the
effects to the second and third Button
as well
we'll just copy and paste this above
code below and make changes to this code
will set the width to 100 here
and hike to zero
we'll change it to height hundred
percent
just save the file and refresh the page
as you can see both the buttons have the
horror effects now
it's time to add the hover effect to our
third button
foreign
effect to the button third
just save the file and go to the page
as you can see all the three buttons are
ready
now it's time to add the hover effect to
the post button
we'll set the color to Hash FFF
foreign
this will change the text color to red
when we hover over the fourth button
set the position to Absolute
yes thank you
keep the width as 200 percent
we'll set the background to hash dcd159
we'll keep the Z index as -1
keep the transition to 0.8 seconds
foreign
set the height to 180 percent of the
page
now to add the hover effect
write the following code
just save the file
refresh
now you can see we have all the hover
effects on our Pro button
as you know the asset animations is a
powerful concept that is used to make
your web page engaging and attracting
with those to your website
they make the user experience smooth and
entertaining
so in this video we are going to learn
how to create some cool CSS effects
using just HTML and CSS so without
further wasting any time let's jump to
our Sublime Text Editor so we are on a
Sublime Text Editor for our example
purpose I have used one image from an
unsplash.com and we have created a
simple class div clock container for it
now let's go and style these images to
get a 3d effect so first let's design
the body part
we'll set the margin and padding to zero
itself
we set the width to 100 percent
and will set the height to 100 vertical
Heights
we'll keep the display as Flex
and will align the items in the center
and will justify the content in the
center as well
now we'll design our container class
so for the container class we'll set the
position to relative
we'll set the width to 360 pixels
and will keep the height to 640 pixels
we'll set the margin top to 150 pixels
and will keep the background to White
we'll use the rgba format
we'll use the transform property to
apply a 2d or 3D transformation to an
element
so we'll use the transform and we'll use
its properties we'll keep this two
30 degrees
we'll set this Q to
say 25 degrees
and we'll scale it to 0.8
let's discuss more about this property
so
the translate profit defines a 2d or 3D
translation the scale defines the 2D or
3D draft scale transformation
and this Q property is used to give
transformation along the x or y axis
now let's design the images
foreign
to Absolute
we'll set the width to 100 percent
and will keep the transition time
to 0.5 seconds
let's go back to our page and see how it
looks up to this point
so as you can see we have the images
aligned as we want
on a flat side
milk will create the 3D transformation
when we hover over it
so let's go back to our CSS file
so for the 3D effect we are going to use
the edge child property the end style
selector allows you to take a single
argument that describes a pattern for
the matching element indices in a list
of siblings
we'll design the eat image separately so
for the fourth image
we'll use the transform property and
will translate it to 160 pixels and -160
pixels
let's copy this code
four times
okay we have to set the opacity as well
so we'll set the opacity here
to 1.
the opacity property says the
transparency of the element
just change that number of the ends
child elements so here we'll keep it to
120 pixels
minus 120 pixel will set the opacity
to 0.8
for the second element let's keep the
translate to 80 pixels
minus 80 pixels and we'll set the
opacity
to say 0.6
and for the last image
will translate it to 40 pixels
and minus 40 pixels and we'll keep the
opacity to say 0.4
so now when you save the file and you
will go back to the page
let's see how it looks
so if you refresh and hover over it now
you can see the image has a 3D over
effect over it there are four layers to
the image and we have
design the opacity according to the
image layer
so this is a 3D image hover
the next property we are going to
discuss is a 3D perspective image
so for this let's use a new set of
images
so we'll go back to the unsplash.com
again
and let's select one image
this one looks beautiful
so let's copy the image address
and mention it under the image tag
just save
[Music]
now when you go back to the page
you'll see you have your image here
now let's add the 3D perspective Image
Design over it so under our CSS file
let's first design all the elements
let's keep the margin and padding to
zero
let's keep the width of the container
elements 200 pixels
or say hundred percent
let's keep the minimum height to save
100 vertical Heights
and we'll use a background color of hash
let's design the image as well before
going back to the page
so we'll set the perspective to save
4000 pixels
the perspective property is used to
determine the distance between a z plane
and the user in order to give a 3D
positioned element some perspective
let's keep the width of the image 20
percent
will keep the position to Absolute
keep the left margin to 50 percent
and drop to 50 as well
we'll use a transform property
let me use the translate value of it to
minus 50 percent and plus 50 percent
we'll use the transform style property
and set the value to preserve 3D
the previous 3D indicates that the
children of the element should be
positioned in the 3D space
so just save the file and let's go back
to the page to see how it looks up to
this point
so as you can see we have the required
background image and we have the image
over
in a required position
now it's time to style our image
so use the transform property
and we'll rotate
we'll use the rotate X property of it
we'll keep it to 70 degrees
foreign
States
it results in the transform function
data type the transformation is tax size
where three dimensional Vector it
coordinates how much the element moves
in each Direction
let's set the Box shadow
to minus 80 pixels
60 pixels
15 pixels
it has an rgba value to
0 comma zero comma zero
point four let's say
let's set the transition to all 0.4
seconds
and we'll set the transform style to
preserve 3D
so just save the file and let's go back
to our page to see how it looks up to
this point
so as you can see the image is flat for
and ready for 3d effect now let's Design
This 3D over effect on it
so for the 3D over effect
we'll use the cover property image
colon rule
over the image
will set the transform
rotate x 0 degrees
rotate red to zero degrees
and translate 0 to
0 pixels comma
zero pixel comma 0 pixels
let's check this one again
this is right
now we'll set the Box Shadow to
0 pixels 0 pixels zero pixels
zero pixels and rgba
0 comma zero comma zero comma zero
just save the file
and refresh
now when you hover over it you will see
that the perspective of the image
changes
foreign
so this is a 3D perspective image
now there are many CSS effects that you
can design using these properties
in this video you will learn what is
navigation bar and its importance on a
web page
you will also learn how to create a
basic navbar using HTML and CSS
so let's start by discussing the agenda
for this tutorial
we will start with what is navigation
bar and why navigation bar is required
in a web page you will look at some of
the well-designed navigation bars on
websites after that you will work on the
code to create the basic navigation bar
using HTML and CSS so let us Begin by
discussing what is navigation bar
a navigation bar is a graphical user
interface intended to Aid the user in
accessing the information it is usually
placed at the top of the page a
navigation bar needs standard HTML as
the base
navigation bars can be created either
vertically or horizontally
so what makes a navigation bar so
important
an irrigation bar is an important
element of website design since it
allows user to quickly visit any
sections within the website if we have
ever visited a website without a
navigation bar you may have found it
difficult to locate the page you need
you may have also had to click back
several times in order to find a link to
the next section you wanted to visit
thankfully web design has become more
standardized in the recent years and
nearly every websites now include a
navigation bar keep in mind that you
want to keep people on a site to explore
further a well-designed navigation bar
is an important part of the user
experience now let us look at an example
of a navigation bar on a website we are
on the home page of Amazon website as
you can see this is the navigation bar
that has several elements on it as the
user clicks on these elements they will
be directed to the different sections of
the website the navigation bar allows
the user to easily boot through any
section of the website
by clicking on the best service button
you will be redirected to the best
sellers page on the Amazon
now we are going to create a navigation
bar with HTML and CSS that's going to
look like this
we'll have the following sections with
sub menus and some of them
make sure you have a text editor to
write the code I'll be using a Sublime
Text letter for this purpose we will
create two new files index.html and
style.css where we will be writing on
HTML and CSS code respectively
let's start by adding the standard
boilerplate
keep the title as CSS navbar
link your CSS file with the HTML file by
using the link tag and hdf attribute
this navigation bar is going to consist
of a bunch of UL tags which means an
another list and list items
let's create our first another list and
this will be our main menu of the
navigation bar
I have options such as home about
contact services and news so this is
going to be our main menu
save the file let's see what it looks
like right now by opening it inside our
browser
you can see it is just an unordered list
with no menu at this point let's go
ahead and add our sub menus home will
not have any sub menus but the about
list item is going to have a sub menu
add another UI tag inside the LI tag
this will create a sub menu inside the
about item save the file
just copy paste it and paste it inside
the UL tag
name them as team
clients
careers and Legacy
just make the indentation properly
if you see this is a browser you'll see
that we'll have the sub menus inside the
about let's do the same thing for
contacts just copy paste this whole
section and place them inside the
contacts list rename them according to
your wish and save the file
if you go back to the browser you will
see that we'll have the sub menus inside
the contact as well
as you can see this is our complete sub
menus without the styling all the HTML
content is ready now we are going to
write the CSS for it in the CSS file
let's apply the background image first
because it will make the page look a
little bit nicer
I have my file on my computer make sure
the image file is in the same folder as
your HTML and CSS file I am using a
tech.jpg
and for the background size I will set
it to the cover which is going to adjust
it to the image screen and it's going to
cover the whole background of our web
browser foreign
family as aerial
let's see what it looks like at this
stage you can see we have a background
image and the font is changed to Ariel
now let's make sure our unordered list
does not have any margins or padding by
setting it to zero
thank you
also put the list style to run because
we don't want to have any kind of bullet
under our listing
now another list list items they are the
main items that are going to apply the
style to the list items of the main URL
tag
float that all the text to the left
and set the given formatting
we will set the background color with
the hash
value003542 you can choose your own
value from our website known as color
picker.com
we will fix the line height to 40 pixels
this will Center the text vertically
text align to Center
this will align the text horizontally
and font size to 20 pixel
font size 20 pixels
let's see what it looks like now you can
see the text is floated to the left
now let's tell the actual menu link so
the menu link will be ulia
Uli a
keep the text decoration
to none and color white
keep the display as block
now it's time to set the hover effect of
our array the urli hover will set the
formatting when the user hovers over the
menu
we will use the background color of the
hash value de1 FCB
save the file and let's see what our
page looks like up to this point
you can see we have the hover effect
over our menus and we have the sub menus
under the main menu we want our set menu
should be visible only when we hover our
menus so we will set the UL Ally to
display none and we will set the hover
effect to the block
let's save the file and see what our
page looks like up to this point
now you can see our navigation bar is
ready
with all the sub menus and menus at
proper places we have this nice hover
effect over the menus
in this video we will discuss some cool
tricks that every web developer should
be familiar with and which will help you
during the time of your designing of the
web page so let's jump onto the Sublime
Text Editor and see these tricks so the
first trick is called the CSS blend mode
the CSS background blend property sets
the blend mode for each background layer
and you can blend it with image or with
different colors with the help of this
property we can blend background image
or blend them with colors
so here's an example of the CSS blend
mode here you can see the images are
blended with different colors
so let's see how we can achieve this
so for our example purpose I am going to
use this image
to our page
so in the body tag add the image URL and
the location of a file
keep the margin left and margin right to
auto
now let's add some style to a body tag
in the blend mode there are several
modes such as normal multiply darker and
lighter or screen
let's blend that image with one color so
you can select the color from this HTML
color codes I'll use this color for my
purpose so just copy paste here
and in the background blend mode let's
keep it to lightened
now if you save
and then refresh here
you can see we have Blended our image
with color
let's go back and change here something
different
let's keep it to darken
let's try something friend let's keep it
to screen
so as you can see there are several
properties for this blend mode and you
can use according to your needs the next
trick is called clipping the CSS clip
Pass Property creates a clipping region
that specifies the region that should be
shown on the page so let's understand
this with the help of an example here
we'll create a div
and give this class any class say TR
the easiest way to generate the clip
value is to use a generator
there are several websites that give the
value of the clip
so we'll use this
website to generate our clip value
suppose we want a hexagon shaped image
on our page
so here you can adjust it according to
your needs
the any shape that you want
here you can see the clip value just
copy paste it from here
now here we'll use that class that we
are specified
we'll just copy paste the clip value
here
will keep the height to say
fifty percent or less than sixty percent
set the width to sixty percent as well
select the color you want to give to a
clipped image
I'll use the same color from the
previous example
so just copy paste this color code
keep the position to Absolute
and Z index to minus 1.
just save and go back to the page and
refresh
now you can see we have the clipped
image on our page let's try something
different
um let's say I want
a left Arrow
so just copy paste this
clip
value clip path value
[Music]
foreign
and you can see we have the arrow on our
page another must have for web
developers is animations
CSS allows us to animate almost every
property that we use in the CSS
let's look at one example so here an
HTML file we'll just add one div tag
first
and to start with animation we'll have
to mention a keyframe the keyframes
allows us to create different steps for
our animations
we'll keep the keyframes name to Blink
so here in this example we'll create a
box and we'll add different colors at
different points of animations right so
we'll write zero percent and we'll set
the background
to Indigo
which change the colors five times so
just copy paste this code five times
we want next change at 30 so we'll set
the background here
suppose say red
at 50 we wanted yellow
at 70 we wanted green
and finally we'll change it to say blue
so inside the div tag we'll mention the
height and width of the Box first let's
say 400 pixels and width also 400 pixels
now I will mention the border of the box
so just set it to say one pixel
solid black
now for the animations part
will set the animation for 10 seconds
and for infinite number of times
write this webkit so as to support in a
Google Chrome
okay
now just save the file and go back to
our page
and here you can see we have the
animation on our box
you can style each and every elements in
HTML using animations
another thing you can do is add PSS
gradient the CSS gradient property
allows you to add smooth transitions
between two or more colors
for this purpose you can get the
gradient value from a website called
grid CSS gradient.io
foreign
you can get the mix and match of the
different colors you want to use let's
look at an example to understand better
so here in this HTML file first let's
set the height so we'll set the height
to 100 percent
now inside the body tag
will keep the height as 100 percent
foreign
color
let's select different colors this time
so we will use say this color
this time
just copy paste the value here
now for the gradient value just go back
here in this website and you can select
the color you want
let's say I want a mix of this color
and you can change the shades from here
now when you're done with the colors
just go back below and copy this
code here
to your page
now when you go back to the page you
will have a beautiful gradient here
let's try one more
this time a linear gradient
just copy this value to your code
just save the file and go back to the
page
and you will have a linear gradient here
in this video we are going to learn some
of the more advanced features that can
be used to optimize your web page and
add some extra features to it
so let's get started so the first
function we are going to discuss is CSS
sudo class
a CSS sudo class is a keyword added to a
selector let's specify the special state
of the selected elements
so low class lets you apply a style to
an element not only in relation to the
content of the documentary but also the
relation to external factors like
history of the Navigator the status of
its content or the position of the mouse
like hover which lets you know if the
mouse is over an element or not
so the first sudo class we are going to
discuss is CSS hover
this pseudo class is used to add a
special effect to an element when our
Mouse pointer is over it
let's work an example to understand how
this works
so we are on a Sublime Text Editor and
we have added a standard wall update to
it
so first I'll create a box element
s
we get the div class box
foreign
let's save this and see right now what
is the status of our page
so as you can see we have this simply
learn tag and the heading that we have
given and the color changes when you go
over me
now add a style tag to define the
styling of the box
so
we'll keep the background color of the
box as
painting
will keep the width to 300 pixels and
height
up to 200 pixels
we'll set the margin to auto
if the font size 240 pixels so that we
can see the text clearly
and will align the text to the center
just save and go back to the page
now you can see
we have this box with the tag the color
changes when you hover over me
now to add the hover effect you just
have to mention the class with semicolon
and hover so we'll mention the class box
it's a semicolon and Hoover
he'll mention the background color to
which the Box will change any hover over
Mouse
so we'll keep the background color to
say a CN color
just save and go back to the page
so if you refresh and when you hover
over it you can see the color changes
so this is how the pseudo hover class
works
the next photo class we are going to
discuss is an active solo class
the actors for the class represents an
element that has been activated by the
user either while pointing a device or
by a touchscreen device
let's work on an example to understand
how to use the active class to change
the color of active elements the
possible values could be any color name
in any valid format so we'll use the
same example with some minor changes
first
let's change this text here
we keep it to click here
effects
we keep this part as same and instead of
over here we will use the active pseudo
class so we type active and we'll keep
the background clear to scan
let's text align this H1 to the center
when you refresh and go back
so
you see here it is click here to see the
effects now
to see the difference now you can see
when we are hovering over it the color
does not change it instead of it when we
click on it the color changes
foreign
class works the next Advanced Property
we are going to discuss is a CSS sudo
elements
a CSS pseudo element is a keyword added
to a selector that lets you style a
specific part of the selected element
you can use one pseudo class element in
a selector
it must appear after the simple
selectors in the statement
as a rule double column should be used
instead of a single column this
distributes the singular classes from
the pseudoelement so the first Studio
element we are going to discuss is the
first letter Studio element this pseudo
element applies that the first letter of
the first line of the Block Level
element
let's work out an example to understand
this better
so let's add some content to the body
and we'll add an H1
which says welcome
and we'll add an H2
which says this is an example
foreign
let's just give proper spacing here
now to this H1 that will add the first
letter sudo so to add the first letter
sudo element just use the double colon
and type first
letter
we'll keep the font family of the first
letter as well you see the
calligraphy
there's a spelling mistake
it will keep the font size to 370 meters
we keep the color to red
and just add a text shadow
for better animation
so we'll keep the text Shadow to 5
pixels
keep pixels
and pixels and color cyan
now when you save and go back
just refresh so this WC is a first
letter pseudo element
as you can see we have changed this
first letter with the proper shadowing
of a CN color and a different font size
so this is how the first let us
pseudo element works
the next one we are going to discuss is
the before pseudo element
the before pseudo element can be used to
insert some content before the content
of an element
let's work out an example
so just add the standard boilerplate
inside the body let's add
welcome to Simply learn
we'll add the text inside a q tag the
qtag defines a short quotation so inside
the queue tag
we'll add welcome
to get closed
to
and away
and again Q tag
in pre-learn
now that we have the text inside the
body let's add the styling
foreign
so we'll keep the font size of all the
text 230 pixels this is the all selector
we have used
font size 30 pixels
now before the text we are going to add
some symbols so we'll use double column
Q before
we'll add the content with some symbol
like this
foreign
keep the color of this
symbol to Blue
and we'll use the after pseudo class to
add the content
like this
we'll keep this color to red
now that we have everything in place
let's go back to see how it looks
you can see the symbols before and after
our text so this is how the before
pseudo element works
so the next function we are going to
discuss is CSS loader
the CSS loader is an animation that
shows the visitor about the page when it
is loading
it is helpful when a page takes some
seconds to load the page content it is
similar to the buffer sign so let's see
how to create a loader so I hope you
remember the concept of the keyframes
and animations
if you want to revise the concepts you
can watch the previous videos on the
keyframes and animations from the
playlist
so
let's create the loader
we have the standard boilerplate
so inside the body tag just add the
center tag and inside it
will add one H1 which says
welcome to Simply learn
and we'll add five div tags with the
class A1 A2 A3 A4 and A5
just copy paste it five times
A1 A2 A3 input and A5
let's open our style tag inside of style
tag we'll first add color to our H1 so
let's keep the color of our H1 to Orange
now comes the div tag so for the div
tags
we'll keep the display to block
um keep the position to Absolute
we set the width and height to 10 pixels
each so with 10 pixels
High 10 pixels
foreign
function to determine the left margin so
to use the calc function that add CLC
50 percent
minus 1 em
the calc function performs a calculation
to be used as a property value
foreign
radius to say 1.3 em
is related to the font size of the
element
1.3 em means 1.3 times the size of the
current point
we'll use the transform origin function
with the value 1.3 em
and two em
the transfer margin property allows you
to change the position of the
transformed elements
2D Transformations can change the X and
Y axis
we'll keep the animation iteration count
to infinite
I will keep the animation duration to 2
seconds
let's save and go back to the page to
see how it looks at this point
so as you can see we have our heading
and you cannot see it but we have a
loader ready
and we just have to add some keyframes
and animations here
so
let's define keyframes
foreign
[Music]
function to rotate it to
zero degrees
just copy copy this
100 when it's complete it will rotate to
the complete 360 degrees
so here we will give the right 360
degrees
now let's return each of the
classes here that we have defined so
dot K1
the animation delay
will be of 0.1 seconds
so for each of the classes that we have
here we have to Define them with a
different color so that when the loader
appears we can see them clearly with the
different colors so for this A1 let's
keep the background color to say cyan
let's copy paste it
so that if you don't you don't have to
write our code again and again
three four and five
let's make changes here so for the A2
you want it
to appear after 0.2 seconds
the color of pink
let's see is 2 0.3 seconds
The Color Purple
0.4 seconds with color green
0.5 seconds is color black
we have kept the animation delay to so
close like 0.1 seconds 0.2 seconds 0.6
seconds so that the loader appears in a
complete sink with each other
so just save the file and refresh and go
back to the page
now you can see this is the loader we
have our heading and this is like a
buffer and it will show when you have
some content to load
in this tutorial we are going to discuss
what is responsive design and how we can
achieve this
so let's get started making a website
with an adaptable layout is called
responsive web design and CSS media quiz
are one of the most important part of
responsive design
in the past building a website was much
simpler today a Website Layout should
adapt itself not only to computers but
also to tablets mobile devices and even
TVs so let's see how we can create
responsive web layout using CSS media
queries with the help of an example so
here we have a Sublime Text writer we
haven't asked our standard wallet ready
so let's create something
so let's start by creating the four days
here
we'll give it a class name box
with an ID box one
we'll name this windows
just copy it four times
let's rename this ID to box two and here
we'll type back OS
for the Box 3 will have
Linux and other box or
will have Android
let's add some styling over here
we'll just open this time tag
I will explain the textures we send the
text align to Center
uh we'll set the background color let's
select some color
so we go to the center HTML fellow
course choose a book seller
description
you set the text color to white
and we'll set the font size to say
something
let's go back to refresh the page
we have some errors let's figure it out
okay so first this is not valid let's do
this
so classy refresh you see we have our
lives with Windows Mac OS Linux and
Android and with this background color
so to design a responsive web pages use
the media queries so what are media
query let's first discuss this
so a media queries are used when you
want to customize the website's
presentation according to the user
screen size with the help of the media
queries you can display different
markups based on the device's general
type mobile desktop tablet to name it
is applied to the Target element
so to start the video query just type at
the rate and media
now here we'll mention the max width
to save 400 pixels
inside this media query you write the
CSS code that should take an effect when
this condition is satisfied
so here
you set the box one
to display block
now
you go back to the page and page and
refresh
you see nothing happens because we are
not made this display To None So first
go back to the CSS code
and set any display to none
now you can see we don't have any
display here so let's inspect the page
first
so you see we have our contents here now
you can see this is the layout we are
currently using the current width is 685
pixels into high 255 pixels
now we are setting a Max width to 400
pixels
if this width decreases to less than 400
pixels how this CSS score will kick in
so let's decrease the width here
so as you decrease
this way
QC as soon as it gets less than 400
pixels our CSS kit kicks in so we have
our Windows displayed here which is the
box id1 so this is how the media query
Works let's add some more media queries
to understand it better so just copy
this code now
so now let's set this minimum width
to
401 pixels
and maximum you say 600 pixels
now when this condition is true let's
say we want our box to
to display block
with color green
so this is the background color here
to please say green
now we will add one more media query
so just copy this code
[Music]
paste it here
so when the width is from 601 pixels to
stay
800 pixels so we'll set the Box 3
display
to block and color
to fitting
so just save this and let's understand
it
on the page
so let's change the width of the screen
so see as soon as the width goes less
than 400 pixels we have our windows on
display now we're going to increase the
width size and it goes more than 401
pixels it has a Mac OS display keep on
increasing it
now see the width is more than 1500
pixels and we have a Linux on display so
this is how we create the responsive web
design for the different devices in this
session we bring to you all the
fundamental concepts of JavaScript first
let's have a look at the agenda for the
session first we look at a simple hello
world program using JavaScript
then we'll understand the different
types of arrays deployed in JavaScript
we look at the concept of Loops objects
this keyword and functions in detail
then we learn about form validation
JavaScript regular expressions
and JavaScript email validation
then we'll move on to more advanced
topics like promises and asyncavate so
without further delay let's begin so
what is Javascript
JavaScript is a dynamic computer
programming language which is
lightweight and object oriented
now the best part about JavaScript is
the fact that it's open source and it's
cross-platform compatible meaning one
piece of code written in any system
regardless of the operating system
functions the same in other operating
systems as well
lastly most commonly used as a part of
web pages it allows client-side script
to interact with the user and make
Dynamic pages
now moving on to the next important
question why JavaScript
now being the most popular language in
the world JavaScript has a huge fan base
and benefits from a large community
support
JavaScript is now being used in many
industry Fields such as web development
mobile application development and also
game development it is very diverse in
nature
there are great career opportunities for
JavaScript developers as this technology
seems to be holding on its own when
compared to other languages
all right now moving on let's go ahead
and execute a simple program to
understand JavaScript better
so we'll go ahead and execute a simple
hello world program
all right for that first thing you need
is the text editor in this case we've
used the VF code editor
so now let's go to our text editor that
is vs code and here let's open a file
let's say in file and now you can type
in your code here so we will have to add
the JavaScript to the HTML code and then
print out the words hello world on the
browser window right that's an objective
so let's add the HTML boilerplate in
this file
so let's type in HTML
this is our tag
and then next we have the body type
So within the body tag
we can add the script tag to insert the
JavaScript into HTML page right so we
say script
language
equals JavaScript
and type
equals
text
slash
JavaScript
all right
let's close the path
and then in the script we call a
JavaScript function that is document.wi
which writes the string to our HTML page
right so we say document
dot right
and within braces we say hello world
thank you
and now we close the tags
you also close the body
and primitive
all right
now when we save the file
you're going to save it say on my
desktop and I'm going to call it
index.html
right so make sure the extension is HTML
and then save it
and that is already exists
if I replace it
and now once you save it as an HTML file
you can see that the colors will appear
so any errors will be easily indicated
here
so now let me see this and now let's go
ahead and execute the file that is
stored
okay let me go back
to my desktop
and here I have indexed HTML there you
go when you click on the file it opens
in your browser
and you can see the words hello world in
this we will be learning all about
JavaScript arrays and the popular
methods of the array object
so what's in it for you we'll start by
understanding what a JavaScript array is
then we will get to know about the
operations that we are performing on the
array
after that we'll get familiar with some
of the most used array methods and
lastly we'll go through map reduce and
filter functions
so what exactly is an array
now an array object lets you store
multiple values in a single variable
it stores a fixed size sequential
collection of elements of the same type
now when array is used to store a
collection of data and it uses only
integers as element indices
however associative arrays can also use
string indices
moving on let's understand what array
operations are
now we can perform various operations on
an array in JavaScript but let's start
by creating an area
so for that let's go ahead and create a
folder first which will consist of the
file that we're creating right so for
that
let me just uh go ahead and create a
folder
and I'll call it demo underscore array
so once you're done with that open your
Visual Studio code editor
and here say open folder
and click on demo array
okay is creating the workbench all right
and now here you can see the new file
icon so go ahead and create
demo.html file
all right here you go now let's start
typing the code
the first thing we do is type in our
HTML tag
and here I have the head tag
[Music]
foreign JavaScript
tutorial
all right and now let's create the body
tag
now within the body tag I create a
paragraph tag and create an ID and let
me call it demo
and then close the tag now I'll explain
to you why we're doing this a little
later
so first let's go ahead and create the
script tag
so save script
and within the script let's create our
array so let me use the keyword let
and say we give the name of the array
cars
equals in square base braces we say BMW
and uh Volvo
[Music]
and then say Honda
all right so now we create an array now
one more thing is that we use the
keyword let so that which indicates that
the array can be changed throughout the
program
all right so now we go ahead and display
it so I say document
[Music]
dot get element by ID
and here I say now the ID created was
demo so I say demo here
and I use the DOT in our HTML property
which is equal to cars
okay let me change this to BMW first
all right so what exactly a naught HTML
does is that it is responsible for what
is being displayed on the web page okay
now since we've taken ID as demo any
changes made is reflected in this ID and
then displayed onto the web browser
all right so let's save this and now
execute the file
so here I go back to my folder and then
to the file and go ahead and click on it
so there you go
The Heading is displayed and the entire
array is displayed here
all right so let's go back to our vs
code
okay so I hope this was easy to
understand
now let's go ahead
so the next operation is to access an
array element so let's go back to our vs
code
and here let's create another variable
say let BMW BMW variable don't get
confused with the array element so BMW
equals cars of the index 0. so basically
cars of 0 is nothing but BMW all right
so that is being saved in the variable
BMW
and now let's just go ahead and display
this
so we let's just copy this
and paste it here and instead of cars
you use the variable name BMW that is
this one
all right
so now let's save this
and when we
execute it
you see BMW here that's how you retrieve
an element from an array next up we have
the array length property which displays
the length of the array
so again let me show you how to do that
let's go back to our code
and here
let's create a variable and let's call
it length variable so I say let Len
equals cars.lab
now you can use the length property
which will retrieve the length of the
array for us it's as simple as that
and now after this again let's just
copy the same
code here and then
let's pass Len
okay
now let's save this
and when you execute it again
it says 3.
so we've successfully retrieved the
length of the array
all right so the next operation is to
access the last array element right so
let's go back to our vs code and now
let's create another variable and let's
call it last
and we'll just say last equals cars
and within Square braces cars.length
minus 1.
right
so basically
the length of the array is 3 and 3 minus
1 is 2 so it should retrieve
cars of 2 which is Honda right
so let's just
execute this let me pass last here
save it and see if it displays Honda for
us
there you go
it's as simple as that
all right so moving on
the next array operation is Loop over an
array item
so for that let's go to our
code
and here
let's use the for node so I say cars dot
for each
and within this we'll save
item
comma index
comma array
and now we use the arrow function
and display the content on the console
so I say console.log
of item
along with its index
so let's see this
and now let's go ahead and execute it
all right now as you can see nothing is
printed on your web page right because
whatever is being printed has to be
printed in your console so now click on
F12 which opens the developer options
and here you can see console so click on
that and now you can see the name of the
item in the array along with its index
so you see BMW 0 Volvo 1 and Honda two
all right
so moving on now that we've learned
about the array operations let's go
ahead and learn about the array methods
so the first method is two string now as
the name suggests it is used to convert
an array into a string
all right so let's go back to our vs
code
and now let's copy the same
code here
and here instead of last I just say
cars.2 string
now you can use this method
to convert the array into a string so
let's save this
and let's execute it
all right now here are the same output
as shown which means that the type has
only been changed to string type
All Right Moving On
the next method is pop now pop basically
removes the last element from the array
so let me show you how that works
let's go back to our vs code and here
we have to save the pop element into a
variable right so let's create a
variable say last
okay and oh since last is already used
let me call it last one
last one of cars.pop we can use the pop
method to pop the element
and now you can just
copy the same code
to display this onto our web page
and here I just see
last one
now since we've popped the last element
the array has only two elements right
that is BMW and Volvo so if you want to
display the last element it should
display Volvo right so what we can do is
we can just create another variable say
last two
and just
use the same logic here
okay and now let's just
split on our console and let's say last
two all right
so now let's save it
now the popped element has been saved in
last one which is displayed on the web
page and the last element of the array
after the pop function has to be
displayed on our console
so let's go ahead and execute the file
all right so Honda has been displayed
that is the element that has been
removed from the array and now once we
check our console
here you go here you can see Volvo which
means that is the last element in the
array
moving on
the next method is the push method now
as the name suggests it is used to add a
new element to the array and remember to
the end of the array so let's go back to
our vs code
and here let me say cars
dot push push is the method that we are
using inside of which we'll say Audi all
right
and now let's just display the same
things so let me copy this
and here let me say cars
okay so let me save it
and once I execute it
it says BMW Volvo and Audi so we'll
successfully added another element to
the end of the array
so the next method is the shift method
now basically shift is used to remove
the first element from the array now
this method shifts all the elements
reducing the indices of every element by
one all right let me show you how this
works
so let's go back to RVS code
and here let me just say cars dot shift
it's as simple as that and let's just
display this
let me copy the same thing
let's save it and when we execute it
here you can see it just displays Volvo
and Audi so now cars has array elements
Volvo and Audi with array indices 0 and
1.
all right so moving on the next method
is on shift
all right so to add an element into the
beginning of an array we use the unshift
method therefore this method increases
the array index by 1. right so let's go
back to our vs code
and use the same function on shift
cars Dot unshift
here we go let's
save it and here we have to specify what
we're adding right let me say Hyundai
okay
let's save this
and when we execute it you can see
Hyundai Volvo and Ori
as simple as that
all right moving on the next method is
the concat method now this is basically
used to merge two different areas right
so let's go back to our vs code
and sure
let's create another array first
and let's just call the array bikes okay
and let's create say Yamaha
and let's see Suzuki
foreign
and now
let's save this
and say let Vehicles this is another
array which is basically the after
concatenation
the entire array is saved into this
array all right so let's say cars Dot
concat
[Music]
of bikes we just concat bikes and cars
together
okay and then let's just
display this over the web page so
let me change this to vehicles
[Music]
all right let me save this
so let's go ahead and execute it
there you go now both the areas have
been merged together into a single array
so the next array method is the sort
method now basically sort is used to
sort the entire array into ascending
order all right so let's go back to our
editor
and here
let's just use the
sort method on the
array Vehicles all right
Vehicles dot sort
okay
and let's just
play this on our web page
so again
let's go back and
execute it and here you can see it has
been sorted
the next method
is the reverse method so the reverse
method is again used to reverse the
elements in an array so it's logic right
so sort was used to sort it in ascending
order now when you reverse it it just
sorts it in the descending order
so let's go back here
you want to copy the same thing
all right and here instead of sort
let me just say divorce
so let's save this and execute it
there we go it is displayed the entire
array in the reverse order
all right
with that we finish the array methods
next up we have map reduce and filter
first up we have array.map now the map
method is used for creating a new array
from an existing one by applying a
function to each and every one of the
elements in the first array
and it does not change the original
array all right so to make you
understand this better let's go back to
our Visual Studio code
and now here let's first create another
area
okay so let me call this num1
and let's have
integers let's say 2 3 4 5.
6 and 7. okay
and now let's have another array
num2
so let's go ahead and say num1
dot map
of let me Define a function say multiply
okay so multiply is the function that is
that I'm going to Define here
so let's say function
multiply
of value
okay
and inside this let me say return
value
into 2.
okay
so what this basically does
is that it multiplies each and every
element of the array num1 by 2 and saves
the new elements into the array num2
okay now after this let's go ahead and
display the contents so let me copy this
and let's display the content
in the array nump2
right so let me save it
let's go back here
execute it so there we go every element
has been multiplied by 2 and then
displayed again
I hope this was clear for you
now the next method is the filter method
so the filter method takes each element
in an array and applies a conditional
statement against it
and if this condition returns true the
element gets pushed onto the output
array but if it returns false the
element does not get pushed all right so
let me show it to you
now
let's
go ahead and create another
variable say num3
and here I see num1
dot filter
of say com
now comp is a function
let me Define the function here
let me say function
comp
of value
takes a value as a parameter
within which I'm going to check if the
value is greater than 4.
now with only appends the element into
the array num3 if the value is greater
than 4. all right
so now let me just
go ahead and change this to num3 all
right let's save this
and when we go back and execute
here we go
now the values so let's go back here let
me check
now num1 had the values two three four
five six and seven right so according to
this it has to only display five six and
seven to not get confused with num2 here
with pass num1 here so it checks put
this array
right so according to the logic it
should display five six and seven and it
has done so here
okay
moving on
the next method is the reduce method
now the reduced method reduces an array
of values down to just one single value
now to get the output value it runs a
reducer function to each element of that
array
okay now this method does not reduce the
original array again
so let's go back to our vs code
now let me create another
variables in Num 4
and say num1 dot reduce
and let me call it sum so what we're
basically doing is that we're adding all
the digits two three four five six and
seven in num1 to a single value right
that is the sum and then we're going to
be displaying that
so what we're going to do is let's
define the function here
function sum
basically is total comma value
right and then here let's say return
total Plus
the value
okay
and after this
I'm going to
display the content so let's say num 4.
okay let's save it go back and execute
here we go it displays the sum of the
entire values in the array we're
learning all about JavaScript loops if
you're new to JavaScript I suggest you
go through our previous videos on this
topic
so without further Ado let's begin and
look at what's in store for you
so we're going to be covering topics
like for Loop while loop which also
includes the do while loop and then
we're going to learn about breaking out
of a loop and then we'll see how to skip
a loop cycle
now before jumping into the for Loop
let's first understand what exactly a
loop is right so a loop is basically a
programming construct that executes a
piece of code as long as a certain
condition is met
all right and there are two different
types of Loops we have entry control
loops and exit control loops now what
exactly are entry control loops now
these are the loops where the test
condition is checked before executing
the piece of code
for example you have the for Loop and
the while loop so in their case before
entering the loop the condition is
checked and only if the condition is met
it enters the loop and executes the code
all right when it comes to exit control
loops the test condition is checked
after the loop has been executed all
right so in this case the loop at least
gets executed I mean the code in the
loop gets executed at least once
so the example for this is the two while
loop all right with this basic knowledge
let's go ahead and learn about the
different loops
so the first Loop is the for Loop all
right
so what exactly is a for load this is
the basic logic and the flowchart in
front of you so what exactly happens is
that say for example you want to print
the word looping say 10 times right so
what you can do is you can start and you
can have a for Loop which goes from 0 to
9. and then you increase the number by
one every time you print the loop once
it's equal to 10 or even greater than 10
it ends the load right so let me help
you understand this better with an
example so let's go to our editor that
is vs code
here I've created a folder called demo
underscore Loops within which I've
created a file called for Loops all
right so now let's just write down our
initial code for HTML that is
HTML
and then I have a head tag
[Music]
but in which I save JavaScript
loops
all right
now I have a body tag
[Music]
within which I give a heading for
clearer understanding let me have a
heading say
JavaScript
[Music]
for loops
all right
let me just call it for Loop
now let's have the script tag
within which
I'll have
a variable say X
and now we have the for Loop so we say
four
x equals
zero
X less than
five
X plus plus
within which I say console DOT log of x
so basically
what happens is
now you have the first readable which is
called the counter variable now this
keeps track of how many times the code
is being executed
right and next I less than 5 is the
condition now the loop keeps executing
as long as the condition is met
and lastly the counter variable is
implemented and usually it's incremented
by one right so here we've done the same
thing
and inside the loop we print the value
of x
all right so let me save the file
and then execute it
all right it's printed JavaScript Loops
here let me just go back
okay my bad I missed out on the title
tag
so this has to be enclosed within the
title tag
so let me just
change it here
now let's save this
let's go back and just refresh the page
and that is it so whatever is in the
title tag basically appears here all
right so now since we're printing the
value of x on our console we'll have to
inspect our element so let's go here
and here let's check on console
and here you can see all the values have
been printed from 0 to 4. all right now
this is a simple for Loop
so next up is a while loop
now the logic is similar to that of a
for Loop first the condition is checked
and if the condition holds true then the
code is executed and if it is false it
terminates
all right so moving on let's understand
the general syntax
so here first you have the variable
whose value keeps changing
and then you have the ending condition
which is basically the maximum value a
variable can reach all right so let's go
back to our vs code
and here for better understanding let me
just change this to JavaScript while
loop
all right let's just
delete this and here let's initialize
the value of x to 1.
and now I say while X
less than or equal to 5
within braces I
say console.log
of x
and then I increment the value of x
all right so let me save this
and let's execute the file
all right so it says JavaScript while
loop and let's inspect and here in our
console it displays the values of x
all right so according to the logic
X is initially initialized to 1
and the value gets executed once it
enters the while loop all right it's
incremented and then checked every time
until the value reaches
6 right and then it breaks from the loop
since the value does not hold true and
then it terminates
so this is a logic behind the while loop
next up is the two while loop
now here
as you can see first the code is
executed and then the condition is
checked if the condition is true then
the code execution continues and if it
falls it's terminated all right so this
is an exit control Loop also in an exit
control Loop the code is executed at
least once so let's go back to our vs
code
and here
let me just delete this
now let's initialize X to say
15 all right and now I use the do
keyword within which I write the code so
first I'm going to print the value of x
console DOT log of x
and then I increase my value
and here I mentioned my test condition
which is while X
less than say 10.
all right so according to the logic
initially the value is X and once it
enters the loop here
it should print the value of x which is
15. all right and then it increments the
value but once it comes out of the loop
it checks for the condition
here the condition says less than 10 but
since X is not less than 10 it prints
the value X that is 15 and then
terminates all right so let's save this
and execute it
so let me execute this
and here
let's check
the console
so there we go it prints 15. so what it
does is that it prints the value 15
first and then checks the condition
now
let's go ahead and change the value of x
to save
5.
all right so now it enters the loop and
then it prints the value of x and then
increments it and when it comes out of
the loop and checks the condition
as long as the value of x remains less
than 10 it prints it okay
so let's save this
go back here
and let's refresh the page
and here you can see the value is 5 to 9
are printed so this is how the do while
loop works
moving on to the next concept breaking
out of a loop now as the name suggests
break is the keyword that is used to
break out of a loop now here is a simple
code for you
so according to the logic it prints the
values between 1 to 10. and say at the
value 5 you want to break out of the
loop you can simply use the keyword
break so let's go back to our vs code
and here let me just
make it simple
unsave
for x equals one
X less than or equal to 10
[Music]
let's increment it
and within the loop let's
display the value X
on the console and then we're going to
check for the condition if x equals 5.
all right so if x equals 5 we break out
of the loop
so let's save the file and execute it
and there you go it's displayed the
values from 1 to 5.
so basically the code inside the for
Loop is executed and once the value of x
reaches 5 it breaks from the loop
simple right
all right so let's move on
next up we have skipping a loop cycle
all right so here what exactly we do is
we make use of a keyword continue to
skip a particular Loop cycle
say in this case we have a for Loop
which displays the values of I ranging
from 1 to 10. however we want to skip
the cycle when it reaches the value 3 so
what we do is we make use of the keyword
continue here so basically it displays
one and two and skips the third cycle
and then directly displays four all
right so let me show you in our vs core
editor here
let me just remove this and Save
if x equals
[Music]
I'm going to continue
all right
after which
I'm going to say console
DOT log f of x
so let me save this and then execute it
so here let me refresh the page
and there we go
as you can see it displays one two three
and four and the fifth cycle
is skipped
all right and the rest of the digits are
displayed so that is how you can skip a
load I highly suggest you also practice
all of this and then play around with
loops to get a better understanding
so taking a step forward we're going to
learn about JavaScript objects so
without further Ado let's begin and look
at what's in store for us
first we'll start by understanding what
a JavaScript object is then we learn how
to create a JavaScript object and also
get to know about the properties of
these objects after that we'll get
familiar with using JavaScript methods
lastly we'll understand what JavaScript
accessors are
so what is a JavaScript object
JavaScript is an object-oriented
programming language so everything in
Java is an object
a JavaScript object is like a real world
entity having State and behavior for
example a car now we can take a car as
an object it will have its state like
color and model it will also have
behaviors like accelerate and break
JavaScript is template based and we can
create objects without having the need
to create a class
generally object is accompanied by a
class that defines an object's
blueprints but JavaScript doesn't
require any class to be defined for
objects
moving on to the next concept
to create a JavaScript object now
basically there are three different ways
of creating a JavaScript object all
right so we look at them one by one
the first one is to use a literal to
create and Define a JavaScript object
so let's go to our vs code editor
now if you have any doubts regarding the
initial setup then I suggest you go
through the previous video that is
Javascript arrays to get you started
with it so here I've created a folder
called demo objects and now I'm going to
create a file
called create
underscore objects dot HTML
all right
so we'll Begin by writing the initial
code
that is the head and the body so I say
HTML
within this as create the head tag
[Music]
and then I create a title tag
and let's say JavaScript
objects
then after the head tag I'm going to
create a body tag
and let's create a heading and say
creating JavaScript
objects
okay
and now we create
an ID
all of this is explained in the previous
video I really suggest you go through
the video before and that you get a
clear picture
and then I say ID equals
say demo
and then I'm gonna close it
now the first method that we're going to
use to create an object is by using
object literals right so what we can do
is say script
within which I declare a variable
say
where student
now within the object we're going to
create three different properties now
this is basically like a dictionary it
has a property a key and then a value
okay so I say name property and let's
say
crisp
and then another property say h and say
21.
another property say
studies
and say maybe computer designs
[Music]
okay so this is the syntax used to
create an object using an object
literary
now after this what we're going to do is
we're going to display this right now we
want to display the message saying Chris
of age 21 studies computer science so
what we can do is say document dot get
element by ID
and the ID that we're going to pass is
demo
we say
in now HTML
equals
student dot name
which is Chris
after which we display the message
of the age
and then the age that is student dot h
studies
student Dot
okay let's save this
and when we execute the file it says
Chris of the h21 studies computer
science
all right this is one of the ways in
which you can define an object
all right so moving on to the next way
of creating a JavaScript object it is to
use the new keyword now this is the most
traditional way of creating an object
right so let's go back to our vs code
foreign
script
[Music]
within which we see
where student equals new
object
I'm sure everybody has learned the same
way the same syntax
so this is one of the ways after which
we can say student dot name equals Chris
again student dot age
equals 21
and then student Dot
studies
equals computer science
[Music]
all right
now after this we again
display the message so let me just copy
this
all right
so let's save this
and run our code again
and there we go it displays the message
Chris of the h21 studies computer
science
all right this was the second method
used to create an object
all right so then moving on to the third
method
it is to use an object Constructor to
create and Define a JavaScript object so
let's go back to our code editor
and here
[Music]
we Define a function so we say function
say start
with three parameters
that is name age
and say
studies
okay and now within the function we use
the keyword this so we say this dot name
equals name
all right and you say this dot h
equals h
when I say this dot studies
equals studies
now what we do is that we can
create a variable and pass parameters to
the function so we see where
student
equals stud and within braces we say
Chris
comma 21
comma computer science
[Music]
all right so we've done passing the
parameters
after this
we're going to copy the same
print message
here
[Music]
all right so let's save this and execute
our file
so let's refresh the web page
and there we go it still displays the
message place of the age 21 studies
computer science so this was the third
method that can be used to create
objects
moving on to the next topic
object properties
now a JavaScript object is basically a
collection of unordered properties right
values associated with the JavaScript
object are called its properties
and properties can usually be added
updated or deleted excluding read-only
properties so now let's have a look at
the demo to help you understand this
better
so let me go back to my
vs code so this was where we left off
and this was how we created objects
right so now let me create another file
and let me call it
objects underscore properties
[Music]
email
and now what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
copy the first piece of code here
all right let me just copy this into my
new file
and here as you can see student is the
object that we've created and name agent
studies are the three properties
now say we want to update the age all
right so what we can do is here we can
just say student
dot h equals
let me change it to 24 all right
and let me save this and when we execute
the file that is object underscore
properties
you can see Chris at the age 24 so 21 is
updated to 24. so this is one of the
ways you can do it
or there's another method
you can just assign the property to a
variable and then display the variable
instead so what we can do is we can just
assign student.h to a property say X
and here instead of displaying
student.age we can just say
all right so let's save this
and when we run it
it says 21 because we haven't updated
21 to 24 anywhere all right
so 21 Remains the Same
so another method we can use is we can
just say
x equals h
so we're directly assigning the property
to the variable
and here when I am displaying it I say
student of x
all right
so let me save this
and when you look at the web page
it still displays the same thing these
are different ways of accessing the
properties you can update them delete
them unless they read only
all right so let's move on to the next
concept object methods now basically a
JavaScript method is an action that can
be performed on the objects
so you'll understand better with the
help of the demo
so let's go back to RBS code and here
I've created another HTML file called
objects underscore methods all right so
let's let me just copy the initial code
paste it here and let's have the
enclosing tags as well
[Music]
and HTML all right now here I declare
another tag that is the button tag so
we're going to be making this a button
here so I save button
ID equals click B so that is the action
that I'm going to
performing
and the message that is going to be
displayed on the button will be
okay
all right
so we're going to see the usage of it a
little later
now let's go ahead and create an object
so I say script
within which I create
[Music]
the user object
so we created using a object literal
here
and I declare the property name
as this again
and age
say 24 okay
so let's close this
all right so the next thing I'm going to
do is I'm going to create a new function
that we will use as an object method
all right so I say function
and let's give the name say hi
okay
within the function we declare
we basically display a message so we're
going to say alert and hello
all right so this is going to be
displayed in a separate dialog box
so now once the Declaration is done
what we're going to do is we're going to
use
create another property basically say
user Dot
let's say message
and assign say hi to it
so basically what we're doing
is we're adding the previously created
method to a new property that is user
Dot message the message property all
right
so now I say
document dot get element by ID
we say demo
[Music]
and the message that I want is just
High plus the username all right
[Music]
so what we're going to do is we're going
to display the message hello
all right when the user clicks on the
button
so for that let's say
let's just copy this
[Music]
in here
instead of demo
right we're going to be passing the IDE
click me
as per this and the event is going to be
on click event
so here I say on click
after which I'm going to Simply pass
user Dot message
let me just delete this
all right so here I notice that I've
given an equal to sign I'm sorry it's a
colon
all right so let's save the file
and
let's go ahead and execute it
all right so here you can see high crisp
being displayed and once we click on the
button
you can see an alert which says hello
all right
so now let's move on to the next concept
that is Java object accessors
now Getters and Setters allow defining
an object accessor all right to get the
value of a property in a JavaScript
object we use a getter and to set the
value of a property of a JavaScript
object we use a setup so let's go back
to our demo
and now let me create another file
and let's call it
object
accessors
and now again let me just
copy the first initial part
[Music]
all right so now let's go ahead and
create a new
object so let me say script
but in which I say red
and let's call it car all right
so let me define the properties say
model
and
model let's say BMW
320d
and
another property say color and let's say
it's navy blue
and the last property say fuel type
[Music]
and let's see it's diesel
now what we can do is we can you make
use of the keyword get
to access the properties so I say get
and say fuel
within which I return
this Dot fuel type
all right it's as simple as that
so now let's display it document Dot
get element by ID
[Music]
demo
dot inner HTML equals we say car
dot fuel
all right so now let's save it
and execute our file
here you go it retrieves diesel for us
now this is one of the ways of accessing
the properties
now to help you understand Setter let's
go ahead and create another
object
let's say where car again
now let's say the model
is
Audi A4
[Music]
color be bright
red
[Music]
and fuel type let's keep it blank
all right
now to set the value we use the set
keyword we say set fuel
the parameter is fuel
within which we say this dot you will
type
[Music]
equals fuel right
now let's set the value for the fuel
say car dot fuel
equals petrol
all right
now let's display the same
let me copy this
and what we want to display is the fuel
type right so here we say fuel type
so let's save this
and let's go ahead and execute the file
and there we go it retrieves petrol so
what it does is basically it assigns the
value petrol to the property fuel type
and then we display the same on our web
page
so this is how you make use of Getters
and Setters we're going to be learning
all about JavaScript this keyword
so without further delay let's Jump
Right In
so you must have heard about this
keyword several times so in JavaScript
this keyword basically refers to an
object which is executing the current
piece of code well in simple terms this
keyword basically just references the
object that is executing the current
function
now if the function that is being
referenced is a regular function then
this keyword preferences the global
object
all right I'm sure it must be a little
tricky at the moment but please hold on
and if the function that is being
referenced is a method in an object then
that this keyword references the object
itself
so to help you understand the concept
better and to clarify all your doubts
let's look at a simple demo
so here in vs code I've created a file
called this dot HTML all right you can
give it a name of your choice now here
let me first
Define a variable
and let's call the variable save
value and let's set it to say 50. all
right now let's go ahead and create a
simple function
so let me say function
my function
all right and within this let me Define
the value for Value let me set the value
for the variable value as 100.
okay
and now let me just alert that all right
so let me say alert
value
[Music]
okay plus value
and then let me have another alert
message
which is going to display this dot value
so let me just say this value
[Music]
and instead of just saying value I say
this dot value
all right now after this let's go ahead
and call the function
my function
so let me just save this and execute it
so here it says value equals 100
and then when you see this dot value it
says 50. so now here you can come back
to the code and see now when I just say
value it takes the value 100 all right
which is taken locally but when I say
this dot value since it is a normal
function its references to the global
variable which is here
this value
I hope this makes sense to you now
now moving on let's look at the behavior
of the this keyword within an object
method
so let me create an object here
before that let me just comment this out
say script
and now let's create an object so
let's say const
and then I give the name of my object as
random
and within this let me say name and
let's call it John
and then I create a method called info
okay and within this I display a console
message that says hi
my name is
and now I make use of this keyword I say
this dot name
all right and now let me just go ahead
and call this method so I say random
dot info
all right so let's save this and execute
it
so let me check my console
and there you go it says hi my name is
John so if you clearly observe here when
we say this dot name since it is being
used within a method that is defined in
Saturn object
it references to this property here
all right unlike this case where it
reference to the global variable that
was mentioned outside
so I hope this helped you understand the
difference between the two
now let's look at another simple example
so now let me just change the value of
name here
to say tutorial
and now let's define another property
which is basically an array so let me
just call the property video
within which I have an array let's say
JavaScript
another value
save this
and then let's say keyword
add in my info method I'm going to just
display these video tags so let me just
save this
hopefully let me just delete this first
and let's see this
dot video
now since it's an array we can make use
of for each
and now for each in turn takes a
callback function
and then I say
I'm going to call it
a tag
the parameter that's being passed within
which I just console log it
and say tag
all right so let me save it
and then execute this
now here you can see that the values in
the video property are displayed there
is Javascript this and keyword
now let's suppose that you want to
display the name along with every string
here right so naturally you would go
ahead and just say
this dot name
right it makes perfect sense
so let me just save and execute this now
if you see just the values of the
property video are displayed here
now the main reason for this is if you
closely observe that this function here
is mentioned within the Callback
function
right so when it is referencing it is
referencing to the global object which
is unclear which is undefined in this
case so to overcome this what we can do
is that the for each method takes in two
properties one is the function the other
one is the object so here we just pass
this
all right so what happens is it's going
to reference the current object That Is
Random so let me save this and then
execute it
and there you go
you can see that tutorial that is the
name has been displayed
all right I hope you understood the
concept of the this keyword it could be
a little tricky but as you work on it
you'll get the hang of it we're going to
learn all about JavaScript functions in
our previous videos we cover topics like
JavaScript arrays and loops if you're
new to this topic I suggest you go
through these topics before
all right so before jumping in let's go
ahead and look at what's in store for us
first we're going to learn what exactly
JavaScript functions are
then we'll look at JavaScript function
Expressions then the functional
Constructor self invoking functions
functions as values functions as objects
Arrow functions generate a function and
the predefined functions
also don't forget to subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update
moving on to our first topic what are
JavaScript functions
so basically a function is a group of
reusable code which can be called from
anywhere in your program right when you
have a piece of code that you want to
execute repeatedly in your entire
program it makes more sense to Define it
once and call it over and over right it
makes the code more efficient and
readable this also helps programmers
write modular codes
so this is the syntax you make use of
the function keyword followed by which
you mentioned the name of the function
the name of the function is completely
your choice next you mentioned the
parameter list and within curly braces
you can Define the function now the
function body is basically the code that
is executed every time the function is
called
so let's go to our vs code editor
and here I've created a folder called
demo functions within which I've created
an HTML file called functions.html
all right and now I've just typed in the
initial code
now let's create a function
so let me say script
within which I use the keyword that is
function keyword
and now I give the name for my function
I say my underscore function
and the function takes a parameter say
value now this function basically
Returns the square of the digit all
right so within which
I say
document dot get element by ID
foreign
and now it just displays value into
value
all right so the function basically
displays the square of the number
now outside the function let me call the
function
does
my function let me pass the value 5.
all right now let's save this and
execute it
so let me go back to my file
and here we go it displays the value 25
so this was a simple function which took
a value
a digit as a parameter and then returned
the square
moving on to the next concept function
expression
now what we learned previously was
function declaration but a function can
also be defined as an expression now
this is what the syntax looks like
now here the function is created and
assigned to the variable explicitly like
any other value the meaning Remains the
Same that is you create the function and
store the value that it returns into a
variable and in our case it's X right so
let's go to our vs code and let me help
you understand this better
so now
I create another function
[Music]
and here I say let
x equals let's use a simpler function so
I just mentioned function
and within curly braces I display an
alert message and I display a message
saying hello
all right
now
after that to display the message what
we can do is let me just copy this
output
code
if you paste it here
and here what we're going to be
displaying is the value X right now
since it consists of a function you'll
have to type the curly braces now this
is crucial for its execution all right
so let me save this and then execute
let me execute this
and here you go it says the site says
hello so we've successfully executed the
piece of code
we can also assign this variable X to
another variable and then call that
variable instead
right we can say let
Y equals X
and instead of calling X here
we can simply call Y
we save it and then let me refresh the
page
and there we go it's still displays a
message hello
all right so this is one of the ways of
defining a function that is as an
expression
moving on to our next concept function
Constructor
now JavaScript functions are defined
using the keyword function right now
functions can also be defined using a
JavaScript built-in function
now this is the basic syntax so here
we've created a function called my
function and we've used the keyword new
after which we've used the Constructor
function
and inside we provide the parameter list
after that the return value
next you can call the function here
right so let me just go back to my vs
code
and now let me just make changes to the
same piece of code here
I create a function say my underscore
function
okay all right let me just change the
name
to my function all right
and then here I use the keyword new
and the function Constructor that is
function
[Music]
within which I'm passing all the
parameters so I have
a b and I'm going to return the sum of
the digits
all right
and now while calling the function
let me just store the value in a
variable say X
and let's call the function that is my
function
with the parameters 2 and 3.
all right
and now let me just play it so I'm just
gonna copy this
and I want to display the value of x
right
all right so let me save this and
execute it
if you refresh the page it displays the
sum that is 5.
to make it more readable let me just
display another message here
let me just say
the sum is
all right
let me save it and then refresh the page
it says the sum is 5.
all right now this is how you make use
of the function Constructor
next up we learn about self invoking
functions
now as the name suggests these functions
are invoked automatically without being
called now previously when we learned
about function Expressions we saw that
parentheses were crucial
so you have to add parentheses around
the function to indicate that it is a
function expression so here is a Syntax
for you so what we've done is we've made
sure we've enclosed the entire function
within parentheses
so let me help you with that let's go
back to our vs code
and let me create another script
[Music]
and here let me create the function
within the parentheses and say function
it's not taking any parameters
instead it is going to
alert for message so let me say
hello welcome
right
after which
we're going to call the function so
again we have to mention the parentheses
let's save this
and execute
so when we refresh the page it says
hello welcome
so we never call the function rather it
got invoked by itself so these are
self-invoking functions
now let's go ahead and look at functions
as values
now in JavaScript a function is
basically a value so we can deal with it
as a value now here is a simple syntax
now if you closely look at the syntax
you might think that this is same as
function Expressions well no in this
case what we do is we first Define the
function and then we assign it to a
particular variable but in the case of
Expressions the function definition was
defined during the initialization of the
variable right and also we have to
specify the parenthesis in order to call
the function so to help you understand
this better let me go back to our vs
code and here
let me just erase this
and let's define a function that Returns
the product of two digits so let me just
call it product
[Music]
which takes two parameters let me say A
and B
within which we return the value
a into B
all right now after this let's create
another variable say y
equals function for I'm sorry the name
of the function is product so product of
2 and 5.
right so this basically returns us 10
right so let me just copy this to
display this on our web page
and here I change the message to the
product
and here let me change it to y
so let's save this and execute it
so let me refresh the page and here you
go you can see the message the product
is done
now what we can do is we can make
alterations to this now say I want to
multiply the value
with 5 again
right so basically this returns 10 and
that value is multiplied by 5. so let me
save this
and refresh our page and there we go it
returns
and there we go it displays 50. so this
is how you can make use of functions as
values
moving on to the next topic functions as
objects
now JavaScript functions are a special
type of objects called function objects
now a function includes a string which
holds the actual code that is the
function body of the function the code
is literally just a string although not
recommended you can also create a
function with the help of the function
Constructor I will show that you a
little later on but for now let's look
at the syntax
now here we have a variable called body
which basically consists of the function
body its enclosed in double quotes and
that's a mistake please ignore it all
right so next we have variable function
name so here we create a function using
the keyword new and then we pass the
parameter list and the body basically
tells us what the function returns all
right next we have an alert message to
call the function so let me just show
how this is executed
back in our vs code let me create
another
function
and let's say the function Returns the
area of a circle right so let me just
create
a body variable
which returns
so the area of a circle is pi R square
so we make use of math dot pi
into radius
into radius right
so it's basically Pi R square
after which
let's see where Circle
[Music]
and here let's create a function using
the new keyword
function
and then here we pass
the value that is the radius
and then the body
right so basically this is the
definition of our function
so let's use alert
to display the area so we say alert of
circle
or five
all right let me save this and execute
it
so when you refresh the page
it displays the area of the circle
so this is how you can use functions as
objects
moving on to our next concept Arrow
functions
now functions can be written more
compactly and more precisely with the
help of Arrow functions all right now
Arrow function expressions are
Illustrated as methods and they cannot
be used as Constructors
now also while using Arrow functions
using const is a safer option because a
function expression is always a constant
value
so this is the syntax now you can only
omit the return keyword within the curly
braces if the function is a single
statement
so this is the syntax first you provide
the name of the function
with an equal to sign followed by the
argument list and later you make use of
this Arrow icon and Define the
expression so this is basically nothing
but this
so let's go back to our vs code and
check for ourselves
so let's create another function
and here let me say
const
my funk
equals now say we want to display the
product of three digits so let me just
pass ABC as my parameters
and we make use of this icon which
indicates that this is an arrow function
within which I say return a into B into
C
all right
now let me just assign this to a
variable
okay let me say
product because we've used X here
and then let me call my function that is
my func and pass the value 2 3 and say
4. foreign
so let's display the product so let me
just copy this
code
and here let me say the product
of the three
digits is
and let me say product here because that
is what is being used here right all
right so let me save this and execute it
all right first it displays the area of
the circle all right and then we say
okay
and there we go it displays the message
the product of the three digits is 24.
so let me do one thing let me just
comment this out
okay
let me save it and then execute it again
it just displace this
all right so this is how we can make use
of Arrow functions
moving on let's look at the generator
function
now regular functions typically return
only one value right or a single value
or sometimes even nothing but a
generator function can return multiple
values
and the specialty is that it can do it
so on demand all right now to create a
generator function we make use of an
asterisk
so an asterisk indicates that the
function is a generator function
so here you can see that we have a
function followed by asterisks and we've
created a function called generator
sequence so here you can see we have the
asterisk after the keyword function
followed by the name of the function
right
but the main method of a generator
function is the next method when this
method is called it basically runs the
execution until the nearest yield value
all right all the nearest yield
statement then the function execution
pauses and the yielded value is returned
to the outer code
all right so the result of the next
method is always an object with two
properties it has a value property which
is basically the yielded value and then
it has a done property which displays
true if the function code is finished or
false if it's otherwise so let me show
its execution for a clearer
understanding so let's go back to our vs
code
and here let's create the generator
function
let's say function asterisk
generate
function all right
now within which
I make use of the keyword yield
and I say yield one first
followed by yield
and finally I make use of return which
indicates the termination so I say
return 3.
all right
now we make use of
a variable say generator
and assign it to the generator function
that is generate
funk
and now I create another variable say 1.
which will basically return the value
when I call the next function so here I
say generator
dot next
okay so whatever generator dot next
returns it's stored in one
so to display the message I say alert
and now I'm going to make use of a
method called Json Dot stringify
[Music]
all right so basically this method
converts a JavaScript object or a value
to a Json string
all right so within which I'm gonna say
one
that is this
all right
so now let me save this
and execute it
Let me refresh the page and there you go
here it returns
two properties that is value and done it
says value is one and done is false
right it is false because we haven't
reached the return statement yet
so what we can do is to display the rest
let me just copy these
and display it one by one
see there let's see this
and here let me say two
and this is three
let me copy this
[Music]
okay here I see
two
and then I say three
all right so let me save this and then
execute it
so when I refresh the page it says one
and false
after which again it says 2 and false
and finally when it displays three it
returns true for the done property that
means we've reached the end of the
function definition
so this is how you make use of a
generator function
now let's move on to our last topic that
is predefined functions
now JavaScript has many built-in
functions all right now here are a few
of them we have eval parseint pass float
escape and unescape now let's go through
one by one
all right first up is eval now this
basically evaluates a string and returns
a value all right so to help you
understand this better let me go back to
our vs code
and now let me just create another file
and let me call it redefined
functions.hdn all right
and I've just copied the initial code
all right so for eval the syntax is eval
within which
I see expression
all right now this is the general syntax
so what this eval does is that it
evaluates the expression and if the
result is not a string the result is
just returned and if the result is a
string it is taken to be a JavaScript
program and evaluated
so let me show you how it's done
so first let's create three variables
all right let's call them X
and initialize it to 5
then y
with six
and then let Z be seven all right
now let's just displace the result on
the console so let's say console.log
eval
or let me say X Plus y
all right after which I again say
console.log
okay then offset
here since the expression is a string
this gets evaluated and here since it's
not a string it just Returns the value Z
and here since it is not a string it
just Returns the value of Z so let me
save this and then execute it
all right so let me just
check our console
there you go it evaluated the expression
and added the two values that is X and Y
and returned 11. while Z is returned as
it is
all right this is what eval does
next up is parseint now as the name
suggests it passes a string argument and
returns an integer of the specified
Radix or base
and the syntax basically includes the
keyword parse and the string within
parenthesis
parse float on the other hand passes a
string argument and returns a floating
Point number again the syntax has the
keyword parse float along with the
string within parenthesis
next up is SK now this returns a
hexadecimal encoding of an argument
and on the other hand unescape Returns
the ASCII string for the specified value
we're going to learn all about
JavaScript form validation
so what exactly is form validation
now I'm sure you must have filled
several online forms right a simple
example would be a new registration for
a website now every time you miss out on
giving a particular detail or end up
giving faulty information the website
alerts you
so this process of ensuring that the
information provided is legit is called
form validation
now this generally happens on the server
side however JavaScript facilitates form
validation on the client computer before
sending it over to the server now there
are two functions performed one is the
basic validation which ensures that all
the mandatory fields are filled now this
is implemented with the help of a simple
Loop
and the other is a data format
validation now this checks the data for
its correctness
so to help you understand form
validation better let's look at a simple
demo
alright so back in my visual studio code
I've created a file called forms all
right it's an HTML file and I've typed
down the initial code
now the simple use case that I'm going
to show will include the validation of
the email and the password fields in a
form all right so for that let's go
ahead and first create a simple form
so here HTML allows the form tag so I
say form
within which I'm going to provide our
Fields so I say input
and then the name I'm going to be
providing is email
[Music]
all right and then I'll provide a
placeholder and call it email
um
and then the type of the input is going
to be text
all right and then let me just give a
free tag here
so now let me just copy the same thing
for my password as well
so here you go I say
password Here
and then the placeholder again will be
password
[Music]
and then I'm going to keep the type as
text
foreign
button right so let me say button
type is basically submit
all right and let me just please submit
on my button all right
okay so with the input this we've
created a simple form so let me show you
how this looks
so here we go we've successfully created
an email field a password field and a
submit button and every time I click on
the submit button you can see that my
page is getting refreshed
now once the user provides the correct
email ID and password we want to display
a message all right so for that I've
created another file called message.html
and this is a simple file where I'm
displaying the message hello there
welcome
all right so this is a simple message
that I want to display so for that I
have to add it in my form tag
now once the form gets submitted
an action has to be performed and the
action is to navigate to the
message.html file right so let me just
say action
[Music]
equals message dot HTML
now you can also provide a name to your
form so let me call it
[Music]
my form
all right
so let me just save this
all right so moving on we have to now
validate the information that is
provided for that I'm going to create a
function here
so let me call the function
validate
[Music]
all right
so here I'm going to check my Fields
right now if the email field is empty
then I'm going to alert the user saying
please enter the email
and if the password field is empty I'm
gonna again alert the user to provide
the password
so for that we're going to make use of
this simple if else logic so let me say
if
document
dot my form
[Music]
dot email
dot value is null
so I'm going to check if the value
provided on my email field in my form
is null all right
what I'm going to do is I'm going to say
alert
please
provide
your
email ID
okay
and then I'm going to say
document.myform
dot email dot Focus now what exactly
Focus does is that it makes sure that
the cursor remains at the email field
that is it is focused at the same field
all right
so let me just copy the same thing for
my password field
so let me say else if
let me just copy this
instead of email I say password
[Music]
within which I'm going to alert the user
to provide the password
[Music]
I'll say please provide
your password
all right
so basically it first checks for the
email field and then for the password
field so let me just say finally else
do nothing
all right
okay so now what we're going to do is
every time we click on the submit button
the form gets submitted correct now we
can control when the form is getting
submitted
so basically the form gets submitted
when this function is executed
so for that we can use another property
here
called on submit
and here I'm going to call my function
that is validate so let me say validate
here
all right so let me save this and let's
check the output
so here as you can see
let me just try submitting it without
providing the email field all right so
here we go it alerts us all right and
once I click on OK
it still displays the message hello
there welcome now that is not what we
want right so once the email field is
empty it should remain in the same page
and the form shouldn't get submitted but
here in our case it is getting submitted
so for that we're going to have to make
use of return values so what happens is
if my email field is empty then I'm
going to return a false
so here I see return false
and here as well
yeah
and finally when both my email and my
password fields are filled I'm going to
return true
all right
and same goes here
let me just say return validate instead
of just validate right
so
here we go
let me save this and now let's check the
output
so here let's first submit the form
without providing any information
all right so it says Please provide your
email ID when I click on OK observe that
the cursor remains at the email field
so here let me just give some random
value
and then let's try submitting it again
without providing the password
and it says Please provide your password
all right
okay now if You observe that the cursor
is remains at the email field so let me
just check my code once
here we go I haven't mentioned password
Here so let me change email to password
so let me just provide some random value
at my email field
and say submit
and when I get a message saying please
provide your password
and now you can see that the cursor is
at the password field right so let me
just give random information there
and then I say submit
and here we go the message hello there
welcome is displayed
so this was a simple demo on form
validation
so I really suggest you pause the video
here and then go through the code once
we're going to learn all about
JavaScript regular expressions
so now without further delay let's begin
so what exactly are regular Expressions
now a regular expression is basically a
sequence of characters now these
characters could be digits or the
letters of the alphabet and this
expression usually searches for a
particular pattern
now the user can basically Define what
has to be searched in a text all right
and these Expressions could be alphabet
or digits as I explained before
also one of the main reasons that we use
regular Expressions is put text search
and text replacement operations
so this is a general syntax you have a
pattern that needs to be checked and you
have a flag associated with it so
further on in the video I'll explain to
you what flags and patterns are but
before that let me give you a small
example of what a regular expression is
so I've made use of this website called
recxr.com I'll link it down in the
description box below
so this is the website now here let me
just show you a simple regular
expression now say we have a text that
says Apple
all right and now we have to search for
the letter A so what I do here now this
is going to be my expression so I first
provide a pattern right so I just say
capital a
so when I say capital A you can see that
the letter A has been matched in my text
all right so it's as simple as that now
one thing to remember is that here it is
case sensitive all right so if I say
the regular small a it does not get
matched all right so if I want to match
AP I can just say AP and it gets
highlighted here
all right so this is a simple regular
expression that matches with the text
so moving on
let's see what exactly these flags
patterns and quantifiers are
so what exactly is a flag so we
previously saw that the syntax consists
of a pattern and then a flag right so
these flags basically specify to alter
the behavior of a regular expression now
these flags are generally appended after
the regex literal and can be specified
as a second argument in your expression
right so let's see the different flags
that are supported by JavaScript
now you have these Five Flags here you
have G which is a global flag now this
file all matches instead of stopping
after the first all right then you have
I which is ignore case which makes the
entire expression case insensitive and
then you have M which is multi-line
so the carrot and the dollar match the
beginning and the end of each line
respectively then you have Unicode and
if this flag is not supported you must
match specific Unicode characters and
then finally you have Y which finds all
the consecutive or adjacent matches
so moving on we have patterns now these
patterns are basically brackets and are
used to find the range of characters now
again we have these patterns you have a
to z which finds all the characters from
A to Z in lower cases only then we have
0 to 9 which finds all the digits
between 0 to 9 and finally we have the
letters of the alphabet and the digits
separated by a pipe all right so this
basically finds any character be it an
alphabet or a digit
I hope this was clear to you so moving
on we have quantifiers now these
quantifiers Define the number of
occurrences of a particular string now
consider n to be a string so we have
three quantifiers here we have the plus
we have the asterisks and we have the
question mark So plus indicates one or
more occurrence of the character n
all right and the asterisk indicates
zero or more occurrences of the
character n while a question mark
indicates 0 or 1 occurrence of the
character n so now that you know Flags
patterns and quantifiers let me help you
understand them better with the help of
a demo
all right so here I have a simple text
which says welcome to this tutorial on
JavaScript this video teaches regular
expressions
now here when I search for a particular
word say let me search for the word this
okay so I say this
now ideally even this has to be
highlighted right however it does not
that is because as mentioned earlier it
is extremely case sensitive right so
what we can do is here we have Flags so
here I say case insensitive so once I
click on that both these words get
highlighted
all right so this was how you make use
of the I flag
now moving on let me help you understand
patterns now as mentioned you can have a
range of characters now just in case
here
[Music]
say I just make it case sensitive again
and here I would like to select all the
letters of the alphabet from A to Z
all right so when I do that you can
observe all the letters are highlighted
except the ones that are in the
uppercase
correct because that is not mentioned
here so here when I make it insensitive
you can see all of them get highlighted
so this is how you can make use of a
pattern
now to understand quantifiers let me use
a separate text all right let's have a
couple of A's and a few V's
now here when I say A you can see all
the characters a are being highlighted
right which is correct but when I use
the as tricks so here what happens is
you can observe all the Four A's are
considered to be a single unit what
Asterix does is that you can see here it
says matches 0 or more of the preceding
token now the preceding token is a and
matches 0 or more occurrences of the
character a
now same if I say B next to it you can
see all the characters B are matched
right
however you can check
the characters a in this particular text
are not highlighted
I'm sure you can understand why because
the expression that I'm looking for is
any occurrences of a
followed by the character B in this text
here there are no characters A and B
together correct so here you can say
that a is not highlighted but once I
given asterisks again what happens is
that the character a gets highlighted
what happens is that B can have 0 or
more occurrences so here there is a zero
occurrence of B so a gets highlighted so
this is how the asterisk quantifier
works
now one of the most important concepts
of using regular expressions are the
special characters so here we're gonna
indicate the special characters with the
backslash
so we have backslash W for example now
what w does is that it matches any word
character right so all the characters
here get matched
now it also has a counter character
which is the capital W all right so what
this does is that it does not match any
word so it matches everything that is
not a word including the periods
now let's see if you want to match
all the white spaces you can make use of
the character s here
all right and when you have the
uppercase s it matches any character
that is not a white space
now let's say you want to match
a digit you can just have backslash d so
let me just type in a few digits
and here you go all of them get matched
now let's say you want to have a range
of values that get matched right now
let's say I want to match just three
digits
so I can make use of curly braces and
within which I can mention three now
here you can see that it matches three
of the preceding token correct so the
preceding token is basically a digit so
it groups them in threes
so let me just add two other digits and
there we go
same goes with the matching of words so
here let me say w
so when I say 3 all of the characters
are grouped in threes all right now
let's say I want to group the words that
are three or four in number so here I
can just say
comma 4
all right now it gets matched
all right so now it gets grouped in
force so this is a simple example to
show you how special characters work in
a regular expression
moving on let's see how you can use
regular Expressions to search for phone
numbers
now here in my phone number
I'm going to have an area code so let's
say 0 is 0 followed by a new digit
number all right so let me give a random
number
all right so it's eight digits so some
people write a phone number like this
While others could write it something
like this you could have a hyphen in
between and then
any digit number all right now how are
you going to look for this text so what
we're gonna do is we're going to make
use of the special character that is for
a digit you make use of hyphen t and
first we're going to look for the area
code that is a three digit number right
so let me just say
three year and next we're gonna have an
optional hyphen so for that now since we
learned a pattern can be enclosed within
square brackets so let me just say
hyphen here and let me say a question
mark now a question mark indicates zero
or one occurrence of the preceding
character right so we're gonna have a
hyphen for a question mark and then
finally we're gonna have a digit again
and here the number of digits is eight
so let me just specify that
all right so when this happens you can
see both my numbers are getting
highlighted
although the text Remains the Same it
could be specified with different
formats right so just like this you can
create Expressions that match various
formats so this was just a simple video
to acquaint you with regular Expressions
we're going to be learning all about
JavaScript email validation let's begin
so first of all validation is an
essential part when you're communicating
with the user almost all the websites
and applications that you use have forms
that you need to fill in and every time
you fill a form that information you
provide needs to be validated
so this is an essential and a crucial
part now when you're providing more
critical information like user
credentials say your ID your password
your date of birth all of that needs to
be validated so JavaScript enables this
with the help of a feature called email
validation
now email validation first of all
ensures user authenticity it also
facilitates email validation on the
client side so that all the processing
that takes place on the server side is
faster
and lastly with JavaScript one can
validate a name password email date Etc
now I'm sure everybody has used email
IDs right so here's a dummy email ID for
you one thing that you must have noticed
is that all IDs come with an ad symbol
now the first part before the ads
character is the personal data now here
it could include your name you can
provide digits Etc so the length of this
personal information can be up to 64
degrees and following the at character
you have the domain name the domain name
can be up to 253 characters
talking about the personal data now this
data can include any sort of information
you can provide your name your birth
date Etc so basically it can consist of
all uppercase and lowercase letters of
the alphabet
it can have digits from zero to nine
you can include all special characters
and lastly it could include the period
character one thing to remember is that
the period character cannot occur twice
and is not supposed to be either the
first or the last character all right so
this was just a brief introduction to
email validation now to give you a
better understanding let's go ahead and
look at a simple demo
so back in our Visual Studio code I've
created a folder called JavaScript demo
and I've also created a file called
email validation
I've also typed in the initial code also
if you haven't watched our videos on
JavaScript regular expressions and
JavaScript form validation then I highly
recommend you go through them
email validation is basically just a
combination of the two so I'd suggest
you first head back and watch those
videos and come back here all right so
the first thing that we need to do is
create a form that includes the email
field right so for that let's go ahead
and create a form
here I'd say
form
within which add give input
let the ID be text
and I'll give the placeholder property
and let it be email
and the type
text
all right and then I will
break the line
and finally I have a button that's
basically the submit button right so let
me just say button
type
save button
and then the message displayed is submit
all right
so now when you're validating a form you
will have to provide certain cases that
is the if else conditions to validate it
correct now first I'm going to create a
function wherein I'm going to pass the
information typed in by the user as an
argument and this function consists of a
regular expression against which the ID
provided by the user is checked and if
the pattern matches it then the ID is
valid and if it is not then you'll have
to alert the user so now let's create
our function
let's see script
and now let me
create a function
called validate
all right
and now I'm going to create a variable
called mail
I'm going to get
the information provided by using this
ID from the input now I'm going to get
the text using this ID correct so let me
just say document dot get element by ID
within which
the name of the ID is text
let me say text Dot value all right
so the next thing is to create a regular
expression
now consider two different IDs here now
the domain of the first ID ends with.com
while the next one is ending with DOT Co
Dot N so when we're defining the regular
expression we'll consider all possible
scenarios so now let's head back to our
vs code
and here let me just see
variable reg X
beginning with a forward slash and then
you have
a carrot now the carrot symbol indicates
the beginning of the regular expression
now since we can have the lowercases
uppercases and all the digits
let's go ahead and mention them so here
let me say A to Z all lower cases then
we have uppercase
and we have all digits
0 to 9
followed by which we can also include a
period and an underscore so when you're
including a period symbol you will have
to use the Escape character that is
backslash
and then you mention the period now uh
one thing to remember is that a period
symbol in regular expression means that
it can include any of the characters but
here since we're using the literal
character that is the period we have to
include backslash after that we can
all right
followed by which we have a quantifier
that is plus now plus here indicates one
or more occurrences of all these
characters so here we include Plus
after which we have a literal that is
the X symbol
followed by which we have the domain
name so again the domain name can
include all the letters of the alphabet
and the digits
so for that let me save
A to Z
A to Z and 0 to 9.
again to remember we have to include the
plus symbol
indicating that it
let me just get rid of this
so we include the plus symbol to
indicate one or more occurrences of of
these characters
again followed by which we have a period
symbol
so for that let's just go and type in
Period now you must be wondering why I
didn't use the backslash
um now a backslash or an escape sequence
here can only be used within the squared
bases outside of it it is considered as
a literal
so here I just mentioned the period
again I highly recommend you go through
the JavaScript regular Expressions video
to clarify all your doubts
so moving on after this I have to
mention the extension that is.com or dot
Co Dot N
now generally these extensions are in
lower cases so for that let's just
go ahead and mention e to Z again
followed by a plus that is a quantifier
with an optional
dot again
followed by the letters a to z
again these can
again I mentioned Plus
followed by which I'm going to add the
question mark
now the question mark indicates 0 or 1
occurrence of the preceding expression
so in this case
this
extension that is dot in is optional now
the question mark here indicates either
a zero occurrence or one occurrence
all right
so uh to end the expression you have
the dollar symbol and then the front
slash
I might have missed something
okay yeah I haven't closed this so let
me just add the parenthesis all right
so this is your regular expression
against which we're going to be checking
the email ID right
so now we're going to use the simple if
else logic
so for that let's say if
reg X
dot text
dot mail
is basically what has been passed by the
user
all right now if this is true
that is if the mail went checked against
the regular expression comes in to be
true
then I'm going to alert the user
seeing you have
[Music]
provided
um
a valid email ID
and I'm going to return true
else
if the expression does not match
then I'm going to alert the user with a
message
saying sorry
incorrect
email ID
and I'm going to return a false
so now you must be wondering where is
the return value going so for that I
have to add the on click event on my
button
so here let me say on click
it's going to call the validate function
all right so there we go let me save
this and execute it
in my browser when I type in XYZ
gmail.com and when I click on submit
it alerts me saying you have provided a
valid email ID so to check the other
condition as well let's type in dot Co
dot in and submit
and again it says I will provide it a
valid email ID
now let's just add a period and an
underscore as well
so if I say x y z
Dot
a underscore b c
gmail.co.n and when I submit it it again
says it's a valid email ID
for a false case let's go ahead and
remove the ad symbol
and submit it it says sorry incorrect
email ID
or you can also go ahead and remove the
period here
I'm going to submit it it still says
that the ID is valid now here what
happens is that Gmail Co is taken as one
domain name with an extension dot in so
here this is valid
so this was a simple video to explain
email validation
I encourage you to play around with
regular expressions and also uh consider
all possible scenarios while you're
validating your ID in our previous few
topics we learned about arrays functions
in Loops however this time we are going
to take a step forward and then learn
about promises
now You Must Be Wondering Why JavaScript
promises even came into picture and what
exactly these promises are
so don't worry I've got your back in
today's video we're going to learn about
promises why they were introduced and
also I'll explain their functionality
so let's go ahead
first up why JavaScript promises
now JavaScript is predominantly single
threaded meaning
all processes contain the execution of
instructions in a single sequence so
basically in simple terms one command is
processed at a time now if a function
relies on the result of another function
it basically has to wait for the other
function to finish and return and until
then the current function remains idle
now this can be extremely frustrating
because a time consuming and very
restrictive I mean you're not using the
system to its full capability so to
overcome these drawbacks asynchronous
Concepts or asynchronous programming
came into picture
so in this case the main thread
continues its execution while JavaScript
allows long Network requests and other
tasks to happen simultaneously
now with the help of features like
callbacks promises and async await
asynchronous programming can be easily
achieved
I hope now you understood why promises
or asynchronous programming came into
picture
moving on what are JavaScript promises
now in the case of synchronous actions
you could instead of arranging for a
function to be called at some point in
the future return an object that
represents this future event
this is what the standard class promise
is for now the promise is basically an
asynchronous action that may complete at
some point in the future
and when it's completed it produces a
value
now it is able to notify when its value
is available
the easiest way to create a promise is
by calling the promise.resolve method
now this function ensures that the value
you give it is wrapped within a promise
now a problem is basically has three
states first up is the pending State now
this indicates that the underlying
operation has not yet been completed
next up is the fulfill State this
indicates that the promise has been
fulfilled with a particular value
lastly we have rejected now this
indicates that an error has occurred
during the operation and the promise is
rejected with the particular reason
Moving On A promise is said to be
settled when it is either fulfilled or
rejected
because remember promises are immutable
they cannot change the state so once
they're either fulfilled or rejected
they said to be settled
so when a promise is fulfilled it has to
do a particular job so for that we make
use of the then method now the then
method basically runs for a result and
this is used to attach a callback when
the promise has been resolved all right
same with the case of the scenario when
the promise is rejected it makes use of
a catch method which is used to attach a
callback when the promise has been
rejected don't worry you'll understand
the concepts better when we get to the
demo
so moving on let's look at a quick
flowchart to understand promises better
first up you have a new promise now the
promise is in the pending state
now this promise runs for an
asynchronous action now we check if the
action is successful if it is a yes then
we call the then method and if it is a
no then the catch method is called
and to end it if it is fulfilled then
the asynchronous action is performed and
if it is not that is if it is rejected
then error handling is performed
and lastly the values of these methods
is returned to the promise
I hope this was clear so moving ahead
let's look at the general syntax
you can use the LED keyword and provide
a name for your variable and then you
create a new promise now this promise
object takes a function which in turn
takes two parameters that is resolved
and reject
so to help you understand all of this
better let's go ahead and look at a
simple demo
so in vs code I've created a folder
called demo promises within which I've
created an HTML file named promises so I
have the initial code ready here
so let's begin typing our code
so let's say script
and here as I explained we say let and
let's give the name car
to our variable say car and we create a
new promise
all right so the promise object returns
a function which takes two parameters
called resolve
and reject
all right
So within the function
let's define
a simple use case now let's assume that
we're checking the car for its fuel all
right so we'll create variable called
fuel
underscore full tank
now let's set the variable to say true
all right
now let's set the variable to true
now this indicates that the fuel tank is
full
so now if the fuel tank is full
what I can do is I say resolve
all right
else I reject it
okay I hope you understood what I'm
doing here I'm just checking for the
fuel tank and if it is full which is
true then it gets resolved and if it is
false then it gets rejected
so if the promise gets resolved the then
method is called right so let me call it
here I say car dot then
now this runs a result right so it's a
callback function
which in which I say document dot right
the fuel
tank is full
happy driving
foreign
and if it is
rejected
I say dot catch
which also returns a function
[Music]
that says document
dot right
let's just display a simple message
saying that the fuel tank is not empty
[Music]
all right so let me save this and
execute it
so here it displays the message the fuel
tank is full happy driving
now that happens because we've set the
value to True here now in case we change
it to false
let's see what it displays
all right it displays the message the
fuel tank is not empty
so this was a simple example showing how
a promise works
now let's go ahead and understand nested
promises so for that let me just comment
this out
and now let's create a function that
returns promises so in our case what
we're going to do is first we'll check
for the fuel tank now in our case we're
taking a scenario where the fuel tank is
empty and the engine of the car is
overheating so as a result the car is
not safe for traveling all right so
let's go ahead and create these
functions
so I'll say let
empty underscore
tank
okay which returns
[Music]
a promise
So within which I say return
new promise
and the function takes two parameters
that is resolve
and reject
which in which I am going to display a
message saying resolve
it says the car
doesn't
have enough
fuel
all right
now let me just copy the same piece of
code
to check for the engine all right so let
me just change the name of our variable
here
let's call it engine
and here it displays the message
the engine is overheating
all right and lastly
when both of these scenarios hold true
that is the car doesn't have enough fuel
and the engine is overheating
we say that the car is not fit for
travel
let me just call it
and here
I'll display a message saying the car is
not safe for traveling
[Music]
all right
so right now we've created three
functions that returns promises
so first we check for the empty tank
right so let me just call the function
here
empty tank
and we make use of the then method
which is executed when the promise gets
resolved
which takes
a callback function
all right so basically when we check for
the empty tank
after this is executed we check for the
engine right so here we simply call the
engine function so let me just say
return
engine
all right
now this is a nested promise in itself
so on top of it I can run the then
method again
so if the tank is empty and if the
engine is overheating then I'll just
check if it is safe for traveling or not
so let me see
function
[Music]
and here let me just return
the method travel
all right
now after this
if all of these are executed then I say
function
finally I'll display a message
saying
same done
all right
so let's save this file and execute it
thank you
so here I go ahead and click on promises
let's go and check our console
and there we go the message done is
displayed
so here since every time the promise is
being resolved a message is displayed I
can basically catch the message in a
result
okay and this result can be passed to
the coming methods so here I just say
result
I see result again
[Music]
all right
so now we get the message the car
doesn't have enough fuel so we have to
append it with the next message so let
me just say message here
I've used MSG
[Music]
and let's just append it here
and the final message gets appended here
good result
okay I have to add message here as well
all right so let's save it and execute
the file
all right so here you can see the
message done gets displayed first and
then since we're appending it after the
message done it says the car doesn't
have enough fuel the engine is
overheating the car is not safe for
traveling
so this was how you can make use of
nested promises we're going to learn
JavaScript asynchronous concept that is
async and away
firstly let's understand the basic
concepts of synchronous and asynchronous
programming in case of synchronous
programming all the actions are
performed sequentially so you have the
execution of the function 1 after which
you have function 2 and then you have
function 3 and after all of these are
executed the program terminates now all
those synchronous programming is clean
and has lesser errors it has its own
drawbacks the entire system is halted
when a particular process is being
executed now as a result of which it is
time consuming and the system is not
used to its full capacity so to overcome
that asynchronous programming was
introduced now in this case let's assume
that a particular function or a process
is being executed now let's consider
that this particular function is waiting
for a resource let's say a network
resource now instead of waiting for the
function to acquire this resource the
main thread continues its execution with
function 2 and function 3 and when the
resource is acquired it receives a
callback indicating that the function 1
has to be called and finally the entire
chain is terminated so this is how
asynchronous programming works it makes
sure that the system does not halt when
a particular process is waiting for a
resource this makes the entire system
very efficient now that you know the
concepts of synchronous and asynchronous
programming let's move ahead now async
innovate a purely asynchronous
programming Concepts I again suggest you
check out the video on promises before
watching this
alright so moving on
what are JavaScript async functions that
is async and await now async animate are
built on promises the function is
basically accompanied by the keyword
async indicating that it returns a
promise within this function the away
keyword is applied to the promise that
is being returned and the await keyword
ensures that the function waits for the
promise to resolve now on the surface
the execution looks synchronous while
it's actually asynchronous now add the
place of usage of the weight keyword the
execution of the function is practically
blocked now async functions make the
code more readable and are easy to
handle when compared to promises now to
give you the general syntax you have the
async keyword associated with the
function name within which we have the
await keyword with a particular promise
now to help you understand the entire
concept better let's look at a demo now
I've created a file called acing await
in my visual studio code
so what we're going to be doing is that
we're going to have two functions that
help you check for the result now if you
pass this code as a parameter to these
functions which in turn return promises
telling if you have passed and will also
give you the grade that you scored all
right so let's go ahead and say let
let me call the variable result and
let's have a function
which takes the score as a parameter all
right
within which it returns a promise so I
saved return new promise now as you know
a promise basically has a function
which takes two parameters that is
resolved
and reject
now I just display a message saying
calculating
[Music]
results
all right now if my score is C above 50
I resolve it
by displaying a message saying
congratulations
[Music]
you have passed
all right and if it is less than 50
I reject it with the message saying you
have faith
all right so this is a very simple
promise that I created
so moving on let's create another
function that returns a promise so
basically this function will tell you
the grade that you've scored so say let
grid equals
function
now this takes response as a parameter
so let me just say response
now again let me just copy this
all right within which I'm going to
console log a message
saying
calculating your grade
[Music]
and we're just going to resolve the
promise with the message
your grade is a all right
and then we append the response
[Music]
now the first promise either results
saying that you've passed or it rejects
saying you failed and in case it gets
resolved then the next promise is
automatically resolved with the grade A
all right so moving on
let's call the functions so here let me
first call the function result so I say
result
and let me pass the value 80 since it
gets resolved and now I make use of the
dot then method
now here I catch the response
all right and then I just display a
message indicating
results received
okay
now what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna pass
the response to my next function that is
the grade function so what I say is I
say return
rate and the parameter is response so
let me just pass that now what exactly
happens is that the grade function also
returns a promise so on top of that I
can use the dot that method so I use the
then method
and let me just say final grade
[Music]
now within which I just displayed the
message
fine and green
all right now lastly we make use of the
catch method
in case of errors this catches the
errors
so let me just say error
and then
we'll console log it
[Music]
all right so this is the code let me
save this
and let's execute it to see its normal
execution so this is without using async
anyway all right
so let's go ahead and execute this
so here let me check the console
and there we go it says calculating
results results received calculating
your grade your grade is a and
congratulations you have passed so this
was basically without using async
innovate so now let me show you how you
can use async and await and how easier
the code becomes all right so what we
can do is let me just comment this out
all right now what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to call my function right so I'm
just going to make use of the async
keyword while calling it so I say async
function and let me call the function
calculate
results
okay
so now inside this method I'm going to
call the functions result and grade so
when I first called result the value
that is returned by result is going to
be stored in the variable response so
for that let me just say const
response
now I make use of the await keyword here
I say await
result
of 20 or in our case let me just say 80.
all right so what the away keyword does
is that the function result ceases to
execute until the promise is resolved
and whatever the promise returns gets
stored in the variable response all
right so now after this let me just
display a message
that says results
received
all right now next I'm gonna call the
other function that is great so again
I'm going to say constant and I'm going
to have to create another variable let
me call it final grade and it's the same
procedure I use the await keyword
and call the function grade
and I pass response as the argument all
right
and after this I'm gonna say console log
final grade
so it's as simple as that so first we
call the result function which returns a
promise which gets stored in the
variable response all right then we're
going to call the grid function and pass
to response as an argument
and the result of which is being stored
in final grade all right and lastly we
display final grade so now you must be
wondering if this executes what about
errors what if the value that I pass is
less than 50 right for that I'm going to
have to catch an error
so what I can do is that I can place
this entire code within the try block
all right so let me just say try
and now what I can do is I can catch
now if there is an error it gets caught
and then I display it
you say console log
error all right
and lastly let's call the function
calculate results
okay so let me save this and execute it
so all right here we go it displays the
same messages in the same sequence that
we saw before
so now to give you an example of
rejection so here let me just pass 20.
all right
let's save it
and there we go it says calculating
results you have failed so you can make
use of async in await instead of
complicating the entire piece of Code by
using promises react.js is a widely used
front-end development Library so if
you're just starting or wish to brush up
your Basics then you're in the right
place this video will cover all the
basic concepts of react.js first we look
at what react.js is
then we'll see how to install and set up
the react environment then we'll move on
to learn the fundamental concepts of
components
props and States lastly we'll conclude
the session by creating a simple
calculator app I'm sure you're excited
to learn so let's Dive Right In let's go
ahead and begin with what is react react
is a JavaScript library used to build
fast and interactive user interfaces for
both web and mobile applications now one
thing that makes react extremely
powerful is the fact that it's open
source any user can access its source
code modify it and enhance it in a
typical model view controller
architecture react defines the view part
of the application it is also
responsible for how the app looks and
feels fun fact react was built by Jordan
walkie an engineer at Facebook now let's
go ahead and see how react Works in real
time consider a typical web application
say Instagram the entire UI of the web
page is divided into several components
we have the search component a profile
description component stories component
and a post list component these
components make the code easier to debug
and always remain discreet components
also make development and maintenance of
web applications faster as multiple
developers can work simultaneously on
different components of the same web
application now let's see why react is
so popular these days the ACT helps in
creation of dynamic web applications it
also provides performance enhancements
now there are several performance
enhancements like virtual Dom and
one-way data binding we'll learn about
these topics a little later in the video
react uses reusable components now this
helps decrease the development time
react involves unidirectional flow of
data react also has a small learning
curve compared to other Frameworks like
angular react is much easier to learn
react can also be used for mobile
applications react recently release an
extension called react native that is
used for developing mobile applications
that are cross-compatible it also has
dedicated tools for easy debugging now
let's dive in to the features of react
first let's understand jss X jsx is a
syntax extension to JavaScript using jsx
we can add HTML to the Javascript file
all coding in react is done using jsx it
also helps in making the code easier to
understand and debug ultimately jsx is a
combination of JavaScript and HTML now
let's consider a small example cons
simple here is a JavaScript notation H1
tags indicate HTML again the semicolon
indicates JavaScript note that the
semicolon is not mandatory however it's
a good practice to include it moving on
the next feature is virtual dom dom dom
which is an acronym for data object
model actually defines how documents are
accessed and manipulated in a web page
it represents the entire structure of
the web page in the form of a tree
now let's see how this actually works
react creates a virtual Dom that is the
exact copy of the real Dom traditionally
whenever something changes in the web
application all objects in the real Dom
are updated this makes it extremely slow
let's see how react counters this now
consider two objects whose states have
been changed react now compares the
virtual Dom with the virtual Dom
snapshot that was taken right before the
update by comparing the new virtual Dom
with the pre-update version react
figures out exactly which virtual Dom
objects have changed now react only
updates those objects on the virtual Dom
this makes a big difference when it
comes to speed coming to the next
feature performance react uses virtual
Dom as discussed earlier virtual Dom
impacts the speed of the web
applications we also took an example of
Instagram and learned how multiple
components can affect the development
time they help improve performance
drastically the next feature is one-way
data binding this means information
Flows In Only One Direction One Way data
binding is specifically used when
information is displayed and not updated
remember that the components of react
are functional in nature that is they
receive information through arguments
and pass information via their return
values the next important feature is
extensions react has many extensions
that we can use to create full-fledged
front-end applications it provides
server-side rendering which means that
the application is rendered on the
server rather than in the browser react
native which is a react extension is
used for developing mobile applications
there are many other extensions that
react provides for every scenario in web
development now let's look at a few of
them react native lets you build mobile
applications using only JavaScript a
react native app is a real mobile
application and not just a web
application running on your mobile
devices thousands of applications like
Facebook Instagram Pinterest Skype use
react native the next popular react
extension as flux flux is the
application architecture that Facebook
uses flux implements a unidirectional
flow which makes it easier to understand
what actually is going on now let's see
how it works when we trigger an action
the dispatcher will get notified the
dispatcher receives actions and
dispatches them to the stores a store is
what holds the data of an application
stores will register with the
applications dispatcher so that they can
receive actions data from stores is
displayed in views actions define the
internal API of your application they
capture how anything might interact with
your application the last feature of
react is debugging react applications
are easy to debug thanks to the large
and active developer Community you can
practically debug react codes within
your browser now notice the small react
extension icon at the top right corner
this developer tool allows the user to
inspect the code and also easily debug
it moving on let's learn about the
building blocks of react components
state weight and props are the essential
Concepts that one should know before
implementing react they are the
foundation on which react is built now
what exactly are react components
components are the building blocks of
any react application react divides the
user interface into multiple components
wherein each component defines how a
particular element is viewed in the
application react components remain
discrete and are processed independently
another feature is reusability
components can be reused multiple times
across the application this reduces the
development time consider the following
code snippet a component is implemented
as a JavaScript class having some State
and a render method state is the data
which we want the component to render
the render method is responsible for how
the UI looks and feels to the user the
next concept is state state of a
component is an object that holds some
data this data influences the output of
a component every time the state of an
object changes the component is
re-rendered onto the screen now let's
see what props are props are short for
properties allow us to pass arguments or
data to components properties help make
confidence more Dynamic it is important
to Define all the properties their types
and their default value props are passed
to components in a way similar to that
of HTML tag attributes now consider the
following code Snippets this shows
exactly how properties are passed to
components also detailed illustrations
on components props and state will be
shown in the upcoming videos so stay
tuned for that moving on let's go
through some of the things that you
should know before you can actually
start working on react you should be
familiar with programming Concepts like
functions objects arrays and classes one
should also have a basic knowledge of
JavaScript and a familiarity with HTML
don't worry if you feel like you're not
good at them once you start working on
them you'll get a good hang of it
finally let's go through the the impact
of react on the IT industry and get
insights into the salaries of react
developers statistics show that react
developers earn way more than other web
developers according to pay scale the
average salary for a react developer in
the United States is a whopping 91 000
US Dollars the average salary for a
react developer in India is 7.25 lakhs
per annum over the recent years react
has gained immense popularity and is
being adopted by many companies
according to the data by Google Trends
Riyadh has had a better growth scale
compared to other Frameworks like
angular and view statistics show that
front-end developers have wholeheartedly
adopted this lightweight framework
foregoing other available options if you
are scared and have a knack for
front-end development react can help you
gain fantastic career opportunities
lastly talking about a few companies
that use reactive oceanally we have
Facebook Instagram Netflix Dropbox
WhatsApp among others in this video
we'll be learning all about react
installation on Windows to set up the
react development environment we need
two things installed node and a text
editor of your choice so let's begin by
installing node.js we can head to the
official node.js website say download
node.js so here you can see the windows
installer depending on your system you
can either download the 32-bit version
or the 64-bit version so I'm going to go
ahead and click on the 64-bit version
since it's already installed on my
system I'm not again installing node you
can follow the installation guidelines
and download it once you're done with
node installation you can go ahead and
download a text editor of your choice so
I'd suggest vs code so let's head to the
vs code page say download vs code click
on the first link and download the
64-bit version for Windows once you're
done with the installation of both node
and your text editor you can start
creating your first react application so
for that let's create a folder I'm
creating it on my desktop while you can
create it in any of your drives let's
call it first react now open your
command prompt now you can type in the
path for the folder that you just
created so say CD
users
first react now go ahead and type in the
command npm install
hyphen G create react app okay so this
command installs all the necessary
react.js modules now to check if the
version is correctly installed you can
type in create
react app version so you can see the
version here now let's continue and
develop your react application type in
the command create react app and you can
give a name to your application so I say
my app now this should take a couple of
minutes okay once you've successfully
created our application they say to
begin by typing the following commands
so let's do that save CD my app and npm
start this should typically start your
application and here we go all right you
can also open your application in the
text editor that you've downloaded so
let's go ahead and open vs code vs code
file open folder go to your desktop or
the drive that you've saved your folder
in first react my app and I say select
folder so as you can see all your
modules have been imported you can click
on app.js and start editing in this
video we'll be learning all about the
most basic infrastructure of react.js or
components so we'll be touching on
topics like what are components types of
components nesting components higher
order and pure components and a brief
description about component life cycle
alright to begin with what exactly are
components components are the building
blocks of a react application wherein
each component represents a part of the
user interface now to make it more
understandable consider the Facebook
home page the entire UI can be broken
down into several elements say we have
the credentials component the sign up
component the image component and the
logo component notice that each
component adds something to how the home
page looks alright reusability is one of
the Salient features of react components
one component can be reused several
times across the application and this
improves the development speed
components can also be nested one
component can internally consist of
several other components in its minimal
form a component must Define a render
method that specifies how exactly the
application looks and feels the
components can also receive properties
from its parent components also you'll
get a better understanding of all of
these when we start working Hands-On so
don't worry so so moving on let's look
at the different types of components
first we have the stateless functional
components and then we have the stateful
class components now functional
components are typical JavaScript
functions that return HTML now they can
be contained in a DOT JS or a DOT jsx
file coming to class components these
are regular es6 classes however it's
mandatory that they contain a render
method that in turn returns HTML they
can also be contained in dot JX or a DOT
jsx file okay then let's go ahead and
build our first react application using
components alright so I've opened my
text editor that is vs code to build my
application Also I suggest you watch the
react installation on Windows video to
help you get started the video briefly
explains how to install node and how to
start building your first react
application in my case I've opened a
folder called react component tutorial
and here in my source folder I have
app.js now app.js is the main component
that gets rendered to the term let me
show you that here in index.js you pass
app.js which is a component that gets
rendered to the react Dom so app.js
consists of several other components
that can be nested so as you can see
app.js is a functional component and
before moving on let me get rid of all
the unnecessary code so let me delete
all of this
and return an H1 tag that says hello
welcome to Sibley let me save it and if
you look at the browser you'll have
hello welcome to Simply learn now let's
go ahead and display another message say
H1 this video is about components let me
save it and let me check the browser it
gives you an error so jsx uses a
conventional rule which states that all
HTML tags have to be enclosed within a
div tag so for example I say div and I
enclose it so let me save and check my
browser again here you go so multiple
HTML tags have to be enclosed within the
div tag moving on let's create a first
functional component to do that I'll
first create a folder in my source
folder say components within that I'll
create a file say functional
component.js all right so the first
thing to do is import react so I say
import react from yeah the general
Syntax for a functional component
involves the keyword function and say
functional component now you say return
an H1 tag or I've already used H1 tags
so I'll say paragraph I say this is a
functional component all right before
explaining to you how these components
are exported and imported let me show
you the general Syntax for a class
component so I create another file say
class component dot JS I again import
react from react the general notation is
using the class keyword followed by the
name of the class extending from the
base class react.component so going
ahead I say class class component
extends react dot component now the key
feature of a class component is the
usage of a render method so I say render
within braces I say return a paragraph
tag saying this is the class component
so
so moving on let's see how these
components can be nested into the main
component that is app.js components can
be nested into the main component using
Import and Export keywords so as the
name suggests export feature is used to
export a particular file or a module and
import is used to import a particular
file or module into the current existing
module so we have two different types of
exports you have default export and just
export or named export so a default
export is used to export just one object
be it a function a class a variable from
the file and there can only be one
default export per file and when you're
importing it you can specify the address
and use the word import before it so let
me show you how it works let's go back
to our editor and then functional
component and here I say export default
and the name of the function component
that is functional com so let me save
this and going back to my app.js I say
import name of the functional component
that is functional com from and I pass
the path this components slash
functional component also let me get rid
of these unnecessary files here now
let's define functional component in our
app.js component so here I say
functional com let's compile it and
check our browser here it says this is a
functional component moving on to my
class component it's the same syntax
here as well let's say export default
name of my component and in my app.js I
import it import class comp From the
Path and again I'll have to Define it in
my return method I save so let me
compile it and check my browser it says
this is the class component one unique
feature of default export is that I can
rename the file while I'm importing it
so for example I can rename it as say FC
and while I'm defining it I'll have to
make sure I use the same naming
conventions so I say FC again and when I
check it it says this is the functional
component there's literally no
difference the next type of export is
the named export or just export so a
named export can be used to export
multiple objects be it functions class
Etc from a file now there can be several
named exports from a single file one
hack is that while you're importing it
cannot be renamed so let me show you how
this works okay so let's create another
class in our class component so I'll
just copy paste this let me give it
another name say class comp 1 and then
message that I want to display is hey
I'm another class all right so when I'm
exporting it I don't want default so let
me take it off and say export here all
right in my app.js while importing it I
want to import both the classes so I'll
include them within curly braces here I
say class com comma class comp one and
then again I Define it here class comp
one let's compile it and run it and here
we go here you can see hey I'm another
class so we've successfully exported
both the classes from the class
component and imported it back in our
app.js component one advantage of using
named export is the fact that I can
choose to import the classes that I want
to now say for example I do not want to
import class component here so let me
take it off and here let me comment us
now let's compile and see hey I'm
another class the second class got
imported while the first class I was
defined earlier is not imported here all
right so next up we have higher order
and pure competence now I won't get into
the nitty gritties of it because they're
Advanced topics but to give you a brief
Insight higher order components are
basically functions that take in a
component and return a new component the
whole ideology behind higher order
components is to facilitate the
reusability of component logic okay so
let's see how this works let's go back
to our code editor let's create a
component in our components folder let's
call the component
click dot JS all right so here we define
a class I use this snippet rce here we
go we get the entire format using the
small snippet rce and here I'm going to
make use of a button now see I use the
tab button and I'll say clicked one time
every time the user clicks on the button
the value gets incremented so for this
I'm going to use a variable say count
and I'm going to use the concept of
States so let's go ahead and Define our
variable count and initialize it to zero
so for that I'm going to use another
snippet called R const and here this dot
State equals my variable count
initializing it to 0. so let's define
the count variable in a render method so
I say const count equals this dot state
so every time we click on the button the
count value has to get incremented right
so we make use of an event called on
click closed captioning not available
[Music]
state DOT count plus one okay and here
we say count times all right so once
this is done let's import our component
in app.js so here again I say import
click from components clip and let's
define it here so let's check our
browser every time we click on the
button the value gets incremented all
right so let's go ahead and create
another component say counter.js wherein
every time the user hovers the mouse on
the button the count value increases so
let's go ahead and do that I say
counter dot JS I'm again going to use
the snippet rce to create a class
component and here in my div tag I
Define a button and say incremented to
for now I say x so now let's go ahead
and add the event save button on Mouse
enter I'm going to call the method this
dot increment count okay so once you're
done with that let's go ahead and Define
the increment count method I'm going to
copy the same code that I've mentioned
in my click.js so I say copy this all
right so one changes that I've changed
the name of the method and call it
increment count again let's define the
count in our render method so I say
const count equals this Dot
and here I change X to count now let's
go ahead and import it in our app.js so
I say import counter from
components and counter and let's define
it here all right let's save it and
let's run the code okay so as you can
see you see another button here
incremented to 0 and every time I move
my cursor on the button it increments
mind you I'm not clicking I'm just
hovering my mouse okay to learn how
higher order components work we'll have
to pass counter.js and click.js as
parameters to give birth to an entire
new component so for that let's go ahead
and create another component for our SOC
let's call it higher order dot JS okay
so I say import react from yeah after
that I say const updated component
equals original component that's going
to be an arrow function again and within
curly braces I Define my class that is
class say new component extends react
dot component inside let's define find a
render method that Returns the original
component with a modification that is I
want to type the user I want to append
the user before the actual message is
displayed all right so let's go ahead
and close the tag and return new
component and let's export this say
export default updated component now we
import higher order.js in our counter.js
and click.js and pass these components
as parameters so let's do that let's go
to our counter.js and here I say import
updated component from dot slash higher
order company and here while exporting I
say updated com and pass this as my
parameter let's do the same to click.js
here I import data.com from higher order
component and here I'll pass this as a
parameter now here in a higher order
component we've defined a property name
and initialized it to the user so we'll
have to include this in our other
components that's counter and click so
let's do that and here right before
incremented 2 I say this dot props dot
knee let me save it let me do the same
thing here and say this dot props dot
name so if you go back to our browser
here you can see it says the user click
zero times and the user incremented to
zero okay so this basically shows how
react Implements reusability of
components moving on our next topic is
pure components now another way to
create class component is by extending
pure component from react pure component
avoids unnecessary re-renders now how
does it do it it does not implement the
should component update method now you
learn about this method a little later
in the video now this method enables
re-rendering of components to the Dom
but a pure component on the other hand
ensures a shallow comparison of states
and props and checks if a re-render is
actually necessary only then does it
render to the Dom a react component can
be considered pure if it renders the
same output for the same state and props
so let's take an example to explain pure
components so let's go back to our vs
code and create two component classes
one for a regular component and the
other for a pure component Now using
this example I'll show you exactly how
pure component is more helpful okay so
let's create a pure component.js file I
say pure form
dot JS so here I'm going to use a
snippet rpce that is going to create a
pure component class let me get rid of
this export and here in my div tag I'll
display the text say I am the pure
component all right now let's go ahead
and create a regular component I may
call it regular component.js and here
I'm going to use the snippet rce and the
message that I want to display is I'm
the regular component so to draw a
comparison between the regular component
and the pr component let's create a
parent component for the two so let me
create one here I'll call it parent
component.js and this is again going to
be a regular class component and here I
display the message I am the parent
component to change the state of the
component we're going to make use of a
Constructor so let's use the snippet or
const and here let me create
name you can give anything and I say
simply learn now we make use of the
component did Mount lifecycle method to
set a time interval now don't worry
about this we're going to learn about it
a little later in the video so moving
ahead I'm going to make use of the
method and say component did Mount and
here I say set interval the first
argument is going to be an arrow
function and the second will be the time
interval and I'm going to be setting it
to 3 seconds now within the arrow
function I'll make use of the set State
function to set the state of my property
however I do not change the name I keep
it simply on itself moving on let's
import pure component and the regular
component into our parent component and
then pass name as a property so to do
that first import your com from your
component and then I say import regular
com from regular com.js and here let's
say regular com name equals this dot
state DOT name and I say pure component
name equals this dot state DOT me now
let's include the property name in both
our regular and pure components so to do
that let's just save this Dot
prop.name and here I again say this dot
prop dot name and finally let's import
parent component into our app.js
component so here I say import parent
come from okay and here let me Define
parent.com
so now if you look at the browser we
have I'm the parent I am regular
component simply learn and I'm the pure
component simply one we've got the
result as expected now to check if the
pure component is actually re-rendering
or not let's include simple console.log
statements so here I say CLG snippet and
here I say
pure component render and in my regular
component I do the same thing I say
control DOT log regular component render
now let's do the same in our parent
component as well here I'd say parent
component render all right so let's go
back to our browser and inspect it in
our console first the parent component
gets rendered then the regular component
and then the pure component after that
for every three seconds only the pairing
component and the regular component is
rendered for the same state and prop the
pure component is not re-rendered so in
conclusion pure components optimize
react codes and also improves
performance so coming to the last topic
component life cycle so basically
component life cycle explains the stages
the component goes through the entire
life cycle of a component can be divided
into three parts we have mounting
updation and unmounting so the first
thing that gets invoked in the life
cycle is component will mount it is
invoked right before the initial
rendering occurs then we have the
rendering method now once a component is
inserted into the Dom component did
Mount gets involved coming to the next
phase we have updation when a complaint
receives props component will receive
props gets invoked set state is called
when the state of the property changes
so every time there is a change react
decides whether the next component State
Should trigger a re-render or not to do
that should component update method is
called component will update is invoked
right before re-rendering after
re-rendering component did update is
called that makes updates to the Dom and
the last phase is unmounted component
will unmount method does all the
necessary cleanup and erases all the
allocated memory and Cycles moving ahead
let's learn about another striking
feature of react.js called props props
short for properties allow the user to
pass arguments or data to components a
pairing component can pass additional
information to its children using props
properties help make components more
Dynamic props are passed to components
in the ways similar to that of HTML
track attributes now we'll look at this
a little later in the video props in a
component are read only and cannot be
changed one thing to remember is that
drops are sent by the parent to the
children components hence the children
components cannot make any changes to
these props now that we've learned about
props in brief let's go ahead and create
our application using props if you're
new to this tutorial I suggest you go to
the react installation and react
competence video on our channel so back
in my code editor that is vs code I've
opened a folder called react props and
now I'm going to create a component a
class component and I'll call it class
props dot JS so let's create the class
component I give rce the snippet and
here I display a message saying an H1
tag basically
[Music]
all right
now let me get rid of export here and
import it in my app.js main component
here I say import
class props
all right now we Define the class
component in our render method
[Music]
all right
now if we go back to the browser you see
Hello Learners welcome to Simply
learning now let's say we want to
individually welcome every student
instead of retyping the message for
everybody we can pass their names as
props now let's see how to do that now
we pass the name as a property from the
main component that is app.js to the
child component and render this onto the
browser so let's do that so here while
I'm defining my child component I say
name
I save it and here in my child component
instead of learners
I say I use a keyword this
dot crops dot name
let me save it and if you look at the
browser we'll have hello learner1
welcome to Simply run now let's go ahead
and welcome learner 2 and learner3 so I
again say class props name equals
learner 2.
all right so if we save and look at the
browser we'll have all the three
Learners displayed on the browser we can
also pass multiple props to the child
component now say for example we want to
welcome the student from a particular
place so we say welcome learner1 from
Place X so I can hear Define another
property say place
and say place
similarly I can do it for the rest too
take place y
now let's go back to our class props.js
component and here say hello learner one
from this dot props dot place
let me save it and if you look at the
browser now we have hello learner one
from Place X Place Y and play Z we can
also display whatever we want between
the opening and closing tags when
invoking a component now this is
facilitated using props.children
reserved keyword now let me explain to
you how it's done with an example here
let's split the self and closing tag
into
an opening and a closing tag and in
between them let me display a message
within the paragraph tag let me say
and in my child component after my H1
tag
let me use a paragraph tag and here
let's use the reserved keyword this dot
props top children
so let's save it
and now if you look at the browser you
can here see the message displayed child
component so prop stop children can be
used when components do not know about
their children ahead of time this is
commonly seen in components like sidebar
and dialog that represent generic boxes
so let's go ahead and create a button
tag and check again so here I'll split
it and add a button tag
and say click
and let's check our browser
here we go we get the output as expected
all right we saw the usage of props for
class components similarly we can use it
for functional components so let's go
ahead and create a functional component
let me call it
I say import react from
react
and then I say function
function props
and here I return an H3 tag
I'll say this is functional component
and I'll return another H3 tag saying
hello learner
so let me save this
and let's export it export default
function props
and import it in our app.js again import
function problem
[Music]
and here in our render method let's
define it
let me call function prop
name
let me give learner 4.
and
place
say a
let me close it and back in a functional
component instead of learner I save
props dot name
let me save it
now if you look at our browser it gives
us an error it says props is not defined
so let's go back to our code editor and
pass props here
to a functional component also let me
Define hello props.name
from
props dot place
let me enclose it within the div tag
here
[Music]
let me save it and now if you look at a
browser here we go we get the output as
expected let's begin and learn what
exactly is a state in react typically a
state is an object that stores the
values of properties belonging to a
component now these values can change
over a period of time either via user
interactions or network changes and the
state helps facilitate this
functionality every time the state
changes react re-renders the component
to the browser the state is initialized
in the Constructor a state can also
store multiple properties a method
called set state is used to update the
value of the state object now this
function performs a shallow merge on the
new and the previous state
conventionally a shallow merge ensures
that the previous state values are
overwritten by the new state values
moving on in our previous video we
learned about props and although props
and state dictate and control the
behavior of a continent they have
significant differences so let's go
ahead and draw a comparison between the
two firstly props in a component are
used to pass data and event handlers to
its children while State on the other
hand is used to store the data that has
to be rendered on the web page props are
immutable once said by the parent they
cannot be changed State holds volatile
data and can be changed over time props
can be used in functional and class
components while state is restricted to
class components props are set by the
parent component while a state is
generally updated by event handlers now
that we've learned all about State let's
go ahead and build an application to see
the working of State alright so in my
code editor that is vs code I've created
my application say State and here in my
source folder I have my app.js file now
here I'm going to get rid of all the
unnecessary code that I'm not going to
be using Also I suggest you go through
the react installation on Windows video
to help you get started with creating
your first application so let's create
our class component say class app
extends react dot component length
inside I have a random method that
returns an HTML tag let's display a
message welcome
let's follow the jsx conventions and
enclose all the HTML tags within the div
tag so I save div
class name equals app we also have to
import the app.css file import
app.css and so we save it and if you
look at the browser we have welcome now
let's beautify our code to do that let's
add some styling so here in my app.js
class component I say Styles equals
and I say font style and I set it to say
bold and I save color save teal and here
in my H1 tag I say style equals this dot
Styles so let me save it and if you look
at the browser now we have welcome in
teal and it's bold now let's go ahead
and create a class component to
understand state so first I create a
folder and I call it components and
inside this folder I create a class
component and I call it newcomp dot JS
and I use the snippet rce to create the
class component to give you an insight
into what we're doing today we'll
display a message asking the user to
subscribe to Simply learn once the user
clicks on the Subscribe button we
instruct them to click on the Bell icon
and finally we display a thank you
message now to do all of this we're
going to make use of state and as
mentioned earlier we initialize the
state of object in a Constructor so
let's use the snippet R const to create
a Constructor now in the state object we
initialize a property let's call it
message and we display a message saying
subscribe to Simply learn that's let's
save it and here in our render method
let's say class name equals app and
let's create an H3 tag and within the
tag I display the message so I save this
dot state DOT message let's save it and
now let's import it in our app.js
component so I'll get rid of export here
and here I say
import new com from components and new
account let's define it here and say new
so we save it and look at the browser it
says subscribe to Central on all right
again to make our code look more
presentable let's add in Styles so I'll
just copy the same styles that I've
added here and I'll paste them here and
instead of bold I make it italic and I
change the color to say purple and again
in my H3 tag I Define style and
initialize it with this dot Styles so
let me save it and now if you look at
the browser it's in italic and it's in
purple
okay so moving ahead let's create a
button that reads subscribe and once the
user clicks on it the button should read
subscribed and the message displayed
above should instruct the user to click
on the Bell icon to do that let's first
create a button the message that I want
the button to read is subscribe however
this message gets changed once the user
clicks on the button so instead of
explicitly mentioning subscribe here I
create a prop I say sub and I say
subscribe here and back in my render
method I say this dot state DOT sub so
let's save it and if you look at the
browser now you have a button which
displays a message subscribe now once
the user clicks on the button the
message displayed should change to click
on the Bell icon to never miss an update
so let's create an event handler for
that so here button on click I call
another method and let's call the method
button change okay so this method should
update the state and change the message
and sub values to do that we make use of
a set State method now our state can be
updated in response to event handlers
server responses or prop changes now all
the updation can be done using the set
State method now this is the general
syntax used by the method we'll however
look at this further in the demo now the
set State method conventionally enques
all the updates made to the component
State and instructs react to re-render
the component and its children with the
updated State now let's go back to our
code editor and look at the working of
this method now here I Define the arrow
function button change if you are not
familiar with arrow functions I suggest
you read up on them and this is the
general syntax and here I say this dot
set State and inside I change my message
to hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update and myself sub-value changes to
subscribed let's save this and now if
you look at the browser when we click on
the Subscribe button the message changes
to hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update so moving ahead let's use a Bell
icon so that the user can click on it
once he clicks on the image the image
changes and a thank you message appears
on the screen so for that I have two
images I have Bell a and Bell B so I
drag and drop both the images in my
components folder alright now let's
import these images into our newcom.js
file here I say import Bell a from Bell
a DOT PNG and again I say import Bell B
from Bell B dot PNG all right let me
save it to display the image on the
screen we make use of the image tag now
this tag has two attributes one is the
source attribute that specifies the URL
and the other is the alt attribute that
specifies an alternate text for the
image so here in my component I say I
make use of a paragraph tag that will
help display the image in the next line
and then I use the image tag now since
my image changes once it's clicked I
have to define a property and pass the
event handler click that will update the
image so here before specifying The
Source let's go back to our state and
Define another
property that is image URL and let's set
it to Bell a since that is the image
that I want to display first and you
save it and here in my image tag I say
Source equals this dot state DOT image
URL and then we have the alt tag and I
do not want to display any message so I
leave it as it is now let's save it and
if we look at the browser we have a bell
displayed however now let's change the
dimensions of the bell I do not want
such a huge bell so back in my vs code I
Define style with width say 30 pixels
and a height with again 30 pixels let me
save this and now if you look at the
browser we have a smaller icon so once
the user clicks on this image the image
changes and the message displayed here
gets updated to do that we'll have to
Define an event so let's go back to our
vs code and here in my image tag let's
say on click okay and Define a method
say this dot image change and now we
Define this method here as the image
change I make use of an arrow function
again and again I use the set State
method I update the image so I say image
URL is now set to Bell B and the message
is updated to thank you happy learning
so let's save this now and if we look at
the browser we see the image and once
clicked on it the image gets updated and
the message changes so finally Let me
refresh the browser once and show the
full execution Let me refresh following
the instructions let's click on the
Subscribe button and now it says hit the
Bell icon and once I do that the image
updates and the message changes in this
session we're gonna cover the topic of
what is angular
sure all of you use mobile and web
applications
from social media to healthcare
e-commerce and net banking these apps
are used by billions of people across
the globe low now the main reason we use
these apps is that they offer seamless
user experience and interface
how they developed to provide such
reliability one of the Frameworks that
is widely used to build such robust apps
is angular so let's dive into the
session now so here is a list of topics
that we're going to be covering first up
we'll see why angular was introduced
then what is angular
features of angular
angular architecture advantages and
limitations of angular
the learning curve of angular and
finally we look at some of the companies
that deploy angular so without further
delay let's begin
why angular now JavaScript is the most
commonly used client-side scripting
language it is written into HTML
documents enabling interactions with web
pages in many unique ways
so as a relatively easy to learn
language with almost pervasive support
it is exceptionally well suited to
develop modern applications but the
question arises
is Javascript ideal for developing
single page applications that require
modularity testability and other
features perhaps not however we have a
variety of Frameworks and libraries
designed to help us with such thing with
respect to front-end development angular
and JavaScript together bring in
structure and consistency to your web
applications and also provide
scalability and maintainability
and angular is specifically developed
for single page applications so now the
question arises what exactly is angular
angle angular is an open source
JavaScript framework written completely
in typescript
now it was primarily aimed to develop
single page applications and is
maintained by Google
angular as a framework provides a few
advantages while also providing a
standard structure for Developers
designed for web desktop and mobile
platforms if you have a doubt here as to
what exactly single page applications
are let me help you with that now these
single page applications are basically
applications that get loaded just once
so the main page gets loaded onto your
browser so any further interactions does
not lead to loading of subsequent Pages
anything that has to be done further is
just an addition to the already loaded
page these single page applications are
primarily developed using angular moving
ahead let's look at the features of
angular
we have four features that we're going
to be discussing we have the document
object model type script data binding
and testing now let's look at them one
by one now the document object model
treats an XML or an HTML document as a
tree structure now here every node in
the tree structure defines an object
representing a part of your document
angular uses the regular Dom now let's
suppose you've made 10 updates on a
single HTML page so every time you make
a change the corresponding Dom or the
tree structure needs to be updated
angular of this entire tree structure of
HTML tags moving on to our next feature
we have typescript
now typescript defines a set of types to
JavaScript which helps you write
JavaScript that is easier to understand
now all the typescript code compiles
down to basic JavaScript that can run
smoothly on any platform now typescript
is a mandatory for developing an angular
application but it is highly recommended
the main reason is highly recommended is
that it offers better syntactic
structure while making the code base
easier to understand and maintain now
typescript can be installed as an npm
package now to do that you just have to
run the command in PM install hyphen G
type script on your command prompt now
next up is data binding now data binding
is a process that allows you to
manipulate web page elements using the
web browser now it mainly employs
Dynamic HTML and does not require
complex scripting or programming
it is used in web pages that include
interactive components like calculators
tutorials Games Etc now incremental
display of a web page makes data binding
extremely convenient when Pages contain
a large amount of data when it comes to
angular it uses two-way data binding so
any changes meet in the UI element is
reflected in the corresponding model
state
and conversely any changes made in the
model state are reflected onto the UI
State this allows the framework to
connect to Tom to the model data via the
controller the last feature we're
discussing is testing
angular uses Jasmine to run its various
tests the Jasmine framework allows
various functionalities to write
different kinds of test cases karma is a
task runner for the tests that use a
configuration file to set the startup
reporters and testing framework so with
that we've covered the features of
angular
so let's go ahead and understand
the architecture of angular
angular is a full-fledged MVC framework
it provides a strong opinion on how the
application should be structured and
offers bi-directional data flow and
updates the real Dom MEC short for model
view controller is an architectural
pattern that separates the application
layer into model view and controller the
model here relates to all the data
related logic view on the other hand is
used for UI logic of the application
and controller is the brain of the setup
now it is an interface between the model
and view
moving on let's look at the advantages
of angular
first up we have custom components
angular allows you to build
functionality along with your rendering
logic into reusable pieces
data binding as discussed angular allows
you to effortlessly move your data from
your JavaScript code to The View